hello everyone welcome to this
interesting video on aws and azure full
course for 2022
as we all know how cloud computing
services are transforming and how
businesses and government agencies use
this technology
cloud services are now available to
satisfy almost any id requirement and
some of these are aws and azure
so in this video we will explore various
important aspects revolving around aws
and azure and its related concepts in
depth
but before diving deep into their
concepts we will first cover the basics
starting with aws
first
we will have an introduction to aws in
aws tutorial
followed by exploring some of the very
important services provided by aws
like aws ec2
aws s3 aws iam
aws cloud formation
aws route 53 and then we will understand
aws elastic beam stock aws vpc aws sage
maker
aws cloudtrans
aws auto scaling
followed by aws redshift and aws els
and at the end we will have a quick
comparison between ews and azure
then we will skip to azure and its
services starting with the basics of
azure in azure tutorial then we will
move to azure machine learning and
understand its functioning
then we will look into azure active
directory as your virtual machine
and at the end azure virtual network
with proper hands-on demonstrations
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your aws and azure related
concepts would have been cleared
so for this training with me i have our
experience aws and azure specialist
sam and rahul together we'll walk you
through the different crucial aws and
azure keynotes
so let's start with an exciting video on
ews and azure full course of 2022
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon and never miss an update
from simply learn
meet rob he runs an online shopping
portal the portal started with a modest
number of users but has recently been
seeing a surge in the number of visitors
on black friday and other holidays the
portal saw so many visitors that the
servers were unable to handle the
traffic and crashed
is there a way to improve performance
without having to invest in a new server
wondered rob
a way to upscale or downscale capacity
depending on the number of users
visiting the website at any given point
well there is amazon web services one of
the leaders in the cloud computing
market
before we see how aws can solve rob's
problem let's have a look at how aws
reach the position it is at now
aws was first introduced in 2002 as a
means to provide tools and services to
developers to incorporate features of
amazon.com to their website
in 2006 its first cloud services
offering was introduced
in 2016 aws surpassed its 10 billion
revenue target
and now aws offers more than 100 cloud
services that span a wide range of
domains thanks to this the aws cloud
service platform is now used by more
than 45 of the global market
now let's talk about what is aws
aws or amazon web service is a secure
cloud computing platform that provides
computing power database networking
content storage and much more
the platform also works with a
pay-as-you-go pricing model which means
you only pay for how much of the
services offered by aws you use
some of the other advantages of aws are
security aws provides a secure and
durable platform that offers end-to-end
privacy and security
experience you can benefit from the
infrastructure management practices born
from amazon's years of experience
flexible it allows users to select the
os language database and other services
easy to use users can host applications
quickly and securely
scalable depending on user requirements
applications can be scaled up or down
aws provides a wide range of services
across various domains
what if rob wanted to create an
application for his online portal aws
provides compute services that can
support the app development process from
start to finish
from developing deploying running to
scaling the application up or down based
on the requirements
the popular services include ec2 aws
lambda amazon light cell and elastic
bean stock for storing website data rob
could use aws storage services that
would enable him to store access govern
and analyze data to ensure that costs
are reduced agility is improved and
innovation accelerated
popular services within this domain
include amazon s3 ebs s3 glacier and
elastic file storage
rob can also store the user data in a
database with aw services which he can
then optimize and manage
popular services in this domain include
amazon rds dynamodb and redshift
if rob's businesses took off and he
wanted to separate his cloud
infrastructure or scale up his work
requests and much more he would be able
to do so with the networking services
provided by aws
some of the popular networking services
include amazon vpc amazon route 53 and
elastic load balancing
other domains that aws provide services
in are analytics blockchain containers
machine learning internet of things and
so on
and there you go
that's aws for you in a nutshell now
before we're done let's have a look at a
quiz
which of these services are incorrectly
matched one
two
three
four
we'll be pinning the question in the
comment section comment below with your
answer and stand a chance to win an
amazon voucher
several companies around the world have
found great success with aws companies
like netflix twitch linkedin facebook
and bbc have taken advantage of the
services offered by aws to improve their
business efficiency
and thanks to their widespread usage aws
professionals are in high demand
they're highly paid and earn up to more
than 127 000 per annum once you're aws
certified you could be one of them too
let me start the session with this
scenario let's imagine how life would
have been without spotify for those who
are hearing about spotify for the first
time spotify is an online music service
offering and it offers instant access to
over 16 million licensed songs spotify
now uses aws cloud to store the data and
share it with their customers but prior
to aws they had some issues imagine
using spotify before aws let's talk
about that back then users were often
getting errors because spotify could not
keep up with the increased demand for
storage every new day and that led to
users getting upset and users cancelling
the subscription the problem spotify was
facing at that time was their users were
present globally and were accessing it
from everywhere and they had different
latency in their applications and
spotify had a demanding situation where
they need to frequently catalog the
songs released yesterday today and in
the future and this was changing every
new day and the songs coming in rate was
about 20 000 a day and back then they
could not keep up with this requirement
and needless to say they were badly
looking for a way to solve this problem
and that's when they got introduced to
aws and it was a perfect fit and match
for their problem aws offered at
dynamically increasing storage and
that's what they needed aws also offered
tools and techniques like storage
lifecycle management and trusted advisor
to properly utilize the resource so we
always get the best out of the resource
used aws addressed their concerns about
easily being able to scale yes you can
scale the aws environment very easily
how easily one might ask it's just a few
button clicks and aws solved spotify's
problem let's talk about how it can help
you with your organization's problem
let's talk about what is aws first and
then let's bleed into how aws became so
successful and the different types of
services that aws provides and what's
the future of cloud and aws in specific
let's talk about that and finally we'll
talk about a use case where you will see
how easy it is to create a web
application with aws all right let's
talk about what is aws aws or amazon web
services is a secure cloud service
platform it is also pay as you go type
billing model where there is no upfront
or capital costs we'll talk about how
soon the service will be available well
the service will be available in a
matter of seconds with aws you can also
do identity and access management that
is authenticating and authorizing a user
or a program on the fly and almost all
the services are available on demand and
most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak amazon
offers 100 plus services and this list
is growing every new week now that would
make you wonder how aws became so
successful of course it's their
customers let's talk about the list of
well-known companies that has their idea
environment in aws adobe adobe uses aws
to provide multi-terabyte operating
environments for its customers by
integrating its system with aws cloud
adobe can focus on deploying and
operating its own software instead of
trying to you know deploy and manage the
infrastructure airbnb is another company
it's an community marketplace that
allows property owners and travelers to
connect each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and the airbnb community users
activities are conducted on the website
and through iphones and android
applications airbnb has a huge
infrastructure in aws and they're almost
using all the services in aws and are
getting benefited from it another
example would be autodesk autodesk
develops software for engineering
designing and entertainment industries
using services like amazon rds or
rational database service and amazon s3
or amazon simple storage servers
autodesk can focus on deploying or
developing its machine learning tools
instead of spending that time on
managing the infrastructure aol or
american online uses aws and using aws
they have been able to close data
centers and decommission about 14 000
in-house and co-located servers and move
mission critical workload to the cloud
and extend its global reach and save
millions of dollars on energy resources
bitdefender is an internet security
software firm and their portfolio of
softwares include antivirus and
anti-spyware products bitdefender uses
ec2 and they're currently running few
hundred instances that handle about five
terabytes of data and they also use
elastic load balancer to load balance
the connection coming in to those
instances across availability zones and
they provide seamless global delivery of
servers because of that the bmw group it
uses aws for its new connected car
application that collects sensor data
from bmw 7 series cars to give drivers
dynamically updated map information
canon's office imaging products division
benefits from faster deployment times
lower cost and global reach by using aws
to deliver cloud-based services such as
mobile print the office imaging products
division uses aws such as amazon s3 and
amazon route 53 amazon cloudfront and
amazon im for their testing development
and production services comcast it's the
world's largest cable company and the
leading provider of internet service in
the united states comcast uses aws in a
hybrid environment out of all the other
cloud providers comcast chose aws for
its flexibility and scalable hybrid
infrastructure docker is a company
that's helping redefine the way
developers build ship and run
applications this company focuses on
making use of containers for this
purpose and in aws the service called
the amazon ec2 container service is
helping them achieve it the esa or
european space agency although much of
esa's work is done by satellites some of
the programs data storage and computing
infrastructure is built on amazon web
services esa chose aws because of its
economical pay as ego system as well as
its quick startup time the guardian
newspaper uses aws and it uses a wide
range of aws services including amazon
kinesis amazon redshift that power an
analytic dashboard which editors use to
see how stories are trending in real
time financial times ft is one of the
world's largest leading business news
organization and they used amazon
redshift to perform their analysis a
funny thing happened amazon redshirt
performed so quickly that some analysis
thought it was malfunctioning they were
used to running queries overnight and
they found that the results were indeed
correct just as much faster by using
amazon redshift fd is supporting the
same business functions with costs that
are 80 percentage lower than what was
before general electric ge is at the
moment as we speak migrating more than
9000 workloads including 300 desperate
erp systems to aws while reducing its
data center footprint from 34 to 4 over
the next three years similarly howard
medical school htc imdb mcdonald's nasa
kellogg's and lot more are using the
services amazon provides and are getting
benefited from it and this huge success
and customer portfolio is just the tip
of the iceberg and if we think why so
many adapt aws and if we let aws answer
that question this is what aws would say
people are adapting aws because of the
security and durability of the data and
end-to-end privacy and encryption of the
data and storage experience we can also
rely on aws way of doing things by using
the aws tools and techniques and
suggested best practices built upon the
years of experience it has gained
flexibility there is a greater
flexibility in aws that allows us to
select the os language and database easy
to use swiftness in deploying we can
host our applications quickly in aws
beat a new application or migrating an
existing application into aws
scalability the application can be
easily scaled up or scaled down
depending on the user requirement cost
saving we only pay for the compute power
storage and other resources you use and
that too without any long-term
commitments now let's talk about the
different types of services that aws
provides the services that we talk about
fall in any of the following categories
you see like you know compute storage
database security customer engagement
desktop and streaming machine learning
developers tools stuff like that and if
you do not see the service that you're
looking for it's probably is because aws
is creating it as we speak now let's
look at some of them that are very
commonly used within computer services
we have amazon ec2 amazon elastic bean
stock amazon light sale and amazon
lambda amazon ec2 provides compute
capacity in the cloud now this capacity
is secure and it is resizable based on
the user's requirement now look at this
the requirement for the web traffic
keeps changing and behind the scenes in
the cloud ec2 can expand its environment
to three instances and during no load it
can shrink its environment to just one
resource elastic beanstalk it helps us
to scale and deploy web applications and
it's made with a number of programming
languages elastic beanstalk is also an
easy to use service for deploying and
scaling web applications and services
deployed a beaten java.net php nodejs
python ruby docker and lot other
familiar services such as apache
passenger and iis we can simply upload
our code and elastic beanstalk
automatically handles the deployment
from capacity provisioning to load
balancing to auto scaling to application
health monitoring and amazon lightsail
is a virtual private server which is
easy to launch and easy to manage amazon
lightsail is the easiest way to get
started with aws for developers who just
need a virtual private server lightsail
includes everything you need to launch
your project quickly on a virtual
machine like ssd based storage a virtual
machine tools for data transfer dns
management and a static ip and that too
for a very low and predictable price aws
lambda has taken cloud computing
services to a whole new level it allows
us to pay only for the compute time no
need for provisioning and managing
servers and aws lambda is a compute
service that lets us run code without
provisioning or managing servers lambda
executes your code only when needed and
scales automatically from few requests
per day to thousands per second you pay
only for the compute time you consume
there is no charge when your code is not
running let's look at some storage
services that amazon provides like
amazon s3 amazon glacier amazon abs and
amazon elastic file system amazon s3 is
an object storage that can store and
retrieve data from anywhere websites
mobile apps iot sensors and so on can
easily use amazon x3 to store and
retrieve data it's an object storage
built to store and detroit any amount of
data from anywhere with its features
like flexibility and managing data and
the durability it provides and the
security that it provides amazon simple
storage service or s3 is a storage for
the internet and glacier glacier is a
cloud storage service that's used for
archiving data and long-term backups and
this glacier is an secure durable and
extremely cost cloud storage service for
data archiving and long term backups
amazon ebs amazon elastic block store
provides block store volumes for the
instances of ec2 and this elastic block
store is highly available and a reliable
storage volume that can be attached to
any running instance that is in the same
availability zone abs volumes that are
attached to the ec2 instances are
exposed as storage volumes that
persistent independently from the
lifetime of the instance an amazon
elastic file system or efs provides an
elastic file storage which can be used
with aws cloud service and resources
that are on-premises an amazon elastic
file system it's an simple it's scalable
it's an elastic file storage for use
with amazon cloud services and for
on-premises resources it's easy to use
and offers a simple interface that
allows you to create and configure file
systems quickly and easily amazon file
system is built to elastically scale on
demand without disturbing the
application growing and shrinking
automatically as you add and remove
files your application have the storage
they need and when they need it now
let's talk about databases the two major
database flavors are amazon rds and
amazon redshift amazon rds it really
eases the process involved in setting up
operating and scaling a relational
database in the cloud amazon rds
provides cost efficient and resizable
capacity while automating time consuming
administrative tasks such as hardware
provisioning database setup patching and
backups it sort of frees us from
managing the hardware and sort of helps
us to focus on the application it's also
cost effective and resizable and it's
also optimized for memory performance
and input and output operations not only
that it also automates most of the
services like taking backups you know
monitoring stuff like that it automates
most of those services amazon redshift
amazon redshift is a data warehousing
service that enables users to analyze
the data using sql and other business
intelligent tools amazon reshift is an
fast and fully managed data warehouse
that makes it simple and cost effective
analyze all your data using standard sql
and your existing business intelligent
tools it also allows you to run complex
analytic queries against petabyte of
structured data using sophisticated
query optimizations and most of the
results they generally come back in
seconds all right let's quickly talk
about some more services that aws offers
there are a lot more services that aws
provides but are we going to look at
some more services that are widely used
aws application discovery services help
enterprise customers plan migration
projects by gathering information about
their on-premises data centers in a
planning a data center migration can
involve thousands of workloads they are
often deeply interdependent server
utilization data and dependency mapping
or important early first step in
migration process and this aws
application discovery service collects
and presents configuration usage and
behavior data from your servers to help
you better understand your workloads
route 53 it's a network and content
delivery service it's an highly
available and scalable cloud domain name
system or dns service and amazon route
53 is fully compliant with ipv6 as well
elastic load balancing it's also a
network and content delivery service
elastic load balancing automatically
distributes incoming application traffic
across multiple targets such as amazon
ec2 instance containers and ip addresses
it can handle the varying load of your
application traffic in a single
available zones and also across
availability zones away auto scaling it
monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain steady and predictable
performance at a lowest possible cost
using aws auto scaling it's easy to set
up application scaling for multiple
resources across multiple services in
minutes auto scaling can be applied to
web services and also for db services
aws identity and access management it
enables you to manage access to aws
services and resources securely using
iam you can create and manage aws users
and groups and use permissions to allow
and deny their access to aws resources
and moreover it's a free service now
let's talk about the future of aws well
let me tell you something cloud is here
to stay here's what in store for aws in
the future as years passed by we're
going to have a variety of cloud
applications born like iot artificial
intelligence business intelligence
serverless computing and so on cloud
will also expand into other markets like
healthcare banking space automated cars
and so on as i was mentioning some time
back a lot our greater focus will be
given to artificial intelligence and
eventually because of the flexibility
and advantage that cloud provides we're
going to see a lot of companies moving
into the cloud all right let's now talk
about how easy it is to deploy and web
application in the cloud so the scenario
here is that our users like a product
and we need to have a mechanism to
receive input from them about their
likes and dislikes and you know give
them the appropriate product as per
their need all right though the setup
and the environment it sort of looks
complicated we don't have to worry
because aws has tools and technologies
which can help us to achieve it now
we're going to use services like route
53 services like cloud watch ec2 s3 and
lot more and all these put together are
going to give an application that's
fully functionable and an application
that's going to receive the information
like using the services like route 53
cloudwatch ec2 and s3 we're going to
create an application and that's going
to meet our need so back to our original
requirement all i want is to deploy a
web application for a product that keeps
our users updated about the happenings
and the new comings in the market and to
fulfill this requirement here is all the
services we would need ec2 here is used
for provisioning the computational power
needed for this application and ec2 has
a vast variety of family and types that
we can pick from for the types of
workloads and also for the intents of
the workloads we're also going to use s3
for storage and s3 provides any
additional storage requirement for the
resources or any additional storage
requirement for the web applications and
we are also going to use cloudwatch for
monitoring the environment and
cloudwatch monitors the application and
the environment and it provides trigger
for scaling in and scaling out the
infrastructure and we're also going to
use route 53 for dns and route 53 helps
us to register the domain name for our
web application and with all the tools
and technologies together all of them
put together we're going to make an
application a perfect application that
caters our need all right so i'm going
to use elastic bean stock for this
project and the name of the application
is going to be as you see gsg sign up
and the environment name is gsg sign up
environment one let me also pick a name
let me see if this name is available yes
that's available that's the domain name
so let me pick that and the application
that i have is going to run on node.js
so let me pick that platform and launch
now as you see elastic beanstalk this is
going to launch an instance it's going
to launch the monitoring setup or the
monitoring environment it's going to
create a load balancer as well and it's
going to take care of all the security
features needed for this application
all right look at that i was able to go
to that url which is what we gave and
it's now having an default page shown up
meaning all the dependencies for the
software is installed and it's just
waiting for me to upload the code or in
specific the page required so let's do
that
let me upload the code i already have
the code saved here
that's my code
and that's going to take some time all
right it has done its thing and now if i
go to the same url look at that i'm
being thrown an advertisement page all
right so if i sign up with my name email
and stuff like that you know it's going
to receive the information and it's
going to send an email to the owner
saying that somebody had subscribed to
your service that's the default feature
of this app look at that email to the
owner saying that somebody had
subscribed to your app and this is their
email address stuff like that not only
that it's also going to create an entry
in the database and dynamodb is the
service that this application uses to
store data there's my dynamodb and if i
go to tables
right and go to items i'm going to see
that a user with name samuel and email
address so and so has said okay or has
shown interest in the preview of my site
or product so this is where this is how
i collect those information right and
some more things about the
infrastructure itself is
it is running behind and load balancer
look at that it had created a load
balancer it had also created an auto
scaling group now that's the feature of
elastic load balancer that we have
chosen it has created an auto scaling
group and now let's put this url you see
this it's it's not a fancy url right
it's an amazon given url a dynamic url
so let's put this url behind our dns
let's do that
so go to services go to route 53
go to hosted zone and there we can find
the dns name right so that's a dns name
all right
all right let's create an entry
and map that url
to our load balancer right
and create now technically if i
go to this url it should take me
to that application all right look at
that i went to my custom url and now
that's pointed to my application
previously my application was having a
random url and now it's having a custom
url let me help you understand about aws
ec2 a compute servers in the cloud
through this video somewhere far in the
country a scientist has a lab far in the
woods and at one day he stumbled on a
calculation that he had trouble solving
and he was very certain that his
computer can handle it and he asked his
computer to do the math or the
calculation for him and the computer
thought about it for a while then took
couple of hours in trying to process the
data and eventually at one point it gave
up and died due to low memory and this
old scientist is now clueless about how
he was going to finish the task and
complete his invention and let the whole
world know about it and that's when he
was introduced to this new friend aws as
you see on the screen aws was very handy
in replacing his old machines and it was
able to give him the service that he
wanted at that moment aws has been
around for a while helping people with
their computer needs and now this new
scientist friend in need is welcomed by
the new and trendy id technology aws and
sure enough his new aws friend welcomed
and walked him through the new way of
computing and this new happy-faced aws
friend talked to this scientist about
aws ec2 in specific and walked him
through about all the new innovations in
it and in cloud that he had been missing
all these days so his new friend aws
started the conversation about
explaining how there is no need for any
hardware units no managing hardware or
provisioning in aws and secondly it
explained increasing and decreasing the
capacity as per the demand is just a
click away and the best part here is
that there is no upfront commitment and
we only pay for what we have used just
like we pay electricity and water bills
and all this comes with complete control
from our side other words the whole key
for this infrastructure is with us and
as if this was not enough all this comes
with enterprise great security that's
beyond imagination in on premises and if
this still does not excite you then this
definitely would you can work from
anywhere in the world
now this really made the scientist to
get excited especially when he thought
about working from home working from
home there is nothing like it isn't it
now this person the scientist is not
tied up to a particular environment he
can work from home work on the fly work
from anywhere still the data and
everything else in his id environment is
secure and safe now let's move to the
next level of discussion let's talk
about what is ec2 and some of the use
cases of ec2 and this use case we're
going to talk about are this
architecture we're going to talk about
it notifies a group of users about a new
letter and the components or resources
this architecture would need the first
ec2 instance then sns a simple
notification service and
coupling ec2 and s3 servers together
that's all it would require to get an
architecture that notifies a group of
users about a new newsletter and now i
think it would be a good time to talk
about what ec2 is aws offers plenty of
services offered under different domains
like you know compute storage database
migration network management tools media
services security business productivity
application integration machine learning
game development and lot more coming up
out of which ec2 falls under the compute
capacity so what is ec2 ec2 is a web
service which aims to make life easier
for developers for providing secure and
recessable compute capacity in the cloud
with ec2 it is very easy to scale up or
scale down our infrastructure based on
the demand and not only that this ec2
service can be integrated well with
almost all the services in amazon and
out of all this the best part could be
we only pay for what we use all right
let's talk about this use case a use
case here is that a successful business
owner has a bunch of users and a
successful product that's running and
now he has developed few more products
that he thinks will be very successful
that he thinks his customers are going
to like now how can he advertise his
product to his new and prospective
customers or the solution for this
question can be addressed by aws in aws
we can use services like simple
notification service sns and ec2 for
compute and s3 for storage we can in a
way integrate them all and achieve this
business use case and that sort of got
this business owner very cheered up and
now he wants to use the service and he
wants to get benefited from the service
he wants to advertise or he wants to
notify his users every time the company
creates a newsletter all right so let's
talk about what it would take to get
this environment up and running or what
it would take to connect the environment
and put the applications on top of it
firstly we would require an aws account
and then for compute capacity we would
require an ec2 instance and here's how
we go about doing it the first thing is
to create an ami which is amazon mission
image that's really the softwares and
the application packages we would need
to run our application and the second is
to choose the hardware in here it's the
instance type depending on the workload
we would be choosing the hardware and
depending on the intents of the workload
we will be choosing the size of the
hardware and finally we would configure
the instances and how many instance do i
want you know which subnet do i want
them in and what's going to be the in a
stop or terminate a behavior of the
instance and do i want to update any
patches when the instance starts running
all those pieces of information go in
here when we configure the instance
and then the first three steps is really
about the os volume and the basic
hardware now it's time to add additional
storage to the ec2 instance that would
be step four here we add additional
storage to the ec2 instance and then
tags we use tags or we would configure
tags to easily identify an ec2 instance
at a later point you know we give it
some meaningful names so we can identify
like you know which team it belongs to
which billing department it belongs to
what's the purpose behind launching this
instance stuff like that in an
environment where we run 700 to 800 or
even more instances identifying an
instance and trying to understand you
know who owns the resource for what
purpose we created it could be an
full-time work so tagging comes to a
rescue at that time after tagging as
step 6 we would configure the firewall
which is also called security group for
the ec2 instance and this is where we
would allow or deny connection from
external world to this particular ec2
instance well it works both ways
from outside and from inside out this
firewall blocks the connection based on
port number and ip address and finally
as step 7 we review all the
configurations that you have done and we
make sure that the configurations is
what we wanted and finally click on
summit that's going to launch an ec2
instance all right this was just an
overview of how to create an ec2
instance now let's talk about each and
every step in detail so to begin with
let's talk about how to create an ami
well the ami is just a template a
template that's used to create a new
instance or an new computer or a new vm
or a new machine based on the user
requirement the things that go into an
ami are the software the operating
system the additional applications that
get installed in it stuff like that the
ami will also contain software
information you know information about
operating system information about
access permission information about
volumes they all compact in the ami
again the ami is of two types one is
predefined amis are called amazon
provided amis the other one would be
custom amis the amis that we create and
if you're looking at a particular ami
that you don't want to create but still
want to get it from amazon there is a
place or a portal called ami marketplace
there we get like thousands of amis in
there available for us to shop and use
them on a pay as you go business model
and use them as pay as you go billing so
there you can search ami that you're
looking for most probably you'll be able
to get it there now let's talk about
choosing the instance type the instance
type is basically the hardware
specification that's required for a
machine that we're trying to build and
the instant types is categorized into
five main families they are to begin
with it's compute optimized now compute
optimize gives us lots of compute power
or lots of processing power so if my
application is going to require a lot of
processing power i should be picking
compute optimized instance and the
second one is memory optimized now this
is very good for application that
require in-memory caching you know there
are some application that performs well
with cash or through cash or the
application would create a lot of data
that it wants to keep in cash for
rereading or for processing you know for
lengthy processing stuff like that for
those type of application this memory
optimized instance that comes with in
memory cache is a very good use case and
the third one is the instant that comes
with the gpu otherwise called gpu
optimized gpu stands for graphical
process unit and this is very good for
application that deals with gaming this
is very good for application that's
going to require large graphical
requirements and storage optimize is the
fourth option just like the name says
this is a very good use case for storage
servers and the fifth family type is
general purpose just like the name says
it's for general purpose if you're not
particular about the family then you
generally would end up picking the
general purpose because here the
services are sort of equally balanced
you know you'll find a balance between
the virtual cpu and the memory and the
storage and the network performance it's
sort of balanced all the components all
the features that needs to go in a
computer are sort of balanced in general
purpose now these instant types are
fixed and they cannot be altered because
it's hardware based we buy hardware we
do not have much control on the hardware
that's being used well we have options
but we do not have control on the
hardware and these instant types are
divided into five main families they are
compute optimized memory optimized gpu
enabled storage optimized and general
purpose then as third thing we have to
configure the instance now here is where
i have a lot of options about
purchasing you know what type of
purchasing do i want to do do i want to
go for a spot instance do i want to go
for a reserved instance do i want to go
for an on-demand instance these are
different billing options available and
that's available under configure
instance not only that here's where i'm
going to put the ec2 instance do i want
an public ipads assigned to it do i want
an im role attached to it im role is
authentication what kind of
authentication am i going to provide and
the shutdown behavior the shutdown
behaviors include do i want to stop the
instance when the user shuts down the
machine from the desktop or do i want to
simply terminate the instance when the
user shuts down the instance from the
desktop so those things go in here just
like the name says configure instance a
lot of instance configuration options
comes in here that's the third step and
not only that under the advanced details
or advanced tab under configure instance
i can bootstrap the instance with some
scripts now bootstrap is nothing but the
scripts that you want to be run in the
instance before it actually comes online
let's say you're provisioning the
instance for somebody else you know
instead of you launching the instance
and then logging in and running some
commands and then handing it over to the
other person you can create bootstrap
shell scripts and you know paste it in a
console option available under configure
instance and amazon is going to take
those commands run it on the instance
before it hands over to the user that
initially requested for that instance
now it could be a different user or just
you it sort of automates you know
software installation procedures in the
instance that we will be launching and
not only that there are multiple payment
options available under configure
instance the user can pick an instance
under normal price and that instance
would apply normal rates applied to it
and there are also options like reserved
instance where the user can pay for an
instance upfront before a year or before
months you know for a span of year or a
span of months and that way they can pay
less per hour for using that instance
not only that you can also go for spot
instance like bidding for those
instances whoever bids more they get the
instance for that particular time well
these instances are a lot cheaper than
on-demand instances and through bidding
and buying you can keep the instance as
long as your bid price doesn't exceed
the price that amazon is proposing and
as the fourth step we will have to add
storage to the instance that we are
about to launch and here we have bunch
of storage options i can go for a
permeable storage which is free or i can
go for an external elastic block storage
also called ebs which is paid and it's a
permanent storage or else i can
integrate my ec2 instance with s3 for
its storage needs and the best part
about storage is a free subscription
users they get to use 30 gigabit of ssd
storage or magnetic storage for the
whole year in this page where we are
ready to add storage we will have to
mention or provide the size in gigabit
and the volume type is it going to be an
provisioned volume is it going to be an
general purpose volume is it going to be
a magnetic volume stuff like that they
are volume types and we also need to
give inputs about where the disc will be
mounted and whether this volume needs to
be encrypted or not so all these options
are all these inputs are received from
us under the adding storage section and
then the fifth option would be adding
tags like we discussed some time back
tags are very helpful to identify a
machine in an environment where we have
700 or 1000 vms running and security
groups are the actual firewall that sits
in front of ec2 instance and it protects
that ec2 instance from unintended
inbound and outbound traffic now here is
where i can fine tune the access to my
ec2 instance based on port numbers and
based on ip address from which it can be
accessed and finally we get to review
the whole changes or the whole
configurations that we have made to find
out whether they are intact with the
requirement and then click on submit
that's going to launch an ec2 instance
but hold on we're not done yet when
we're about to launch or before the
amazon console actually launches the ec2
instance it's going to give us an option
to create a keypad remember i said it's
key pair you know key pair is two things
one is public and private the private
key is downloaded by the user and is
kept with the user and the public key is
used by amazon to confirm the identity
of the user so just go ahead and
download the private key and keep it for
yourself and this private key gets
downloaded as a dot pem file it's a
format of the file and it gets
downloaded as dot pem file and our next
step is to access the ec2 instance and
because the instance that we have
launched in this example let's assume
it's linux instance and that's going to
require a tool called putty to be able
to access it and this putty tool is
really needed when we are trying to
access and linux instance from windows
instance most of the time windows
instance will have putty installed in
them but in some rare cases they do not
come with putty in those cases we can go
ahead and download putty and put the
generator and we can start using it to
access the linux instance now you might
ask well i understand putty what's putty
generator now the file that we have
downloaded is in dot pem format but
unfortunately putty does not accept dot
pem format as input you know it has to
be converted into a different format
called ppk and puttygen is a tool that
helps us to convert the dot pem file
into ppk file so the quick way to do it
is download generator open it up click
on conversion and insert the dot pem key
that we have downloaded and save the
private key and this when we save the
private key it gets saved as a dot ppk
type private key and when that's done
the next very step is to open putty and
try to log in and the way to login is to
open putty put that ip address here and
then click on auth
you know this is where we would input
the file that we have created so click
on opt and then click on browse and find
the dot using cli there are a few other
things that we can do with the terminal
that will explain it a little later all
right so we have successfully launched
an ec2 instance and
yeah give yourself a pat on your back
launching an instance was just one part
of the solution so let's actually talk
about how we can notify our customers
sns or simple notification service is a
service or a product in amazon that
helps us to notify customers through
email so navigate to sns in your account
and create a topic and we're going to
use this topic for public notification
so let's make it public and then add
subscribers to it now these subscribers
these subscribers are the people who you
want to be notified about the newsletter
so we already have the email database in
there add them to the subscribers list
and then they will start getting new
newsletters as and when we post them to
the topic and as next step create a
bucket in s3 where you can store content
and in that bucket create an event that
triggers a notification to simple
notification service so this is how
it'll be set up and notification will be
sent to our subscribers anytime we put
something in our s3 bucket so s3 bucket
is going to create an event for the
notification and the notification is
going to make sure that it's delivered
to your end customer because they're
already subscribed to the topic as
subscribers and finally let's connect
the s3 with ec2 so the bucket and the
aws instance are in sync so we put some
content in the s3 bucket our email
system notifies our customers and the
customers can go online to a website
that's hosted in ec2 and because s3 and
ec2 are in sync the items that we put in
s3 will also show up in ec2 see how this
is all connected and it's working
together and once this is all connected
our subscribers will regularly be
informed anytime we put new content in
the s3 bucket and the same content will
be made available in ec2 instance
through the website let me help you
understand about lambda one day at
office in a growing company there was
discussion going on between two it
personal it was about the new role that
his colleague jessica has taken benjamin
the guy standing here wants to know
about it and jessica's job is new
different and dynamic and interesting
too she scale and manage servers and
operating systems and apply security
patches onto them and monitor all of
these at the same time to ensure the
best quality for application is given to
the users and benjamin was awestruck
with the amount of work jessica is doing
and with the time it would take to
complete all of them but jessica being a
very dynamic person very suitable for
the job said it was easy for her to
handle all of it and even more but that
easiness on the job did not last longer
as the environment grew more and more it
being a startup company jessica was
getting drained and was not really happy
about all her job as she used to be
jessica's manual way of scaling and
environment did not last long and she
was also finding out that she missed to
scale down some of the resources and
it's costing her a lot she needs to pay
for the service that she was not at all
using she sort of felt that she was at
the end of the road and there was no way
out from this manual task she was very
desperate and that's when benjamin
suggested something and that brought
back the peace and joy jessica initially
had benjamin suggested about a service
called lambda that can ease the work
that jessica is doing at the moment and
lambda as happy as it looks like it's a
solution that solves the manual repeated
to work and lot more and lambda
introduced itself as the problem solver
and started to explain the following
things the very same thing that we're
going to learn about in this series so
in this section we're going to learn
about the features of aws lambda and
we're going to talk about what lambda is
and then we're going to talk about where
lambda is being used in the it or in the
cloud environment as we speak and then
we're going to talk about how lambda
works and some use cases of lambda and
we're going to be particularly
discussing about the use case about
automatically backing up the data that's
put in the cloud storage let's talk
about lambda in detail lambda
automatically runs our code without
requiring us to provision or manage
servers just write the code and upload
it to lambda and lambda will take care
of it that means that we don't require
any server to run or to manage and all
you need to do is write the code and
upload it to lambda and lambda will take
care of it which also means that we can
stop worrying about provisioning and
managing service the only thing lambda
expects from you is a code that's
working aws lambda also automatically
scales our application by running code
in response to each trigger our code
runs in parallel and processes each
triggers individually scaling precisely
with the size of the workload scaling
here is done automatically based on the
size of the workload lambda can scale
the application running the code in
response to each and every trigger that
it receives billing in lambda is metered
on the seconds we only pay for the
amount of time that our code is running
which means that we're not charged for
any of the servers the only payment
required is for the amount of time the
code is computed with aws lambda we are
charged for every 100 milliseconds we
are actually charged for 100
milliseconds our code executes and the
number of times our code is triggered
and we don't pay anything when the code
is not running let's talk about what is
aws lambda now lambda is one of the
servers that falls under the compute
section or the compute domain of
services that aws provides along with
ec2 ebs elastic load balancer lambda is
also a service that comes under the
bigger umbrella of compute services in
aws and lambda allows us to execute code
for any type of application with aws
lambda we can run code for virtually any
type of application or backend services
all we need to do is supply our code in
one of the languages that aws lambda
supports as we speak the languages that
are supported by aws lambda are node.js
java c-sharp go and python and lambda
can be used to run code in response to
certain events from other services and
based on the event it can run functions
and those functions can be of node.js
java c sharp etc now let's talk about
where is lambda used there are huge
number of use cases for lambda and there
are many ways aws lambda is used
specifically in the business world let's
talk about some of them one use case is
aws lambda is used to process images
when it is uploaded in an s3 bucket
let's say the object gets uploaded in an
s3 bucket in a format that we don't
expect it to be which means the file
needs to be formatted so it gets
uploaded in a raw format and aws lambda
is triggered anytime a new object is
added to the bucket and the images are
processed and converted into thumbnails
based on the devices the other end
device that would be reading the data it
could be an pc it could be an apple
machine it could be an android phone it
could be an apple phone it could be a
tablet what not so based on the devices
different formats lambda can get
triggered and convert the video or
convert the picture into the different
format that it requires another use case
for lambda is to analyze the social
media data let's say let's say we're
collecting the hashtag trending data and
the data is received and it's
added into the kinesis stream to feed
into the amazon environment and lambda
action get triggered and it receives the
data and then the data is stored into
the database which can be used by
businesses for later analysis and some
of the companies that have gotten
tremendous benefit using lambda are
thomson routers bench links
not storm coca-cola robot are some of
the companies to name at the moment that
have received tremendous amount of
benefit by using lambda let's look at
how lambda works in other words let's
look at how the complicated function
behind the scenes work in a simple and
in a seamless way so here clients send
data now clients send data to lambda and
clients could be anyone who's sending
requests to aws lambda it could be an
application or other amazon web services
that's sending data to the lambda and
lambda receives the request and
depending on the size of the data or
depending on the amount or volume of the
data it runs on the defined number of
containers if it is a single request or
if it is less request it runs on a
single container so the requests are
given to the container to handle and the
container which contains the code the
user has provided to satisfy the query
would run and if you're sort of new to
containers then let me pause here for a
while and explain to you what container
is now container image is a lightweight
standalone executable package of a piece
of software that includes everything
needs to run it like the codes the
runtimes the system tools the system
libraries and any other settings needed
and it is at the moment available both
on linux and windows based application
and containerized software will always
run the same regardless of the
environment it's running on and
containers isolate software from its
surrounding for example there could be
difference between a development and
staging environment so that's sort of
isolated and this helps in reducing the
conflict between the teams running a
different software on the same
infrastructure all right now that we
know containers needed to understand
lambda so if there are few requests it
sends to a single container but as and
when the request grows it actually
creates multiple containers shares the
multiple requests to the different
containers there and depending on the
volume depending on the size depending
on the number of sessions the more
number of containers are provisioned so
to handle those requests and when the
requests reduce the number of containers
reduce as well and that helps in saving
costs we're not running any resources
and paying for it when we're not using
them and in fact we're not at all paying
for the resources we're only charged for
the amount of time a function is running
inside these containers now consider a
situation where you have to set up a
temporary storage and
as a system to backup the data as soon
as the data is uploaded which is a near
real-time backup now a near real-time
manual backups are nearly impossible and
they're not that efficient too and near
real-time manual backups that's what the
business demands but that's not near
real-time backup that to a manual one
that's not at all efficient even if we
come up with a solution of manually
backing up close to near real time
that's not going to be efficient looking
at the amount of data that will be put
in and looking at the random times the
data will be put into the source bucket
and there is no way we can do a manual
backup and they keep it as real as
possible but if that's still your
requirement we can use aws lambda and
set things up so aws lambda manually
handles the backup in other words for an
impossible or a difficult situation like
that aws lambda comes for the rescue and
this is what we do create a 2s3 bucket
one would be the source bucket where the
data will be uploaded and the other one
is and destination bucket where the data
will be backed up from the source bucket
and for these buckets to talk to
themselves it's going to require an im
rule and then for the automatic copy
it's going to require an lambda function
to copy the files from the source bucket
to the destination bucket and what
triggers the lambda function the lambda
function is triggered every time there's
a change in the metadata for the bucket
and this data is then uploaded into the
destination bucket and after setting all
this up we can literally test it by
putting a data in the source bucket
that's going to automatically replicate
or that's going to automatically copy
the data from the source bucket to the
destination bucket all right let's see
how we can replicate data between two
buckets well we have a feature to cross
region replicate in s3 that's a feature
that comes along with s3 what if you
want to replicate between two different
buckets in two different accounts in
those cases we can use lambda to
replicate the data between the buckets
so you put one data or you put data in
the source bucket and that data gets
replicated to the destination bucket and
let's see how that's done the procedure
here would be to have two buckets to
begin with and then create an im role
that lets you access to pull data from
the source bucket and put data on the
destination bucket and then create
lambda files or lambda event or triggers
to actually look for event in the source
bucket and anytime a new data gets added
lambda gets triggered copies the data
from the source bucket and moves the
data to the destination bucket and it
uses the iam role and policy for the
needed permissions and in just a couple
of clicks we have set up a temporary
backup system that can run seamlessly
without any manual intervention and that
can be as near real time as possible all
right that's the concept and let's see
how it is done real time through this
lab so to begin with we need two buckets
so i have here a source bucket and a
destination bucket and the source bucket
as of now do not have any data in it so
as the destination bucket all right so
that's one down the second would be to
create an im role right so let me create
an im role and the role is going to have
this policy in it a policy that's
allowing get object on the source bucket
and a policy that's allowing put object
on the destination bucket and here i'm
going to use or i'm going to paste my
source and destination buckets arn all
right go to services go to s3
source bucket
all right click on the source bucket and
copy the bucket drn
so that would be the source bucket
arn all right on on the destination
bucket copy the destination bucket arn
and this is going to be my destination
bucket arn so with this i'm going to
create a policy
all right
go to im
and create a policy
now i i have already created a policy
with the same information all right
destination bucket arn and a policy is
available with the name s3 bucket copy
lambda attach the policy to the role
right go to roles create a role lambda
is the service that's going to use it in
here attach the policy that we have
created
right give it a name
and then create a role now i have a role
created as well
right copy lambda and that's having the
policy that we have created sometime
back now create a lambda function right
so go to lambda
create a function give it a name like s3
bucket copy all right choose the role
that we want to use
right that's the role that we want to
use copy one two
create a function
all right
and in here
we're going to use node js code right i
have a sample code
this can be used as template here
replace the source bucket with the name
of the source bucket and the destination
bucket with the name of the destination
bucket this is a node.js code that gets
run when an event get triggered now
what's an event anytime there is a new
object placed in the s3 bucket it
creates an event and the even triggers
lambda and lambda checks the source s3
bucket picks the data puts it in the
destination bucket all right paste it
here
paste it here
and click on save
right now before you click on save just
ensure that you have the appropriate
roles defined
that's all you got to do click on save
all right now i already have created
a lambda function
right
which is the same thing same code and
the role is attached to it
now it's running it's active now let's
put this to test go to s3
pick the source bucket
put some data in it
all right and
in theory those data should be present
in the destination bucket as well
there you go it's all done by lambda i'm
going to be touring you with different
s3 features and technical details in
this section so what are we going to
learn we're going to learn about what is
cloud storage in general and then the
types of storage available in general in
the cloud and how things were before
anybody adopted using s3 that's
something we're going to learn and then
we're going to immediately dive into
what is s3 and then the benefits of
using s3 over other storage and then
we're going to do a couple of
labs or
console walkthroughs about what is
object and how to add an object what is
bucket how to create a bucket stuff like
that and then we're going to talk about
how amazon s3 generally works now it
comes with a lot of features it comes
with a lot of promise um how does this
all work how does amazon able to keep up
with the promise we're going to talk
about that and then we will talk about
some features add-on features that comes
along with the amazon s3 so what is
cloud storage in general cloud storage
is a service that provides web services
where we can store our data and not only
that the data can be easily accessed and
the data can be easily backed up
everything over the internet in short if
you could store your data if you could
access the data if you could back your
your data everything you do through the
internet then that's a good definition
for cloud storage and the additional
definitions are in cloud storage we only
pay for what we use you know no
commitment no pre-provisioning is you
know pay-as-you-go type subscription and
the best part is we pay on a monthly
basis you know we don't rent a hardware
for the year or we don't give commitment
for the whole year it's pay as you go
and pay on a monthly basis and these
cloud storages are very reliable meaning
once you put the data in it it's never
going to get lost and these cloud
storages are scalable assuming i have a
requirement to store 100 times of what
my actual data sizes and i want it now
it's available in the cloud and these
storages are secure as well because
we're talking about data data virginity
they need to be secure and amazon
provides tools and technologies through
which we can secure our data and these
are generally not found in the
on-premises storage system so let's talk
about the different types of storage in
general so s3 is a cloud storage in aws
and then we have elastic block store now
elastic block store is actually the ssd
hard drives that gets attached to our
ec2 instance you know it's like the c
drive it's like the d drive it's like
the e drive that gets attached to our
instances now efs is elastic file system
the underlying technology is kind of the
same but it differs from ebs in a way
that ebs can be accessed only by the
system that's attached to it meaning the
e volumes and the d volumes we spoke
about they can be accessed only if there
is an instance connected to it but these
efs are actually shared file systems
elastic file system all right they're
shared systems they can be accessed by
multiple systems they can be accessed
from inside the amazon environment it
can be accessed from on-premises
equipment as well glacier is actually
the archiving solution in the cloud if
you want to dump a data
and try to keep them in
the low cost as possible then glacier is
the product we should be using and then
we have storage gateway if i want to
safely move my data from my local
environment to the cloud environment and
also want to keep a copy of the data
locally so users locally can access them
and in a cloud users or internet users
can access the data from the cloud if
that's your requirement then storage
gateway is the one we would be choosing
and then we have snowball snowball is
really an
data import and export system but
it is actually an hardware that gets
shipped to our premises where we can
copy our data into it and then ship it
back to amazon and amazon would copy the
data into whatever destination we give
them in our account and if the data is
really huge then i can call for a
snowmobile which is actually a data
center on a truck where amazon would
send me and truck loaded with a data
center as you see that has compute
capacity lots and lots of storage
capacity and electricity uh ac and lot
more so they get come parked near our
data center and cables run into our data
center we can copy data into it send it
back to amazon and they would copy it to
our account in whatever storage that we
advise them so if the data is really
really huge then i would be calling
snowmobile snowmobile is not available
in all the regions all right let's take
this example how things were before s3
was introduced you know two
professionals are having a conversation
and one of them is finding it very
difficult to sort of manage all the data
in the organization well if the data is
small it can be easily managed but as
companies grow and we are living in an
era where data is everything we want
data to back up every idea we want data
to back up every proof of concept that
we provide so data is everything so in
this era it's all about
collecting data analyzing them and
saving you know not losing logs you know
saving them analyzing stuff like that so
coming back to our discussion here one
person finds it very difficult to store
and manage all the data that they have
so some of the data that this person is
having problem uh storing is data's that
application used to running and then
data that gets sent to the customers and
data's that the websites require the
data that are because of the email
backups and a lot more other storages
that an enterprise can have and this
person is having problem backing up all
those data and even if
we think of increasing the local storage
capacity that's going to cost the
fortune and few things that
make it sometimes impossible to increase
the storage capacity in-house is
you know we will have to go and pay
heavy to buy hardware and software to
run these storages and we need to hire a
team of experts for maintaining them the
hardware and the software and anytime if
there is a dynamic increase in the
storage capacity the on-premises or
in-house hardwares won't be able to
scale and data security data security is
very costly when it comes to building
our own storage environment in-house and
adding data security on top of it so the
other guy in the conversation was sort
of quietly listening everything the
manager was saying and then he slowly
introduced him to s3 because he knew
that all the problem that this manager
was worried about can be solved to
yesterday in other words all the
scalability all the
data security all the
not being able to provision hardware and
software components are all available
with s3 so that actually brings us to
the discussion about what s3 is s3 is
simple storage service it actually
provides an object storage service let
me talk to you about object and block
storage object storage is where you can
store things into drive all right you
can't install anything in it and this
object storage can be accessed directly
from the internet whereas block storage
is something that needs to be attached
to an instance and
we can't directly access it but we can
install software in it so that's a high
level difference between object storage
and block storage and s3 is an object
storage what does that mean we can store
data from the internet we can retry from
the internet but we can't install
anything in s3 all right so based
storage and it's it's really built for
storing and recovering or driving any
amount of data or information from
anywhere in the internet few other
things you need to know about s3 is that
this s3 is accessible through the web
interface the storage one type of
accessing or one way of accessing s3 is
by dragging dropping content into it and
another way of retrieving data from s3
is go to a browser click on download
that's gonna let you download any
content and the data can be five
terabytes in size now we're talking
about one file you know you can have
hundreds or thousands of files like that
one file can be as big as five terabytes
in size and s3 is basically designed for
developers where they can push logs into
s3 or drive logs anytime they want
instead of storing locally in the server
they can use s3 as code repositories you
know where they can save the code and
have the applications read the code from
there and lot more if they want to
safely share the code with another
person with a lot of encryption and
security added on top of it that's
possible as well so there are a few
things about s3 and on top of all these
s3 provides 11 9 durability and 4 9
availability meaning durability is if i
store the data will it get lost amazon
is like no it's not going to get lost
you're going to have the data because we
provide 11 9 durability for the data and
availability is if you want the data now
will you be able to show it amazon is
like yes we will be able to show it we
have 99.99
availability and when you request the
data we will be able to show the data to
you all right so let's talk about the
benefits of s3 s3 is durable as we saw
it provides 11 9 durability s3 is low
cost out of all the storage options in
amazon s3 is the cheapest and s3 is very
scalable like we were saying that
there's no required to pre-provision a
storage capacity you know if you need
more go ahead and use more if you need
even more go ahead and use even more and
once you're done some data needs to be
removed just remove the data so that
particular month you will be paying less
so it's very scalable in nature and it's
very available as well s3 isn't regional
service you know it's not based on one
availability zone so one availability is
on going down within amazon the whole
availability going down it's not going
to affect your ability to access s3
storage and s3 is secure a lot of
security features like bucket policy a
lot of security features like encryption
and then mfa authentication are possible
with s3 that actually adds a very good
security layer on top of the data that
we have stored in s3 and not only that
this s3 is very flexible in terms of
cost flexible in terms of where i want
to store the data in terms of cost there
are a lot of pricing tiers within s3 s3
itself is a cheap service now within
that we have a lot of pricing tiers
depending on the durability so i can
always choose to put data on a different
storage tier or storage option in s3
we're going to talk about it as you
stick along and in terms of flexibility
in the region i can always choose any of
the region available in the console or
in the s3 console to put my data to
there is no restrictions on where i can
or cannot put the data in the cloud as
long as there are regions available for
me to move the data to and data
transferring with s3 is very simple all
i have to do is browse to the bucket
upload the data and the data gets
uploaded and we can also upload data
using cli commands are very similar to
linux commands are very similar to what
we would use in the run command prompt
in windows and what we would use in the
run command prompt in the powershell all
right let's talk about
a basic building block of s3 which is
bucket and objects now what's a bucket
what's an object object is the actual
data and bucket is the folder where the
objects get stored let me give you a new
definition for objects so object is the
actual data plus some information that
reference the data like is it a jpeg
file the name of the file and at what
time it was added to so they're called
metadata all right so object is actually
data plus metadata and bucket is
actually a container that receives the
data and safely stores in it and when we
add a data in a bucket amazon s3 creates
an unique version id and allocates it to
the object so we can easily identify it
at a later point let me show you a quick
lab on s3
all right i'm in the s3 console if
you're wondering how i reached here
go to services under storage and s3 is
right here
and let's create a bucket called simply
learn
now the bucket names will have to be
unique
so i really doubt if simply learn
will be available let's
let's check it anyway
all right it's doesn't seem to be
available so
um
let me pick another name or let's call
it
simplylearn.samuel.com i'm going to put
this in
mumbai or i can choose oregon
let me choose oregon
oregon yes
let me choose argon
and let me create a bucket
sure enough a bucket got created let me
upload an object into the bucket
and
you know these objects can be as big as
five terabytes we talked about it right
all right let me upload an object
all right so that's my object so you get
the relation right
here is a bucket
right here is my bucket and within that
is my object now object is the actual
file plus what type of file it is
and then
and then the size of the file the date
in which it got added and the storage
class it is in at the moment
so if i have to access it
i can simply access it through the
internet
so let's talk about how does this s3
bucket work anyway all right so how does
it work a user creates a bucket they
will specify the region in which the
bucket should be deployed we had an
option we could have chosen to deploy in
all the regions amazon provides s3
service you know beat not virginia beat
mumbai beat tokyo beat sydney beat
argonne and we chose argonne to be the
destination region where we want to
create bucket and save our data there
and when we upload
data into the bucket we can specify
three types of storage classes in our
case we picked the default which was a
s3 standard as we saw on the object data
it was on s3 standard so that's the
basic thing later once the object gets
added we can always add
bucket policies you know policies define
who access it and who should not access
it what can they access are we going to
allow users only to read or to read
write as well stuff like that so that's
bucket policy we're defining the life
cycle or the life span of the data in
the s3 bucket now over the time do you
want the data to automatically move to a
different storage tier and at any point
do you want to sort of expire the data
you know get the data flushed out of
your account automatically and those
things can be configured in lifecycle
policies and version control is creating
multiple versions if you're going to use
s3 for a code repository creating
multiple versions let's say if you want
to roll back to whatever you had before
a month how are you going to do it if
you kept updating the file and never
took a version of it so version control
helps us to keep different versions and
it helps us to roll back to the older
version anytime there is a need so let's
talk about the different storage classes
in s3 the different storage classes in
s3 begins with s3 standard now this is
the default and it's very suitable for
use cases where you need less or low
latency for example if you want to
access the data of students attendance
you would retrieve them very quickly as
much as possible so that's a good
use case to store data in s3 let's
understand the different storage classes
in amazon s3 now let's take
a school for example and the the
different data is present in a school
and the features of those data the
validity of the data all right so let's
take this example and uh there are
different storage options in s3 let's
take s3 standard for example and what
would be the actual candidate data that
can be stored in s3 standard let's talk
about that so s3 standard in general is
suitable for use cases where the latency
should be very low and in here the good
example or the good candidate file that
can be stored in s3 is a data that
needs to be frequently accessed and that
needs to be retrieved quickly something
like students attendance
report or student attendance sheet which
we access daily and then it needs to be
retrieved immediately as in when we need
it the other type of storage chair in s3
is infrequent access or infrequent data
access just like the name says the use
case for that is less frequently
accessed data i mean the candidate data
that should go in infrequent access data
is a student's academic record you know
which we don't need to access on a daily
basis but if there is a requirement we
might want to go and look at it and
that's going to be quick so it's not a
data that we would access on a daily
basis but it's data that needs to show
up on your screen real quick and the
third option is amazon glacier now
glacier is really an archival solution
in the cloud so for archives high
performance is not a requirement so
let's talk about some candidate data
that can go into archives something like
students admission fee and it's not
critical also now anytime if you want to
look at the data you can always wait to
retrieve the data so in other words you
know put it in the archive and the
driving from the archival takes time so
uh students old record are a good
candidate to be put in the archives the
other options are one zone ia storage
class where the data is infrequently
accessed and the data is stored in a
single availability zone for example you
know by default amazon stores data in
multiple availability zones and uh there
is a charge for that now it's not an
option but the charge includes storing
data in multiple availability zones but
if your data requirement is you want to
keep the charges in a low even further
you can choose a one zone ia storage
class where it stores data in one
availability zone and the candidate data
that can go in one zone in frequent
access is students report card and the
other option with amazon s3 is standard
reduced redundancy storage it is
suitable for cases where the data is not
critical and the data can be reproduced
quickly for example you know take
a copy of the library book take a copy
of the pdf library book for example now
we would have a source pdf and we would
make copies of it and then we make it
available for the readers to read the
other option in s3 is reduced redundancy
storage uh here the use case is data
that's not critical and data can be
reproduced quickly for example books in
the library are not that critical and we
always have a copy of the book we're
talking about pdf so if the customer
facing or the student facing book gets
deleted i can always copy the same pdf
put it in the destination folder and
make it available for the users to read
that would be a very good use case for
reduced redundancy storage all right
let's summarize everything that we
learned about different storage options
in s3 so s3 standard it's for frequently
accessed data it's the default storage
if you don't mention anything the data
gets stored in s3 standard it can be
used for cloud applications you know
content distribution gaming applications
big data analytic dynamic websites they
are a very good use case for s3 standard
frequently accessed data the other one
on the contrary is s3 standard
infrequently accessed data just like the
name says the use case is this is good
for data that will be less frequently
accessed and and then the use case are
it's good for backups it's good for
disaster recovery and it's good for
lifelong storage of data glacier on the
other hand is very suitable for
archiving data which is infrequently
accessed and the vault lock feature is
the security feature of the glacier that
also provides a long-term data storage
in the cloud this is the lowest storage
tier with an s3 the other options are
one zone infrequent access storage class
just like the name says it's
infrequently accessed and it is stored
in just one availability zone and use
cases are any data that doesn't require
any high level of security can be stored
here in one zone the fifth storage tier
is reduced redundancy storage this is
good for data that's frequently accessed
it's good for data that is non-critical
and that can be reproduced if it gets
lost and reduced redundancy storage or
rrs is an highly available solution
designed for sharing or storing data
that can be reproduced quickly all right
let's compare and contrast a couple of
other features that are available in s3
for example durability availability ssl
support first byte latency and life
cycle management so in standard the
durability is 11 9 durability it's the
same for standard standard ia one zone
ia glacier except for reduced redundancy
the durability is 11.9 and availability
of all the storage classes is all the
same except for one zone ia where the
availability zone is
99.5 percentage all of these products
support ssl connection and
the first byte latency of these products
are most of them provide access with
millisecond
latency except for glacier it provides a
retrieval time of couple of minutes to a
maximum of hours and all of them can be
used for life cycle management you know
moving data from one storage tier to
another storage here that's possible
with all of these storage options all
right now that we've understood the
different types of storage options
available in s3 let's talk about some of
the features that are available on s3
lifecycle management now lifecycle
management is a service that helps us to
define a set of rules that can be
applied to an object or to the bucket
itself life cycle is actually moving the
data from one storage tier to another
storage chair and finally expiring it
and and completing the lifecycle of the
object with lifecycle management we can
manage and store our objects in a very
cost effective way it has two features
basically transition actions and
expiration actions let's talk about
transition actions with transition
action we can choose to move the objects
or move the data from one storage class
to another storage class with lifecycle
management we can configure s3 to move
our data from one storage class to
another storage class at a defined time
interval or at a defined schedule let's
talk about transition actions in more
detail let's say we have our data in s3
at the moment and we haven't used the
data for quite some time and it's that's
how it's going to be for the rest of the
time so that data is a very good
candidate to move to the infrequent axis
because s3 standard is a bit costlier
and s3 in frequent access is a bit
cheaper than s3 standard so the kind of
usage sort of fits very well for moving
that data into infrequent access so
using lifecycle transition or lifecycle
management i can move the data to s3
infrequent access after 30 days and
let's say that the data stayed in
infrequent access for 30 more days and
then now i realize that nobody is
looking into the data so i can find an
appropriate storage tier for that
particular data again and i can move it
to that particular storage chair which
is cliche so in this case after 30 days
or in a total of 60 days from the time
the data got created the data can be
moved to glacier and what does this
really help us with the lifecycle
management help us to automatically
migrate our data from one storage cost
to another storage cost and by that it
really helps us to save the storage cost
lifecycle management can also help us
with the object expiration meaning
deleting the object or flushing it out
after a certain amount of time let's say
that our complex requirement requires
that we keep the data for seven years
and we have like thousands and thousands
of data like that it would be humanly
impossible to check all those or keep
track of all the dates and you know when
they need to be deleted stuff like that
but with life cycle management it is
very much possible i can simply create a
data and set up lifecycle management for
the data to expire after seven years and
exactly after seven years the data is
going to expire meaning it's going to be
deleted automatically from the account
all right let me show you a lab on
lifecycle management and let me explain
to you how it it's actually done so i'm
into the bucket that we have created and
here's our data into the bucket assume
we have thousands and thousands of data
in the bucket and that requires to be
put in a different storage tier over
time and that requires to be expired
after seven years let's say so the way i
would create a lifecycle management is
go to management from inside the bucket
and click on lifecycle and then add and
lifecycle rule just give it a name name
like expire so all the objects that's
present in this bucket meaning the
current version of it set a transition
for it so the transition is at the
moment they are in s3 so here i would
like to put them in infrequent access
after 30 days and then after it's been
an infrequent access for 30 days i would
like to move it to glacier all right
plus 30 days so how do you read it so
for the first 30 days it's going to be
in glacier so how do we actually read it
after i put the data in s3 the data is
going to get moved to standard ia and
then it's going to stay in standard ia
and after 60 days from the data creation
it's going to get moved to
glacier so on the 31st day is going to
move to standard ia on the 61st day it's
going to move to glacier let's say if i
want to
sort of delete the data if i want the
data to get deleted automatically after
seven years you know being in a glacier
how do i go about doing it let me open
up a quick calculator
365 into seven that's
2555 days
right after that the data is gonna get
deleted pretty much i have created a
life cycle so after
on the 31st day it's going to get moved
to infrequent access and on the 61st day
glacier and after seven years is over
any data that i put in the bucket it's
gonna get deleted all right let's talk
about bucket policies bucket policies
are some permission files that we can
attach to when a bucket that allows or
denies access to the bucket based on
what's mentioned in the policy so bucket
policy is really an im policy where you
can allow and deny permission to an s3
resource with bucket policy we can also
define security rules that apply to more
than one file in a bucket now in this
case you know we can create an user or
let's say there's already a user called
simply learn we can allow or deny that
user connection to the s3 bucket or
connecting to the s3 bucket using bucket
policy and bucket policies are written
in json script and let's see how that's
done all right there are tools available
for us to help us create bucket policies
what you're looking at is a tool
available online that helps us to create
a bucket policy so let's use this tool
to create a bucket policy i'm going to
create a deny statement i'm going to
deny all actions to the s3 bucket and
what is the arn to which we want to
attach the arn of the resource is
actually the name of the bucket but it
really expects us to give that key in a
different format so the arn is available
right here copy bucket arn so this is
actually going to deny everybody now we
wanted to deny a user just one user now
look at that now we have a policy that
has been created that's denying access
to the bucket
and it's denying a user called simply
learn pretty much done so i can use the
policy
and go over to
bucket policies so once i save it only
the user called simply learn won't have
access
to the bucket and the rest of them will
have access to it
so once you save it it gets added and
only the user simply learn will not have
access to the bucket because we're
denying them purposefully
the other features of s3 include data
protection we can protect our data in s3
with uh now one of which is bucket
policy i can also use encryptions to
protect my data i can also use im policy
to protect my data so amazon s3 provides
a durable storage not only that it also
gives as unprotected and scalable
infrastructure needed for any of our
object storage requirements so here the
data is protected by two mains one is
data encryption and the other one is
data versioning data encryption is
encrypting the data so others won't get
access or even if they get access to the
file they won't be able to access the
data without the encryption key and
versioning is making multiple copies of
the data so let's talk about them in
detail what's data encryption now data
encryption refers to protecting the data
while it is being transmitted and
protecting the data while it is at rest
now data encryption can happen in two
ways one is client encryption encryption
at rest and server side encryption
encryption that's in motion client-side
encryption refers to when client sends
the data they encrypt the data and send
it across
to amazon and server-side encryption is
when the data is being transferred they
get encrypted and stay encrypted
throughout the transfer
versioning is another security feature
like i mean it helps us so our
unintentional edits are not actually
corrupting the data for example let's
say you edited the data and now you
realize that the data is incorrect and
you want to roll back now how do you
roll back without worsening it's not
possible in other words only with
versioning it's possible so versioning
it can be utilized to preserve recovery
and restore any early versions of every
object that we stored in our amazon s3
bucket unintentional erasers or
overrides of the object can be easily
regained if we have versioning enabled
and it's possible only if we have
one file with the same key name and
anytime we update the file it keeps the
file name but creates a different
version id uh take this bucket and data
for example you know photo.pmg is a file
that was initially stored it attached a
version id to it and then we edited it
let's say we added some watermark we you
know added some graphic to it and that's
now the new version of it when we store
it we store it with the same file name
it accepts the same file name but
creates a new version id and attaches it
anytime we want roll back we can always
go to the console look at the old
versions pick the version id and roll
back to the old version id
all right let's take this example now
i'm in a bucket that we've been using
for a while and let me upload an object
now before we actually upload an object
this bucket needs to be versioning
enabled so let me version enable this
bucket from this point onwards this
bucket is going to accept versioning so
let me upload an object
let me upload it all right it
successfully got uploaded
good enough it's uploaded
now
let me
upload another object
with the same file name now look at that
it was uploaded at 7 40 35 a.m let me
upload another object with the same file
name
that i have it stored right here that
got up to uploaded but with the same
name all right so that's the other photo
now what if if i want to switch back
the way i would switch back is simply
switch back to the older version look at
that this is the latest version and this
is the
old version that i have i can simply
switch back to the old version that was
created at such and such time and
i can open it
that's going to open the old file so in
short it creates different version of
the data that i create as long as it's
with the same name and
at any point i can go and roll back to
the original data this is a very good
use case if you want to use s3 for
storing our codes let's talk about other
feature like cross region replication
now cross region replication is an very
cool feature if you want to
automatically keep a copy of the data in
a totally different region for you know
data durability for any additional data
durability or if you want to serve data
to your customers who live in another
country or who are accessing your data
from another country if you want to
serve the data with low latency cross
region replication is a very cool
feature that you can use and get
benefited from and let's see how that's
done so before we actually do a lab on
cross region replication let's put
together a proper definition for it
cross region replication is a feature
that provides automatic copying of every
object uploaded to our bucket or your
bucket source bucket and it
automatically copies the data to the
destination bucket which is in a
different aws region as you see here in
the picture i put data only in region
one it's going to copy the data to
region two and for us to use cross
region replication versioning must be
turned on so it creates versions and
copies the versions as well if tomorrow
the original region goes down let's say
the other region will be active and it
has the complete data that was present
in the original region or at any point
if we want to simply
you know cut the region
replication and use the other bucket as
in standalone bucket it can be used as
well because it already has all the data
that was present in the master or all
the data that was present in the
original replication bucket let's see
how that's done so there are two things
needed one is worsening and another one
is roll when we transfer data from one
bucket to another bucket we need proper
permissions to do so and these roles
they give us proper permissions to
transfer data from one bucket to another
bucket let's see how that's done right
so here's my bucket
a bucket in usr again
let's create another bucket
in
mumbai
call it dot mumbai
dot com
and put it and
put it in mumbai
or create that bucket in mumbai there
you go we have one in oregon we have one
in mumbai we're planning to replicate or
create replication between these two
right create application between these
two buckets so go to the first bucket go
to management and start a replication
add a rule so all content in this bucket
is going to get replicated this is my
source bucket it's quite simple select
the destination bucket now my
destination bucket is going to be simply
learn.samuel.mumbai.com
all right it says well you have
versioning enabled in your source bucket
but not on your destination bucket do
you want to enable it now without which
we won't be able to proceed further so
let's go ahead and enable versioning
through the console that shows up and
then
like i said it's going to require
permission to put data onto the other
bucket now i can create different roles
these are different roles
that are used for different other
services i can also choose to create a
role that specifically
gives permission only to move the data
from one bucket to another bucket three
months it's done so if i go over to my
source bucket and if i
add some data to it
let's say index.html
assuming i'm adding some files to it in
theory
they should move to the other region
automatically there you go i'm in the
mumbai region and the data's they got
moved to the other region automatically
let's talk about the other feature
called transfer acceleration now it's a
very handy and a helpful tool or a
service to use if we are transferring
data which is very long distance
from us meaning from the client to the
sd bucket let's say from my local
machine which is in india if i transfer
the data over to
oregon let's say it's a long distance if
it is going to go through the internet
it's going to go through high latency
connections and my transfer might get
delayed if it is an 1 gigabit file it's
okay but if we're talking about anything
that's uh you know five terabyte size
you know if you're talking about
anything that's a five terabyte in size
then uh it's not going to be a pleasant
experience so in those cases i can use
transfer accelerator uh with which in a
secure way but in a fast way or a
fastest way transfers my data from the
laptop or from client to the s3 bucket
and it makes use of a service called
cloudfront to transfer or to enable the
data acceleration so the way it would do
it is instead of copying the data
directly to the location instead of
copying the data directly to the
destination bucket it copies the data
locally into a cloudfront location which
is available very local to whatever
place we are in and from there it copies
the data directly to an s3 bucket not
going through the internet that helps
eliminate a lot of latency that could
get added when transferring the data so
let's see how that's done
right here i'm in the s3 bucket and
under properties
i can find transfer accelerator and if i
enable transfer accelerator
so i'm in another bucket
let me go to properties and let me go to
transfer accelerator and enable transfer
accelerator
so now if i put data into this bucket
they're going to get copied to the local
cloud front location and from there
they're going to get copied to the s3
bucket from the cloud front now if we
need to compare you know how the speed
is going to be compared to directly
putting the data to the internet and
using cloudfront there is a tool
available that actually runs for a while
and then comes with a report that tells
me uh how much will be the improved
speed if i use transfer accelerator and
it shows for all the regions available
in amazon so from the source to the
destination if you want to put uh you
know what's the normal and what's the
accelerated speed when you transfer the
data those results we will get in the
screen so at the moment this tool is
going through it testing like uploading
some file through the internet and
uploading some file using cloudfront and
it has come up with the calculation that
if i'm uploading file to san francisco
compared to uploading through the
internet and through cloudfront it's 13
times faster so similar way it's going
to calculate for all the regions
available and it's going to give me a
result let me help you understand series
called i am a service and aws for
security here in this section we're
going to talk about what is security in
aws and then we're going to slowly or
gradually move on to the other topics
like types of security available in aws
out of all the services why i am is the
most preferred one and then we're going
to talk about what is im in general how
it works the building blocks or
components in iam and the features it
the the attractive features that it
provides that makes iam stand out from
the rest of the services available we're
going to talk about that and then we're
going to end today's session with a demo
about how iam gets well interacted with
the other services in amazon and help
create a secure environment in the cloud
let's talk about aws security now cloud
security is the highest priority in aws
and when we host our environment in the
cloud we can be rest assured that we are
hosting our environment in a data center
or in a network architecture that's
really built to meet the requirement of
the most security sensitive organization
and this high level of security is
available to us on a pay-as-you-go type
meaning there is really no upfront cost
that we need to pay and
the cost for
using the service is lot lot cheaper
than what it is in an on-premises
environment
so aws cloud provides an a secure
virtual platform where we can deploy our
application now compared to the
on-premises with aws the security level
is very high and the cost involved in
using or attaching that type of security
to our application is very low compared
to on premises there's really no upfront
cost and the cost is very lower whatever
cost that we pay is very lower than what
it would be in on-premises and all this
contributes to the secure environment we
can get through im in aws cloud there
are really many types of security
services available in aws to name a few
are to name the familiar ones im stands
first followed by a key management
system kms and then we have cognito
that's another service and web access
firewall vaf is another security service
in aws now let's start our discussion by
talking about im and that's what this
whole series is about now im or identity
and access management it really enables
us to manage access to aws services and
aws resources in a very secure manner
with im we can create
groups we can actually allow those users
or groups to access some service or we
can sort of deny them uh to access the
service whichever we want that's all
possible through identity and access
management and this feature comes with
no additional charge now let's talk
about how things were before aws before
aws or before i am
in general it was not that safe in a
corporate to share the password over the
phone or through the email that was the
practice that was existed at that time
now we all can remember the days when we
need to switch to a different account or
we had just one admin password commonly
stored in a location or one person would
reset it and maintain it and any time or
we need to log in we call the person ask
for the admin password or the phone and
then we try logging in now that was not
secure at all back then you know
somebody could walk by and sort of
eavesdrop you know get the password now
they walk away with the password with
them so they're all possible when we
share the password over the phone and
through the internet or email now with
aws a lot of options are available that
i'm not sharing password over the
unsecure medium now a slack is a
third-party product available with aws
it's not an aws product but slack is in
third party application that's hosted on
aws and it's really a communication tool
that helps people to share documents so
now we're not sharing the password over
the phone rather through the
applications and no eavesdrop person can
really catch the password and you know
try it in their system to access our
environment that's not possible so you
see the difference now back then sharing
password was only through phone and
email and you would write it on a paper
and you give it to somebody but now
technology is providing provisions
enough for us to share the password in a
secure way we're still talking about i
am i am is an web service for securely
controlling access to the aws resource
now it really helps us to authenticate
or sort of limit access to a certain set
of users accessing the aws account or
certain set of users accessing a certain
set of resources in aws account now you
see this picture we have an im
administrator who is trying to allocate
permissions to different group of people
so we have group one on the top and
group two in the middle and group three
towards the end the administrator using
iam or iam empowers the administrator
allow access to certain group to certain
resources that's what iam is all about
now let's talk about the building blocks
or let's talk about the elements that
make and complete im so the elements are
categorized into six
different elements we have the principle
in iam the authentication the request
the actual request coming in the
authorization allowing denying access
actions what are the scope of actions
can be taken and on what resource is it
easy to is it ideas is it s3 bucket so
what resource these actions are applied
to so they are the basic elements of an
iem workflow let's talk about principle
for example an action on aws resource
can only be performed by a principal an
individual user they can be a principal
a role in aws im it can be a principle
as well in other words a principal is an
entity that can take an action on an aws
resource you know a principle can be an
user a principle can be a role a
principle can be an application that's
trying to access the aws environment
secondly authentication now
authentication is a process of
confirming the identity of the principle
trying to access the aws environment now
how do we get authenticated or how does
the user get authenticated by providing
credentials or the required keys to
validate that this is what he or she is
as per what's in the record so all
principle must be authenticated and we
get authenticated using the username and
password to log into the console if it
is cli or we get authenticated using the
access key and the secret access key
the other component that makes up iem is
request when a principal tries to use
the aws management console what the
principal is doing or what the user is
doing is sending a request to the aws
environment and the request will have
the principal actually wants to perform
is it a put request or is it a get
request or is it a delete request stuff
like that and it's also going to carry
information about on which resource the
action needs to be done is it done easy
to one is it on s3bucketsimplylearn.com
stuff like that so it has a specific
action that it wants to perform and the
resource on which it wants to perform
and also some information about from
where the request is originating from is
it within an aws environment or is it
with another cloud service provider or
is it with on-premises stuff like that
so these information will be present in
the request authorization now this im
uses information from the request
context to check for matching policies
and it determines it takes a decision
whether to allow or to deny the request
now here it has a logic by default all
the resources are denied and im
authorizes your request only if every
part of the request is allowed by a
matching policy so there is an
evaluation logic that says by default
all requests are denied and if there is
an explicit allow
then it overrides the default deny and
if you are explicitly denying a service
then all the allow statements gets
overridden and all the other statements
gets overwritten and this explicit deny
stands by default only the aws account
root user has access to all the
resources in that account so if you're
not signed in as a root user then we
must be specifically granted permission
through a policy in other words we need
to be authorized through the policy now
let's talk about action now after
authenticating and authorizing the
request aws approves the action that we
are about to take now using action we
can view the content we can create a
content or create a bucket or create an
ec2 instance i can edit content or even
i can delete a resource that's all based
on the action that i'm allowed to do now
that was about actions now where is the
action performed the action is performed
on the resources a set of actions can be
performed on a resource and anything
that's not mentioned in the action or
anything that's not tagged with the
action and the resource they don't get
to complete for example let's say if you
attempt to delete an im role and you
also request to access the ec2 instance
for that role then the request gets
denied now let's talk about some of the
other components of im so the other
components are im are the basic building
block is an user and then many users
together they form a group and then
policies are the engines that allows or
denies a connection you know based on
policy one gets to access or gets no
access to a resource and then roles
roles are another component rules are
temporary credentials i would say that
can get assumed to an instance as in
when needed let's talk about this
component called user in an im with im
we can securely manage access to aws
services and
we can create an im user anytime there
is a new employee joining our corporate
so its a one to one mapping you know one
user or one employee get a username
directly attached to them and a username
or a user is an account specific thing
you know it's very local to that aws
account that we are using so for in
detail an iem user is an entity
that
we create in an aws environment to
represent a person or a service that
interacts with aws environment and this
user is going to have some credentials
attached to them and by default they do
not have
a password and they do not have any
access key or secret access key attached
to them in fact literally no credentials
of any kind now we must create an user
and we must create the type of
credential that gets attached to the
user do they want to access a cli so
based on that we would be adding
credentials to them a user by default is
not authorized to perform any action in
aws and the advantage of having
one-to-one user is that we can assign
permissions individually to that user
for example we might want to assign
administrative permissions to few users
who can administer our aws environment
and users are entity within an aws
account users don't have to pay
separately you know they start using
their servers and that get bills under
the account they are attached to so
separate users doesn't mean that
separate payment for those users they
are just users in our account and you
know the whole account gets to pay for
the resources that they provision again
the im user does not always represent a
person an iem user is really just an
identity with associated credential and
permissions attached to it it could be
an actual person who is a user and it
could be an application also who is a
user next we'll talk about groups
talking about groups or understanding
group is very easy a collection of user
forms an iem group and we can use iam
group to specify permission for multiple
users so that any permission that's
applied to the group is also applied to
the users who are at add to that group
now there are a few things you might
want to know about group a group can
have many users and a user they can
belong to many groups but groups can't
be nested meaning group can only have
users a group cannot have a group inside
a group that's not possible and there's
nothing called a default group that sort
of automatically includes all users in
the aws account
if you want to have a group then we will
have to create a group now let's take
this diagram for example now this is a
diagram of an uh small company now the
company owner creates an admin group for
users to create and manage other users
as the company expands every day and the
admin group creates a developer group
and a test group each of these group
consists of users users who are
people users who are application that
interact with aws environment so the
different types of users we have are
jim is a user brad is an user and
dev app one is a user and and so on so
each users have an individual set of
security credential like i said it's one
to one and the uh
10 users that we see on screen are
shared between or they belong to
multiple groups in the account and
managing group is quite easy we set
permission to the group and that
permission gets applied to all the users
automatically in the group and after we
applied the policy if i add another user
to the group the new user will
automatically inherit all the policies
all the permissions that's already
mentioned in that group so
administrative burden is sort of taken
away administrative burden about user a
privilege or user permission management
is sort of taken out with im all right
the next thing we will want to discuss
is policy a policy sets permission and
controls the access to aws resource and
the policies this permissions and
controls are stored in json format a
policy is a very clear document it
defines who has access to a resource and
what are all the actions they can
perform so in other words policy is an
entity in aws that when a policy gets
attached to an identity or a resource
you know it really defines the
permission what they can and cannot do
and aws it evaluates these policies uh
when a principal such as a user makes a
request and the permission statement in
the policy it really defines whether the
user is allowed to access a service or
is he denied to access a service all
right let's take this example now we
have a task the task is to give paul
who's a developer access to amazon s3
environment and what you're looking at
is a snippet of what a policy would look
like so these are some questions we will
have to answer or these are some
questions the policy tries to answer and
once it found an answer then it becomes
a complete policy so who wants access to
the service it's paul who wants access
to the service and what action do paul
want now paul wants to
download or paul wants to upload objects
in s3 in json language it's otherwise
called paul wants to get information
paul wants to put information otherwise
paul wants to get object paul wants to
put object in s3 and which resource does
he want now in this case every bucket
the star symbol represents all buckets
in history so which resource it's all
bucket in x3 so we can stop reading
already from the data present here so
who wants access paul wants access what
action does he want he wants to get he
wants to put and what's the resource
that he's trying to access or you want
to give him access it's all the bucket
in aws and when does he want these
additional statement that goes in a
policy so since when does he want that
access he wants access till march 2nd
2019 so all this who all this action all
this resource you know till the time all
this gets allowed so this is the
statement that really defines now does
this all refer to an allow statement or
does this all refer to a deny statement
if we had deny here it's the direct
opposite of what we discussed but we
have allow that means paul is allowed to
get and put access in an s3 bucket and
all the buckets in s3 till march 2nd
2019 he's allowed to access the
resources so if we put together put all
the information that we have gathered or
all the answers that we have so far if
we put together in a json format this is
how it's going to look like so
the effect is
allow or deny here it's allowing and the
principal uh is any now who can access
it it's any an action it's any bucket in
s3 any action in s3 put get request and
the resource is any bucket in s3 so
that's how a basic policy would look
like or that's how a basic policy is
formed by answering those basic
questions so let's talk about the types
of policies so we have two broad
categories managed policy and inline
policy the manage policy it's the
default policy that we attach to
multiple entries be users be it groups
and beat roles in our aws account on the
other hand inline policy are the
policies that we create and manage them
and these policies are embedded directly
into a single user group or a role so if
i need to brief
it a little bit more then a managed
policies are standalone identity based
policies that we can attach to multiple
users groups and roles in our aws
account we can use two types of managed
policies in other words managed policies
they themselves have two categories one
is aws managed policies which is created
and managed by aws and the other one is
customer managed policies just like the
name says it's managed by the customer
now we can create and edit an im policy
in visual editor or
simply create a json policy document
directly and upload it in the console
and start using them so that's
manage policy on the other hand inline
policies are policies that we create and
manage and that are embedded directly
into a single user group or role let's
talk about this next component called
role now this role is very similar to
everything that we discussed so far uh
it's
a set of permission that defines what
actions are allowed and denied by an
entity in an aws console the role is
very similar to an user i said very
similar i didn't say it's the same as
the user but i said it's very similar to
the user and the difference is that user
is hard coded user permissions are hard
coded but the role permissions are
accessed by any entity you know beat a
user or a beat and aws service and
moreover the role permissions are
temporary on the other hand user
permissions are permanent and the role
permissions are temporary
so in detail a role is very similar to a
user in that it's an aws entity with
permission policies that determines what
the identity can and cannot do in aws
now instead of it being uniquely
associated with one person a role is
intended to be assumable by anyone who
needs it roles generally do not have an
long term credential you know password
or access keys associated with it you
know it does not have
long term credentials it only has
temporary credentials created
dynamically and provided to the user as
in when the user assumes a role and
wants to access any service roles can be
assumed by users roles can be assumed by
applications roles can be assumed by
services that normally you don't have
access to aws resources for example you
might want to grant a user in your aws
account access to your resource that
they do not normally have or grant users
in one aws account access to resource in
another aws account now this is
something that we don't have by default
and this is something we may not need
all the time or you might want to allow
a mobile app to use aws resource but you
do not want to save the key or save the
credential or save the passwords in the
mobile app or sometimes you might want
to give access to resources who already
have identities defined outside of aws
like a user who's already and google or
facebook authenticator if you want to
give them some service or if you want to
let them to access some of the resources
in your account we can use roles for
that purpose or you also might want to
grant access to your account to a third
party a consultant or an auditor so they
can for some time get some temporary
access to audit our aws resources
remember they're not permanent users
just templar users they want some
temporary access to our environmental
the audit is over so for those cases
roles are a very good use case so let's
take this
example let's see where role sits and
let's see how roles give permission
to other services so here is a scenario
where where an ec2 instance
wants access to an s3 bucket
by default though both of them were
created by the same username or the same
admin they do not have access by default
so by default they don't have access and
i also do not want to give permanent
access you know one-on-one hard-coded
permanent access instead i would like to
create and share access so that's
possible to roll so coming back to the
discussion uh the scenario here is that
an ac2 instance wants to access data in
an s3 bucket so the first thing is to
create a role or a permission we saw how
that's done right using policies roles
use policies policy is the actual
working engine for any permission
related actions right so create a role
with an appropriate policy that gives
access to s3's bucket and then launch an
ec2 instance with the role attached to
it we said rules are assumed by any
entity right it could be user it could
be an application it could be a service
it could be another resource in aws
account so here it's another resource in
aws account right so we create a role
and we attach it to an ec2 instance so
now the ec2 instance can assume the role
now the same role can be attached to
another ec2 instance the same role can
be attached to
another user the same role can be
attached to another database service we
get the idea right roles can be assumed
by anyone so when the ec2 instance wants
to communicate with s3 it contacts the
role and then the role gives this ec2
instance some temporary username and
password that expires after one hour
let's say so it's a temporary username
and password now with that temporary
username and password the ec2 instance
can access the
s3 bucket and access the file with the
credential that it already has and that
credential is a temporary one and the
credential will expire after one hour or
how much ever time the admin sets it to
be and then the next time when is when
an ec2 instance wants to contact s3 it
will have to contact the role and the
role will propose a new access key and
secret access key in other words a new
credential with that new credential the
second time the ec2 instance will be
able to contact the s3 bucket and get
the information so the password is not a
permanent or a one-time or a hard coded
password it keeps rotating it's a token
it's a secure token that an ec2 instance
or any application that uses the role
gets to access the resources on the
other end well let's talk about the
features of iam the main feature of iam
is that i can create separate username
and password for individual users or
resources and i can delegate access now
those days where we had just one
username and password for admin and we
need to call the other person to get the
username and password over the phone
if it gets compromised you know the
whole account gets compromised stuff
like that those issues are gone i can
create separate username and password
for all thousand users in my account no
more username and password sharing i can
manage access to all those thousand
accounts in a very simple and an easy
way so im provides shared access for all
the thousand users in my account it
provides share access to the aws
environment and the permissions that can
be given through im are very granular
now we saw how restrictions can be put
on get request you know we can allow the
user to download information and not
update an information so that's possible
through the iem policies that we looked
at some time back and with the use of
roles you know we're authenticating an
ec2 instance instead of the application
running on top of it so if there are
like 10 or 20 applications running on
top of an ec2 instance instead of
creating a separate username and
password for all those 20 instances i
can create a role and assign that role
to the ec2 instance and all the
applications running on the ec2 instance
get a secure access to the other
resources use the role credential that's
provided to that ec2 instance now
besides username and password im also
supports multi-factor authentication
where we provide our credential the
username and password plus an otp from
our phone or an
randomly generated
number that gets displayed in our phone
before amazon console or before amazon
cli would authenticate and
lets us access some of the servers in
the account so it's called multi-factor
authentication it's username and
password plus something else from what
you have im also provides identity
federation if a user is already
authenticated with a corporate ad or
facebook or google you know im can be
made to trust that authentication method
and then allow access based on that
authentication now without federation
what would happen is the users will have
to remember two passwords you know one
for on-premises and one for cloud
anytime they work on on-premises they'll
have to use one set of password and
anytime they switch to the cloud which
is going to be very frequent in a every
day so anytime they switch to the cloud
they will have to again type in the uh
cloud username and password now with
identity federation we can sort of
federate or we can connect both the
authentication systems both on-premises
and im so users can just use one
username and password for both
on-premises and cloud environments and
all that we saw so far it's free to use
there is no additional charge for im
security there is no additional charge
for creating additional users groups or
policies it's a free service comes along
with any account im is an pci dss
compliant product now im comes with
password policy where we can reset the
password remotely or rotate the
passwords remotely
and we can set rules like how a user
should pick an password it should not be
the one that was used in the past any of
the past three times stuff like that so
you get the idea right how the features
of im help us to build and a secure
authentication and authorization system
in or for our aws account
all right it's time to do a quick lab
let's let's put all the knowledge that
we have earned so far together and apply
it and try a lab and solve the problem
so here's a problem statement
we need to create an s3 bucket for a
company where users can read or write
the data only if they are multi-factor
authenticated so there could be like 20
users in an account but a user is
allowed to read or write a data in an s3
bucket only if the user is multi-factor
authenticated you know this is a very
good use case if we have a sensitive
data in an s3 bucket and you only want
privileged or mfa authenticated users to
do changes to those buckets and for
those privileged users you would enable
multi-factor authentication so let's see
how that's done before that let me talk
to you a bit more about multi-factor
authentication a multi-factor
authentication is that additional level
of security process it's provided by aws
here the user's identity is confirmed
only after the user proposes or the user
passes to level of verification now one
being the username and password and
another being an otp that gets generated
in this case it's the mobile phone it
could also be an
rsa token key that generates the
one-time password that's possible as
well but in this case it's the mobile
phone now that's going to be very
similar to how we login to our gmail
account sometimes when we log into a
gmail account and
i mean if you have the proper setting
enabled it's going to send an one-time
password to the mobile phone and only
after we put that information it's going
to let us log in let's see how all this
is done in an aws account so the first
thing is to log in to the aws account
create a user and attach the user to the
virtual mfa device now we're going to
use google authenticator here and we're
going to attach the user to
google authenticator and make the user
use the google authenticator one-time
password every time he logs in to the
account now this is an addition to the
username and password that
he or she already has right so the first
thing is to log into the account connect
or sync the virtual appliance with the
aws username and password now when we
sync there will be an one-time password
that gets shown in the phone type in the
password in the aws console and then the
phone and the username comes to sync and
from that point onwards the user anytime
they log in they will have to propose
their username and password which is the
first step of security and then once
they typed in the username and password
type in the mfa code that gets generated
on the phone that would be the second
step or security or the last step of
security once that is done the account
is going to let them log in and access
the aws resources alright so in order to
test im mfa s3 together this is what we
are going to do so we are going to
create
a bucket and we are going to have two
users and we are going to allow or deny
access to the s3 bucket to those two
users based on whether they are mfa
authenticated or not and on purpose uh
we gonna assign mfa to one user and
no mfa to the other user like you might
have guessed by now the user with mfa
will have access to the bucket and the
user with no mfa attached will not have
access to the bucket both of them are
going to have full s3 services but mfa
like i said is one layer above the other
permissions mfa stands at all time so
irrespective of whether the underlying
policy says but they have full access to
the s3 bucket they're not going to
because mfa stands on top of it let's
see how that's done to begin with
firstly we need a bucket so let's create
a bucket
so i'm in my
aws console so let me go to s3
and in here create a bucket call that
bucket as simply learn mfa bucket and
let me put it in north virginia
and create
all right so that's done
now i'm going to put a separate folder
in here
i'm going to create another folder in
here and the name of the folder is tax
documents now this is where i'm planning
to keep my tax files
and i only want my privileged users to
be able to upload and download
information from the tax document so on
the bucket side it's partially done or
on the s3 side it's partially done so
let's go back to iam
and here we're going to create two users
one a junior employee and another one
and a senior employee the senior
employee is the one who is going to have
mfa access and
more access
to the s3 bucket and the junior employee
is the one who's not going to have
access to that particular bucket so
let's get
started let's create an user under iam
click on users
and let's create a user call as user
junior
right so here's a junior user
and for the password
set a password
the user does not need to create a new
password at sign in because it's a test
environment and
the user who creates the username and
the user are the same person so let's
keep it simple username password
management console access
and this user is going to have
full s3 bucket access all right this is
really the policy
and we should be familiar
with this dslr document by now it says
effect is allowed and what action any
action an s3 and
what resource anybody who is attached to
it
review
and create a user
so this user is having
s3 full access now let's create another
user call them as senior employee
all right attach
a policy to the user
you know from the surface level both of
them have the same permissions both of
them have s3 full access
all right so
both of them have s3 full access as we
see
there's one thing different we're going
to do to this senior employee now we're
going to attach
mfa to this employee so the way we would
do it is under the summary section of
that particular user click on security
credential and see here is a place we
can attach an mfa to this user so let's
attach mfa to this user
for mfa i can use both virtual mfa or
hardware mfa this being in lab
environment we're going to use virtual
mfa now that is an application there are
a lot of applications available but
there is one application that i'm using
at the moment called google
authenticator
so once we have installed the
application and once it is running
so i can go to virtual mfa device and
once it is running i can scan the code
using the google authenticator in my
mobile phone once you turn on the
application and once you do scan the
barcode that is showing right here now
that's going to give us
codes that we can use and we will have
to put in those codes here twice we'll
have to wait for some time and it would
generate a second set of key that we can
put
so my first set of key is four zero two
three five one right i'll have to wait
for some time and then it would throw me
a second set of key it's like validating
twice right here so let me put in my
second set of key
so this user is now mfa authenticated
user so anytime this user logs in it's
going to ask for mfa anytime this user
proposes something it's going to attach
the mfa key along with it all right so
we're done with the iam what have we
done with im we have created two users
both of them have actually full access
but
one of them have
mfa access and the other one does not
have mfa access and based on whether the
user is having mfa or not you know we're
identifying privileged users by this mfa
all right so based on whether the user
has mfa or not are we gonna allow deny
access in the s3 bucket
so we already have a bucket we already
have a folder and this is a very
privileged folder part here i would like
to restrict access based on whether the
user is having mfa or not
so let me create a bucket policy here
now here here's a policy that i have
written
the policy
says that you know under tax document
folder give access only if the user is
mfa authenticated right if the user is
not mfa authenticated simply deny the
access to that user so as you might
guess right now the user one will not
have access
or the
junior employee will not have access
because it's a privilege then you know
junior employee might tend to delete
them unknowingly and only privileged
users get access to the tax document
because it's confidential because it's
privileged because if it gets deleted we
won't be able to get it back for those
reasons right so apply the bucket policy
now try logging in as
the different users and see how the
permissions are applied on both the
users all right so let's make a note of
the im url
and then the two usernames and password
let's login
so let me login as the privileged user
sure enough i'm being asked for an mfa
code let me put my mfa code
so let's directly navigate to the s3
bucket
right here's my privileged path let me
try uploading some content
claim forms
sure enough i'm able to upload content
into it will i be able to delete
yes i'm able to delete as well now let's
see what's the situation for the other
user
so let's login as the other user
navigate to the sd bucket
if you noticed when logging in it did
not ask for an mfa code because the user
is not set up for mfa
so navigate to the folder
which we want to test
now try adding some
files as you see it's failing
to add content to this bucket it shows
error because the bucket policy is
requiring mfa and this user is not mfa
and we did that in iam or under iam
but still as you see you know they will
be able to view the content in the
bucket they can do all that we have
specifically restricted access to upload
and download content from the bucket and
that's exactly this user is now denied
with
in this section we're going to learn
about why we need a solution called
cloud formation or why we need a product
called cloud formation and we're going
to talk in detail about what is cloud
formation and then how cloud formation
works and the concepts involved in cloud
formation like i know templates and
stacks there are some concepts involved
in cloud formation we're going to talk
about that and how do we maintain access
control over cloud formation we're going
to talk about that as well in this video
and then we're going to go through a
demo or a lab where we create an lamp
stack environment from a template
through cloud formation and then we're
going to talk about some use cases one
of which include being able to create an
redeployable template using cloud
formation that's a very good use case
we're going to talk about that in this
video so let's talk about why cloud
formation so when the number of products
and services grow more and managing them
and
maintaining them
becomes and tedious work and cloud
formation it sort of eases that
environment now cloud formation is
really an infrastructure as a code and
it sort of solves all the problem that
we discussed sometime back and with
cloud formation we can actually create a
perfect clone of the server
configuration at any point in time and
we can also manage the configuration
changes and configuration changes with
cloud formation we can manage the
configuration changes across the
environment and not only that we can
easily ember in the ad hoc changes to
our existing environment so one might
ask why use cloud formation let's look
at the current problem that we have
creating and managing multiple aws
resource in the portal is a big task
especially when you need to replace some
services it becomes a bigger task now
cloud formation eases that work let me
explain it in detail now at the moment
without the cloud formation or
environments that don't use cloud
formation have this problem that is a
lot of time is being spent on building
the infrastructure and less focus and
less time at the moment is being given
on developing that application that runs
on that environment that's because
majority of the time is consumed by
building the environment and if we need
to redeploy the same environment again
and again the same happens in a cycle
again in a new environment we start from
the scratch build environment and then
put application on top of it now that
can be avoided using cloud formation now
without cloud formation still is a
problem because the the resource or the
bandwidth that is needed for the
application development is not provided
because that's taken by developing the
infrastructure and to solve that problem
we can use cloud formation now that
leads to a discussion about what is
cloud formation so let's talk about or
let's try understanding what cloud
formation is cloud formation is a
service that provides users a simple way
to create and manage collection of aws
resources by provisioning and updating
them in and very orderly and in a
predictable way if i need to expand
explanation of cloud formation
cloudformation is an server that really
helps us to model and set up our amazon
web services or resources so we can
spend less time on managing the
resources and show more focus on the
application that runs on top of it we
can simply create a template for an ec2
instance or for an rds instance and
upload it in the cloud formation portal
and cloud formation will provision and
configure those resources based on the
template that we define we really don't
have to sort out the complexities in
dependency between those applications
once the template is wetted and
validated cloud cloudformation takes the
responsibility of handling the
dependencies between the application in
an orderly and a predictable way it
creates those services and makes it
available for us once the template is
fully run so in short at the cloud
formation it allows us to create and
model our infrastructure and
applications without we having to
perform the manual action for example
the well-known company called expedia is
able to easily manage and run its entire
front and back end resources they run on
aws in cloudfront what does that mean
they are spending less time on managing
the infrastructure and more time on the
core business and the application that
runs on top of it and we're still
talking about uh what cloud formation is
with cloud formation it enables us to
manage our complete infrastructure or
aws resource in a text file now we're
going to see that in a moment you know
it's either a json or an yml file and
that file is called as the template to
begin with the resources the template
provision is called the stack all right
so the abstract of the code is called
the template and the resource that it
provisions is called the stack and this
stack can be i mean it's going to run
resources obviously and those resources
can be updated as well it's not like
once you create a stack it's done if you
need a change you need to go create
another resource that's not needed this
stack is an updatable stack let's say if
i'm including two more servers if i'm
sort of extending my environment it's
branching out to another application now
i'm including another functionality in
my environment all those can be embedded
in the update and can be updated so like
i said the stack is an updatable one now
let's talk about what the template can
do or some features and functionality of
the template now using a template we can
almost include all the application and
resources that a user might require
let's say you know after the easy to
instance is provisioned running an
application on top of it and you want to
templatize that and include that in the
template that's possible as well and
these templates are portable ones
meaning i can use the template in one
region and i can use the same template
in another region and that's going to
build a very similar environment in
another region i can also share that
with the customer and when they run it
it's going to run an environment from
the portable template in their account
in their environment of course all the
security is taken care i'm just saying
that if we need to build a resource if
you need to build an architecture if you
need to build an environment which looks
very similar to the other environment
that is possible and and these templates
are usable by the use of some sections
in the template like the parameter
section the mapping section the
condition section within the template is
what makes the templates reusable and we
will talk about uh parameters mapping
and conditions down the line we're still
talking about aws how aws cloud
formation works and we're going to talk
about how a template becomes an
infrastructure right so to begin with
one requires a template and the template
uh would be in json or yml format so one
would develop a template based on the
requirement based on number of ec2
instances based on whether they want a
load balancer based on whether they want
and a windows server based on whether
they want an database server in that
environment and then based on the
applications that will be running on top
of it that can be templatized in the
code itself so one creates a code and
then the code is saved locally or they
can be put in an s3 bucket from which
the cloud formation will call the
template and provision the resource
right so we use cloud formation to
create a stack or create the resource
defined in the template and cloud
formation analyzes the template first
validates template and then it
identifies the
dependencies between them and then it
starts provisioning the resource one
after the other for example if you need
a five servers in a new vpc obviously
it's going to create the vpc first and
servers second and stack all right let's
understand the two major components in
cloud formation by now you might have
guessed it the two major components are
the template and the stack together they
aid or they complement cloud formation
and that's how the resource of provision
that's how the resource are managed and
that eases the job of the administrator
who's managing the environment so let's
talk about template first a templated
cloud formation is an text file or a
formatted text file in json or yml
language and that the code or the
template or the text file that actually
describes how your infrastructure looks
like or will look like once provision
and for us to create the template or for
us to
modify an existing template we can use a
tool available called cloud formation
designer from the console or any text
editing tool that's available but i
would recommend the cloud formation
designer though that has rich graphics
in it and these templates are built off
or they consist of nine main objects the
first of which is the format version and
this really identifies the capabilities
of the template based on the version
number and then the second object in a
template would be description and this
helps us to include any arbitrary
comments about the template for what
reason are we building this template
what's the purpose of it stuff like that
and then we have the object called
metadata in a template and that includes
a details about the template details of
the resources in the template and then
we have the optional parameters section
this really helps us to customize our
template now parameters enable us to
input custom values to our template each
time we create or update and stack and
the mapping object it helps us to match
a key to a corresponding set of named
values for example if you want to set a
value based on region then we get to
create a mapping that uses region name
as the key and then the value that we
want to specify for each specific
regions and then we have conditions
object this is again an optional object
with this we can include statements that
define when a resource is created or
when a property is defined for example
we can compare whether a value is equal
to another value and based on the result
of that condition we can conditionally
create additional resources and then the
object called transform it's it's an
optional object as well and this
transform section specifies one or more
transforms that we can use in our cloud
formation template for example uh aws
cloud formation transforms helps
simplify template authoring by
condensing the expression of the aws
infrastructure as a code or the cloud
formation template and it enables reuse
of template components for example we
can condense multiple line resources
declaring it into a single line in our
template now we will talk about all
these examples in the upcoming slides
and then we have the required
section called resource that declares
the aws resource that you want to
include in the stack for example if you
want to include an ec2 instance if you
want to include an s3 bucket we would be
using the resource object in our stack
and then we have object called output
this output object it's an optional
object in the template and it helps us
to sort of
declare the outputs that we can import
into other stacks or
we can actually show it on the cloud
formation console for example if you
want the output of the or the name of
the s3 bucket that got created in
response to a cloudformation template
now we can have that outputted into an
output section in the cloud formation
console itself so it's sort of easy for
us to identify the resources that the
template provisioned so with all of
those objects put together this is how a
full-blown cloud formation template with
all the objects included is going to
look like now this includes optional and
mandatory object let's talk about those
objects in detail in the upcoming
section all right let's now discuss each
and every object of this template
structure and let's begin our discussion
with the format version the format
version it really defines the
capabilities of the template the latest
version format version as of now is the
one that was updated on 2010. now the
value of the template format version it
has to be and
string and if we really don't uh specify
the format version cloudformation
automatically assumes the latest version
talking about description descriptions
are really any comments that help
ourselves that we want to ember in the
template itself that can be a
description and this description in a
template it has to be an string the
length of the string can be between
0 to 124 bytes in length the metadatas
are really used in the template to
provide any additional information
using the json and yaml objects and
metadata holds some implementation
details of a specific
resource and parameters are really a way
to customize the template each time we
create or update our stack these
parameters are the ones that helps us to
give some custom value to the template
during runtime in the example shown
below the parameter named instance type
parameter it lets us to specify the ec2
instance type for the stacks to use when
creating or updating the stack by
default as we see
it's picking t2 micro and this is the
value that will get picked if we don't
provision
another value to it and mapping mapping
really enables us to map a key to a
corresponding named value that we
specify in a conditional parameter and
also we can detrive the map or to try
the values in the map using the function
find in map instrict function let's take
this example let's say based on a region
if you want to set values in a template
we can create a mapping that uses a key
and holds the value that you want to
specify for each region and the object
conditions can be used when we want to
reuse the templates by creating
resources in a totally different context
for example in a template during stack
creation all the conditions that we
mentioned in the template are evaluated
and any resources that are associated
and that come up to be true are created
and any condition that fails or invalid
are kind of ignored automatically and
the check moves forward to the next
condition and conditional is an optional
object and it includes statement that
define when a resource is created or
when a property is actually defined for
example you can create whether for
example you can compare whether a value
is equal to another value and based on
the result of that condition we can
conditionally create resources if you
have multiple conditions then they are
generally separated with commands
sometimes conditions are very helpful
when we want to create
templates and we want to reuse those
templates which was created for one
environment to another environment for
example if you want to use a template
that was created in a test environment
in a dev environment conditions would be
helpful for example in a production
environment we might want to include
instances with certain capabilities and
in a test environment we might want to
include instances with some reduced
capability in them for saving money and
condition helps us to sort of create
resources based on the environment it
will be used in we can also use
intrinsic functions to define conditions
like equals we can also use r conditions
we can use not functions intrinsic
functions in a condition and when put
together the syntax is going to look
like the one that you see on the screen
now the optional object called transform
it specifies one or more transforms that
the cloud formation uses to process our
template now these transform sections
are built on a simple
declarative language of aws cloud
formation with a powerful macro system
that helps us to
reuse the templates or the template
components and they really help us to
condense or simplify our codes by
enabling reuse of the template
components for example condense a
multiple line resource declaration into
a single line in our template the
resource section it really declares the
aws resource that you want to include in
the stack such as ec2 instance such as
s3 bucket and some of the resource
fields are the logical id the resource
type and the properties let's talk about
them in brief the logical id is unique
within the template and the logical id
name it actually reference the resource
in other parts of the template in this
case it's my bucket for example i know
if we want to map an elastic block store
volume or if you want to map and
name of the bucket in another place in
the template not then we would use the
logical id and again in this case it is
my bucket a logical name has the
physical id with which we actually
assign the resource for example in this
case mys3 bucket was named as mybucket
to begin with and the resource type in
the template it identifies that the type
of the resource is an s3 bucket and the
properties are the additional
optional information that we can specify
to our resource for example if it is an
ec2 instance let's say we would like to
know which ami it used then property
section really defines the ami that was
used or ami as the property of the
instance so this section describes the
output value that needs to be imported
to other stacks or the output value that
needs to be shown in the console for the
user to easily navigate to the resource
that are being created for example for a
s3 bucket name we can declare an output
and once the bucket is created we can
actually declare the output and sort of
import the name of the bucket in a
different place in the console so it's
it's easy to view instead of you know
the user getting confused and
going to s3 and searching for the bucket
name this can be made available in the
cloud formation console itself and the
output fields it can include some of
these followings like the logical id uh
it's actually the identifier of the
current output and it's very unique
within the template and it can also
include a description description is
really a string type that describes the
output value and it can also include
value and value is the property that was
returned by the aws cloud formation
describe stacks command all right let's
talk about template
resource attribute in this section we're
going to uh talk about
attributes that you can add to a
resource to control additional behavior
and relationships so let's talk there
are many resource attributes available
out of which we have
if we need to name them we have a
creation policy and then we have
deletion policy it depends on metadata
attribute update policy attribute let's
talk about each of them separately when
we associate the create policy attribute
with the resource it actually delays the
resource configuration actions before
proceeding with the stack creation i
mean the attribute stack creation is
delayed till the time the cloud
formation receives some number of
success signals back i mean this is a
very good use case when we do auto
scaling
and this creation policy can be used
only with a
limited number of services like auto
scaling and ec2 instances some of the
use cases would be if you want to
install and software application on an
ec2 instance you might want the
applications to be running before it
proceeds further so in this case we
would use the creation policy attribute
to the instance
and then send the success signal after
the applications are installed and
configured then cloud formation goes to
the next step here in the syntax that
we're looking at the auto scaling
creation policy and the minimum
successful instance percentage it's
actually a number of signals that it
will have to reply back before it can
move forward using deletion policy it
preserves backing up of resources when
the stack is getting deleted and by
default if you don't have a deletion
policy the
data gets deleted just like that but if
you use an deletion policy we would be
able to preserve the data by taking a
snapshot of it or
just letting the resource and moving on
with deleting the other resources in the
stack and we specify the delete policy
attribute for each resource specifically
that we want to control and if there are
no deletion policy mentioned for a
particular resource the cloud formation
simply deletes the resources as that's
its default behavior and if you want to
keep the resource when the stack is
deleted we use we we mention retain in
the delete policy and that simply
retains the resource from getting
deleted so in this example we're
actually retaining a dynamodb table rest
of the resources in the stack will get
deleted and using the depends on
attribute
we actually
create a an order in which the resource
gets deleted for example if i map one
resource to another resource and say
that this resource depends on the other
resource the other resource gets created
first then followed by this instance or
this resource so with the depends on
attribute we can specify that the
creation of specific resource is
actually followed by an another when we
add the depends on attribute to a
resource the resource is created only
after the creation of the resource
specified by the depends on attribute
let's take this example in this example
we're saying that the resource x
depends on y we've said that x depends
on y so in this case when cloud
formation is executing it's going to
deploy y first because it has some
resources that depends on it so it's
going to create y first and then it's
going to create the resource called x on
the same context let's say in the
template we say that an ec2 is going to
depend on s3 and when the cloud
formation is executing it's going to
create an s3 bucket first and then the
ec2 instant that's probably because the
codes needed for the ec2 instance are
stored in the s3 bucket and and what
we're looking at is the syntax of how
the depends on template resource
attribute will look like this is how it
actually will look like when we put it
in the cloud formation the instance
depends on the bucket the other template
resource attribute is metadata metadatas
are the one that really helps us to
associate our resources with the the
structured data and by including this
attribute in our template or by
including this attribute to a resource
we can specify the data in json or in
yaml language for example in this
section of the template we're creating a
vpc and the metadata explains or
metadata defines that the vpc is part of
the region us east one and the update
policy template resource attribute and
cloud formation we can manage and
replace the updates of the instance in
an auto scaling group for example you're
looking at this uh sample where it says
that the update policy will it replace
the instance in an auto scaling group or
not so depending on what the value is
for the will replace section whether
it's true or false depending on that the
update policy will replace the instance
or will replace the auto scaling group
itself when it's doing enrolling
deployment now that we've discussed
about templates let's talk about aws
stacks as well now we know that aws
stacks are the actual resources that yes
generated or that gets created because
we ran a template right so stack is a
collection of aws resource that we can
manage in a single unit in other words
you know we can create a stack update a
stack or delete a stack and that would
actually create update delete the
collection of resources within the stack
and all the resources in the stack are
really defined by the cloud formation
template and a stack for instance can
include all the resources required to
run a web application such as a web
server a database server and some
networking rules that come along with it
all that gets embedded in a stack and
let's say if we want to delete all the
resources that were created by template
that is in a separate stack we can
simply delete the stack and that would
sort of delete all the resources that is
in the stack so it sort of helps us to
manage all the resources in a single
unit or as a single unit so to summarize
stack is a collection of aws resource
and it can be managed as a single unit
and the cloud formations template
defines a stack in which the resource
can be created deleted or updated in a
very predictable way and a stack can
have all the resources like web server
database server vpc the network and the
security configurations in a vpc all
that is required to run a web or a
database application now stack could be
nested as well with cloud formation we
can actually
nest a stack with another stack and
that's going to create an hierarchy of
the stacks for example
i mean this is a very good picture that
explains how the stacks are nested in a
hierarchical way let's say stack p is
the
root stack and that could be a parent
stack for the stack called r and the
stack call q and the same way the the
stack call r is a parent stack for the
stack s and the stack s is the parent
stack for d and q you get that right so
stacks can always be nested it's
possible cloudformation allows us to
create a microsoft windows stack based
on amazon ec2 windows amis and provide
us with the ability to install software
and use remote desktop to access our
stack and update the configuration of
our stack and these stacks can be run on
windows server instances there are a
number of pre-configured templates
available and it's directly available to
use from the aws website itself to name
a few we have templates available for
sharepoint running on an
windows server 2008 r2 we also have
templates that create a single server
installation of active directory running
on a windows server and in fact we have
templates available for elastic bean
stock and some sample applications that
runs from an windows server 2008 r2
let's talk about stack sets stack sets
actually has taken the stack level
implementation to the next level using
the aws cloud formation template we can
define a stack set that lets us to
create stack in aws account across the
globe by using just a single template
and after we create the stack or after
the stack set is defined creating
updating or deleting the stack in the
target account and the regions can also
be specified by us so the stack said it
really extends the functionality of the
stacks by allowing us to create update
and delete stack across multiple
accounts regions in just a single
operation and using an administrator
account we can define and manage an aws
cloud formation template and use the
template as the basis for provisioning
stacks into you know some selected
target accounts across a specified
region let's talk about cloud formation
access control with im i can specify the
list of users or list of privileged
users who would have access to the cloud
formation template who can create update
and delete stack so that's how im helps
me with having or putting a layer of
control over the cloud formation service
and we can also use service roles
service roles are the one that allows
aws cloud formation to make a call to a
resource in a stack on the user's behalf
and i can also have stack policies and
these stack policies are applied to the
users who already have access to the
cloud formation service and these
policies are the ones that help the
users who attempt to update the stack
all right let's do a quick lab on
creating and lamp stack on an ec2
instance with a local mysql database for
storage now we can do the other way as
well i can pick an ec2 instance and
install the servers one top of the other
that can be done as well but that's
going to take a lot of time now we're
talking about automating it we're
talking about you know provisioning and
infrastructure using a code and cloud
formation helps us to do that so this is
what we're going to do we're going to
create or we have a cloudformation
template already and we're going to use
that template the provision web instance
and that is going to have look at that
that's going to have my sql installed in
it that's going to have php that's going
to have httpd servers installed in it
and running and it's also going to have
an a php website running from it so
that's going to receive information from
the website and that's going to store
that information in the database that's
very local to it
this is the template that defines
that environment
all right this is a very simple
provisioning so let's provision
this environment let's create a stack
we're going to give a stack name
and a database password
right and
which region is it this is in
california is that
all right
now let me do one thing let me switch to
the mumbai region or let me switch to
north virginia region
north virginia and from here
actually let me switch to mumbai region
all right just to be sure it's the same
template that we're provisioning
right that's the same
template that we are
provisioning right let's give this a
name so it can be great this could be
simply long
simply learn lamp stack and what could
be the db password
and db root password
and what could be the db user
i'm going to keep the rest as defaults
and i'm going to launch
all right so there's an issue with the
password
password should only have alpha
numeric characters
get that
so let's go back
and create a new password
it also needs to have
eight characters
so what can be your password
look at that the template is actually
creating the resources
and here in the screen
we can see the template that we used to
deploy the environment
if you remember we have we discussed
about
instant
types in parameters right the default
instance type is t2 small
but these are also allowed
to run
all right parameter section is the one
that was
used to receive information from us like
the db name
the db password the db root password the
user instance type key name and the ssh
locations
all right now this resource section is
is showing us the resource that it
actually uh created
right looks like it's rolling back
why would that be give me a moment
[Music]
all right this is one live example
anytime it could not provision or any if
there is an interruption
that it could not proceed it would
simply roll back and delete all the
resources that it had provisioned and
that's what it did
now let me fix this
all right as a fix i have switched the
region because i had some issue with the
vpc that's going to take time for me to
analyze and fix it so here we're going
to understand
about cloud formation so i thought i'll
run the cloud formation from another vpc
that
i know is working fine that's in not
virginia
all right let's provision a lamp server
which
is running out of linux which has apache
installed in it which has php and mysql
already installed
in it so one server going to act as web
and db server
all right so i'm going to create a stack
and from here i'm going to pick a sample
stack
if we look at if we look at it in the
designer
it's going to provision one lamp server
and a security at that security group
attached to it there you go right so
let's go ahead and create a stack
all right
parameters are used to receive
input from us
what could be the db password
and the db user
and
let's select the key name
right i'm going to keep the rest as a
defaults
and i'm going to create
a stack
all right so our stack
that we run from the template
at the moment it's getting created it's
in progress
from here i can watch the events as to
what is getting created at the moment
like i said in a lot of these would have
already sorted out
their dependencies you know which one
needs to get created first which one
needs to get created second
all that is sorted out by cloud
formation itself
and parameters are the values that we
have inputted
and a resource
tab
is a section where we can find what
resources are being provisioned at the
moment so to begin with it created a
security group
at the moment it's creating an instance
and
output
uh it's empty as of now we're gonna come
back and see it
now output is where
we can
get outputs of a finished job let's say
here i wanted an
url
of the
server that got created so instead of me
you know going to a couple of other
places within the console and
find the
output
of
the url
or
the the output of the resource that was
created i can simply get it from here
well this needs to be defined in the
templates first
once we define it in the template
it's going to be made available
like here
right so i can
open it up
and
there you go so it has it already has
a database locally installed and it's
connected to it if i launch an
application on top of it
that will get connected to the database
which is very local and
my single
uh server with web and database in it is
ready for production
now while we're talking about a lamp
server a single lamp server let's talk
about
uh creating an environment like this
which has elastic load balancer a vpc
a server running in an auto scaling
group
and putting some restrictions that
nobody will be able to access the ec2
instance directly but they should be
able to access
the ec2 instance or the data only
through the elastic load balance so this
is a bit complicated than the
environment that we've already created
let's see how this is done all right in
this lab we're going to create elastic
load balanced auto scaling group which
is going to create a load balancer and
an auto scaling group and that auto
scaling group receives
traffic only from the load balancer so
here's the template
and here's the architecture that we're
going to provision
let me call it
right and the key pair it's going to use
is
simply learn key pair
now this is where the problem was now
we were selecting few subnets
so now if i provision it
now this is going to take its
short time to provision the resources
so through parameters we can see the
values that we have inputted
and the events look good
no rollback no no deletes and
the resource section shows the resource
that
it is creating so previously created a
target group now it's creating the
application load balancer itself
all right so it created an um
load balancer and then it created a
security group it created a launch
configuration it at the moment it's
creating an web server group
and the events look good with all green
and yellow green ones are completed
yellow ones are in progress we don't
have any red delete or roll back errors
so it looks good
all right it took a while and
the resources have been created some of
them show that they are in progress but
the status of the stack is complete
all resources have been created and we
do have an output to access the url
there you go
and remember there was another feature
of the cloud formation that was it
should restrict access i mean direct
access to ec2 instance let's see if that
has been done
if i try to access using the load
balancer it lets me access
but if i try to access it using
the ec2 instance ip or the dns name my
connection
won't go through because it's blocked
through the security group but direct
access through the load balancer is
allowed and that's what we wanted to
achieve through that template here we're
going to talk about amazon ecs a service
that's used to manage docker containers
so without any further ado let's get
started in this session we would like to
talk about some basics about aws and
then we're going to immediately dive
into why amazon ecs and what is
amazon ecs in general and then it uses a
service called docker so we're going to
understand what docker is and there are
competitive services available for ecs i
mean you could ecs is not the on and
only service to manage docker containers
but why ecs advantage of ecs we will
talk about that and the architecture of
ezs so how it functions what are the
components present in it and
what are the functions that it does i
mean each and every component what are
all the functions that it does all those
things will be discussed in the
architecture of amazon acs and how it
works how it all connects together
that's something we will discuss and
what are the companies that are using
ecs what were the challenge and how ecs
helped to fix the challenge that's
something we will discuss and finally we
have a wonderful lab that talks about
how to deploy docker containers on an
amazon ecs so let's talk about what is
aws amazon web service in short called
as aws is an
web service in the cloud that provides a
variety of services such as compute
power database storage content
delivery and a lot of other resources so
you can scale your business and grow not
focus more on your it needs and the rest
of the id demands rather you can focus
on your business and let amazon scale
your it or let amazon take care of your
it so what is that you can do with aws
with aws we can create deploy any
application in the cloud so it's not
just deploying you can also create your
application in the cloud it has all the
tools and services required the tools
and services that you would have
installed in your laptop or you would
have installed in your on-premises
desktop machine for your development
environment you know the same thing can
be
installed and used from the cloud so you
can use cloud for creating and not only
that you can use the same cloud for
deploying and making your application
available for your end user the end user
could be internal internal users the end
user could be the could be in the
internet the end user could be kind of
spread all around the world it doesn't
matter so it can be used
to create and deploy your applications
in the cloud and like you might have
guessed now it provides service over the
internet that's how your users worldwide
would be able to use the service that
you create and deploy right so it
provides service
over the internet so that's for the end
customer and how will you access those
services that's again through the
internet it's like the extension of your
data center in the internet so it
provides all the services in the
internet it provides compute service
through the internet so in other words
you access them through the internet it
provides database service through the
internet over the internet in other
words you can securely access your
database through the internet and lot
more and the best part is this is a pay
as you go or pay only for what you use
there is no long term or you know
beforehand commitment
here most of the services does not have
any commitment so there is no long term
and beforehand commitment you only pay
exactly for what you use there's no
overage there's no overpaying right
there's no buying in advance right you
only pay for what you use let's talk
about what ecs is so before ecs before
containers right ecs is a service that
manages docker containers right it's not
a product or
it's not a feature all by itself it's a
service that's dependent on docker
container so before docker containers
all the applications were running on vm
or on an host or on a physical machine
right and that's memory bound that's
latency bound the server might have
issues on and on right so let's say this
is alice and she's trying to access her
application which is running somewhere
in her on premises and the application
isn't working what could be the reason
some of the reasons could be memory full
the server is currently down at the
moment we don't have another physical
server to launch the application a lot
of other reasons so a lot of reasons why
the application wouldn't be working in
on premises some of them are memory full
issue and server down issue very less a
high availability or in fact single
point of failure and no high
availability if i if i need to tell it
correctly with easiest the services can
kind of breed free right the services
can run seamlessly now how how is that
possible those thing we will discuss in
the upcoming sessions so because of
containers and ecs managing containers
the applications can run in a high
available mode they can run in a high
available mode meaning if something goes
wrong right there's another container
that gets spun up and
your application runs in that particular
container very less chances of your
application going down that's what i
mean this is not possible with
a physical a host this is very less
possible with an vm or at least it's
going to take some time for another vm
to get spun up so
why ec is or what is ecs amazon ecs
maintains the availability of the
application and allows every user to
scale containers when necessary so it
not only meets the availability of the
application meaning one container
running your application
or one container hosting your
application should be running all the
time so to meet that high availability
availability is making sure your service
is running 24 7. so container makes sure
that your services run 24 bar 7 not only
that not only that suddenly there is an
increase in demand how do you meet that
demand right let's say you have like
1000 users suddenly the next week there
are like 2000 users all right so how do
you meet that demand container makes it
very easy for you to meet that demand in
case of vm or in case of physical host
you literally will have to go buy
another physical host or
add more ram add more memory add more
cpu power to it all right or kind of
club two three uh hosts together
clustering you would be doing a lot of
other things to meet that high
availability and also to meet that
demand but in case of ecs it
automatically scales the number of
containers it automatically scales the
number of containers needed and it meets
your demand for that particular r so
what is amazon
ecs the full form of ecs is elastic
container service right so it's
basically a container management service
which can quickly launch and exit and
manage docker containers on a cluster so
it's the function of ecs it helps us to
quickly launch and quickly exit and
manage docker containers so it's kind of
a management service for the docker
containers you will be running in amazon
or running in the aws environment so in
addition to that it helps to schedule
the placement of container across your
cluster so it's like this you have two
physical hosts you know join together as
a cluster and ecs helps us to place your
containers now where should your
container be placed should it be placed
in host one should be placed in host two
so that logic is defined in ecs we can
define it you can also let ecs
take control and define that logic most
cases you will be defining it so
schedule the placement of containers
across your cluster let's say two
containers want to interact heavily you
really don't want to place them in two
different hosts right you would want to
place them in one single host so they
can interact with each other so that
logic is defined by us and these
container services you can launch
containers using aws management console
and also you can launch containers using
sdk kits available from amazon you can
launch through a java program you can
launch container using and.net program
you can launch container using an
node.js program as in when the situation
demands so there are multiple ways you
can launch containers through management
console and also programmatically and
ecs also helps to migrate application to
the cloud without changing the code so
anytime you think of migration the first
thing that comes to your mind is that
how will that environment be based on
that i'll have to alter my code what's
what's the ip what is the storage that's
being used what what are the different
parameters i'll have to include the
environment parameters of the new
environment with containers now that
worry is already taken away because we
can create and pretty exact environment
that the one that you had an on-premises
the same environment gets created in the
cloud so
no worries about changing the
application parameter no worries about
changing the code in the application but
you can be like if it ran in my laptop a
container that i was running in my
laptop it's definitely going to run in
the cloud as well because i'm going to
use the same container in the laptop and
also in the cloud in fact you're going
to ship it you're going to move the
container from your laptop to amazon ecs
and make it run there so it's like the
same the very same image the very same
container that was running in your
laptop will be running in the
cloud or production environment so what
is docker we know that it ecs helps to
quickly launch exit and manage docker
containers what is docker let's let's
answer that question what is docker now
docker is a tool
that helps to automate the development
of an application as a lightweight
container so that the application can
work efficiently in different
environments this is pretty much what we
discussed right before the slide i can
build an application in my laptop or in
on premises in a container environment
docker container environment and anytime
i want to migrate right i don't have to
kind of rewrite the code and then rerun
the code in that new environment i can
simply create an image docker image and
move that image to that production or
the new cloud environment and simply
launch it there right so no compiling
again no relaunching the application
simply pack all your code in a docker
container image and ship it to the new
environment and launch the container
there that's all so docker container is
a light weight package of software that
contains all the dependencies so because
you know when packing you'll be packing
all the dependencies you'll be packing
the code you'll be packing the framework
you'll be packing the libraries that are
required to run the application so in
the new environment you can be pretty
sure you can be guaranteed that it's
going to run because it's the very same
code it's the very same framework it's
the very same libraries that you have
shipped right there's nothing new in
that new environment it's the very same
thing that's going to run in that
container so you can be rest assured
that they are going to run in that new
environment and these docker containers
are highly scalable and they are very
efficient suddenly you wanted like 20
more docker containers to run the
application think of adding 20 more
hosts 20 more vms right how much time
would it take and compared to that time
the amount of time that docker
containers would require to kind of
scale to that amount like 20 more
containers it's very less or it's
minimal or negligible so it's an highly
scalable and it's a very efficient
service you can suddenly scale number of
docker containers to meet any additional
demand very short boot up time because
it takes a it's not going to load the
whole operating system and these docker
containers you know they use the
linux kernel and features of the kernel
like c groups and name spaces to kind of
segregate the processor so they can run
independently any environment and it
takes very less time to boot up and the
data's that are stored in the containers
are kind of reusable so you can have an
external
data volume and i can map it to the
container and whatever the space that's
occupied by the container and the data
that the container puts in that volume
they are kind of reusable you can simply
remap it to another application you can
kind of remap it to the next successive
container you can kind of remap it to
the next version of the container next
version of the application you'll be
launching and you don't have to go
through building the data again from the
scratch whatever data the container was
using previously or the previous
container was using that data is
available for the next container as well
so the volumes that the containers users
are very
reusable volumes and like i said it's
isolated application so it kind of
isolates by its nature it kind of by the
way it's designed by the way it is
created it isolates one container from
another container meaning anytime you
run applications on different containers
you can be rest assured that they are
very much isolated though they are
running on the same host though they are
running on the same laptop let's say
though they are running on the same
physical machine let's say running 10
containers 10 different applications you
can be sure that they are a well
disconnected or well isolated
applications now let's talk about the
advantages of ecs the advantage of ecs
is improved security its security is
inbuilt in ecs with ecs we have
something called as a container registry
you know that's where
all your images are stored and those
images are accessed only through https
not only that those images are actually
encrypted and access to those images are
allowed and denied through identity and
access management policies iam and
in other words let's say two container
running on the same instance now one
container can have access to s3 and the
others or the rest of the others are
denied access to s3 so that kind of
granular security can be achieved
through containers when we mix and match
the other security products available in
amazon like iam encryption accessing it
using https these containers are very
cost efficient like i already said these
are lightweight
processes right we can schedule multiple
containers on the same node and this
actually allows us to achieve high
density on an ec2 instance imagine an
ec2 instance that that's very less
utilized that's not possible with a
container because you can actually dance
or crowd an ec2 instance with more
container in it so to best use those
resources in ec2 straightforward you can
just launch one application but with
when we use containers you can launch
like 10 different applications on the
same ec2 server that means 10 different
applications can actually feed on those
resources available and can benefit the
application and ecs not only deploys the
container it also maintains the state of
the containers and it makes sure that
the minimum a set of containers are
always running based on the requirement
that's another cost
efficient way of using it right and
anytime an application fails and that
has a direct impact on the revenue of
the company and he's just make sure that
you're not losing any revenue because
your application has failed and easies
and pretty extensible services it's like
this in many organizations there are
majority of unplanned work because of
environment variation a lot of
firefighting happens when we kind of
deploy the core from one or kind of move
the core or redeploy the code in a new
environment a lot of firefighting
happens there right this docker
containers are pretty extensible like we
discussed already environment is not a
concern for containers because
it's going to kind of shut itself inside
a docker container and anywhere the
docker container can't run the
application will run exactly the way it
performed in the past so
environment is not a concern for the
docker containers in addition to that
ecs is
easily scalable we have discussed this
already and it improves it has improved
compatibility we have discussed this
already let's talk about the
architecture of ecs like you know now
the architecture of ecs is the ecs
cluster itself that's group of servers
running the ecs service and it
integrates with docker right so we have
a docker registry docker registry is a
repository where we store all the docker
images or the container images so it's
like three components ecs is of three
components one is the ecs cluster itself
right when i say easy as itself i'm
referring to easiest cluster cluster of
servers that will run the containers and
then the repository where the images
will be stored right the repository
where the images will be stored and the
image itself so container image is the
template of instructions which is used
to create a container right so it's like
what's the os what is the version of
node that should be running and any
additional software do we need so those
question gets answered here so it's the
template template of instructions which
is used to create the containers and
then the registry is the service where
the docker images are stored and shared
so many people can store
there and many people can access or if
there's another group that wants to
access they can access the image from
there or one person can store the image
and rest of the team can access and the
rest of the team can store image and
this one person can pick the image from
there and kind of ship it to the
customer or ship it to the production
environment all that's possible in this
container registry and amazon's version
of the container registry is ecr and
there's a third party docker itself has
a container registry that's docker hub
ecs itself which is the the group of
servers that runs those containers
so these two the container image and the
container registry they kind of handle
docker in an image format just an image
format and in ecs is where the container
gets live and then it becomes and
compute resource and starts to handle
requests now starts to serve the page
and starts to do the batch job you know
whatever your plan is with that
container so the cluster of servers ecs
integrates well with the familiar
services like vpc vpc is known for
securing vpc is known for
isolating the whole environment from
rest of the customers or isolating the
whole environment or the whole
infrastructure from the rest of the
clients in your account or from the rest
of the applications in your account on
and on so vpc is a service that provides
or gives you the network isolation ecs
integrates well with vpc and this vpc
enables us to launch aws resources such
as amazon ec2 instance in a virtual
private network that we specified this
is basically what we just discussed now
let's take a closer look at
the ecs how does ecs work let's find
answer for this question how does ecs
work ecs has got a couple of components
within itself so these ecs servers can
run across availability zone as you can
see there are two availability zones
here they can actually run across
availability zones and ecs has got two
modes far gate mode and the ec2 mode
right here we're seeing forget mode and
then here we're seeing nothing that
means it's an ec2 mode and then it has
got different network interfaces
attached to it because they need to be
running in an isolated fashion right so
anytime you want network isolation you
need separate ip and if you want
separate ip you need separate network
interface card and that's what you have
elastic network interface card separate
elastic network interface card for all
those tasks and services and this runs
within an vpc let's talk about the far
gate service tasks are launched using
the far gate
service so we will discuss about uh task
what is fargate now fargate is a compute
engine in ecs that allows users to
launch containers without having to
monitor the cluster ecs is a service
that manages the containers for you
right otherwise managing containers will
be and full-time job so easy manages it
for you and if you and you get to manage
ecs that's the basic service but if you
want amazon to manage ecs and the
containers for you we can go for fargate
so farget is a compute engine in ecs
that allows users to launch containers
without having to monitor the ecs
cluster and the tasks the tasks that we
discussed the tasks has two components
you see
task right here so they have two
components we have the ecs container
instance
and then the container agent so
like you might have guessed right now
ecs container instance is actually an
ec2 instance right capable of running
containers not all ec2 instances can run
containers so these are like specific
ec2 instances that can run containers
they are ecs container instances and
then we have container agent which is
the agent that actually binds those
clusters together and it does a lot of
other housekeeping work right kind of
connects clusters makes sure that
the version
needed is present so it's all part of
that agent or it's all job of that agent
container instances container instances
is part of amazon ec2 instance which run
amazon ecs container agent pretty
straightforward definition and then a
container agent is responsible for
communication between ecs and the
instance and it also provides the status
of the running containers kind of
monitors the container monitors the
state of the container make sure that
the content is up and running and if
there's anything wrong it kind of
reports it to the appropriate service to
fix the container on and on it's a
container agent when we don't manage
container agent it runs by itself and
you really don't have to do anything to
make the container agent better it's
already better you really won't be
configuring anything in the agent and
then elastic network interface card is a
virtual interface network that can be
connected to an instance in vpc so in
other words elastic network interface is
how the container interacts with another
container and that's how the container
interacts with the ec2 host and that's
how the container interacts with the
internet external world and a cluster a
cluster is a set of
ecs container instances it's not
something that's very difficult to
understand it's simply a group of ec2
instances that runs that ecs agent and
this cluster it cluster handles the
process of scheduling monitoring and
scaling the request we know that ecs can
scale the containers can scale how does
it scale that's all monitored and
managed by this ecs cluster let's talk
about the companies that are using
amazon ecs there are a variety of
companies that use
ecs clusters to name a few octa users
easiest cluster and octa is a product
that use identity information to grant
people access to applications on
multiple devices at any given point of
time they make sure that they have a
very strong security protection so okta
uses amazon ecs to run their octa
application and serve their customers
and abima abhima is an uh tv channel and
they chose to use microservices and
docker containers they already had
microservices and docker containers and
when they thought about a service that
they can use
in aws ecs was the only service that
they can immediately adapt to and
because in abima tv the engineers have
already been using docker and docker
containers it was kind of easy for them
to adapt themselves to ecs and start
using it along with the benefits that
ecs provides previously they had to do a
lot of work but now ecs does it for them
all right similarly remind and ubisoft
gopro are some of the famous companies
that use amazon ecs and get benefited
from its scalability get benefited from
its cost gets benefited from its
amazon managed services get benefited
from the portability that ecs and the
migration option that ecs provides let's
talk about how to deploy a docker
container on amazon acs the way to
deploy docker container on ecs is first
we need to have an aws account and then
set up and run our first ecs cluster so
in our lab we're going to use
the launch wizard to run an ecs cluster
and run containers in them and then task
definition task definition tells the
size of the container the number of the
container and when we talk about size it
tells how much of cpu do you need how
much of memory do you need and talking
about
numbers you know it requires how many
numbers of container you're going to
launch you know is it 5 is it 10 or is
it just one running all the time now
those kind of information goes in the
task definition file and then we can do
some advanced configuration on ecas like
load balancers and you know what port
number you want to allow when you don't
want to allow you know who gets access
who shouldn't get access and what's the
ip that you want to allow and deny
requests from on and on and this is
where we would also mention the name of
the container so to differentiate one
container from the other and the name of
the service you know is it an a backup
job is it a web application is it an uh
data container
is it gonna take care of your data data
backend and the desired number of tasks
that you want to be running all the time
those details go in when we try to
configure the ecs service right and then
you configure cluster you put in all the
security in the configure your cluster
step or configure cluster stage and
finally we will have an
instance and bunch of containers running
in that instance all right let's do a
demo so here i have logged in to my
amazon portal and let me switch to the
appropriate region i'm going to pick not
virginia north virginia look for ecs and
it tells ecs as a service that helps to
run and manage docker containers well
and good click on it i'm in north
virginia just want to make sure that i'm
in the right region and go to clusters
and here we can create cluster this is
our far gate and this is our ec2 type
launching for linux and windows
environment but i'm going to launch
through this
walkthrough portal right this gives a
lot of information here so the different
steps involved here is creating a
container definition which is what we're
going to do right now and then a task
definition and then service and finally
the cluster it's a four-step process so
in container definition we define the
image the base image we are going to use
now here i'm going to launch an
httpd or a simple http webpage right so
a simple httpd 2.4 image is fair enough
for me and it's not a heavy application
so 0.5 gigabit of memory is enough and
again it's not a heavy application so
0.25 virtual cpu is enough in our case
right you can edit it based on the
requirement you can always edit it and
because i'm using hdpd the port mapping
is already port 80 that's how the
container is going to receive the
request and there's no health check as
of now when we want to design critical
and complicated environments uh we can
include health check right and this is
the cpu that we have chose we can edit
it and i'm going to use some bash
commands to
create an html page right this page says
that you know amazon ecs sample app
right and then it says amazon ecs sample
app your application is running on a
container in amazon ecs so that's the
page the html page that i'm going to
create or index.html so i'm going to
create and put it in an appropriate
location so those pages can be served
from the container right if you replace
this with any of your own content then
it's going to be your own content ecs
comes with some basic
logs and these are the places where they
get stored that's not the focus as of
now all right so i was just saying that
you can edit it and customize it to your
needs we're not going to do any
customization now we're just getting
familiar with ecs now and the task
definition name of the task definition
is
first one task definition and then we
are running it in a vpc and then this is
an far gate mode meaning the servers are
completely handled by amazon and the
task memory is 0.5 gigabit and the tar
cpu is 0.25 virtual cpu
name of the service
is it a batch job is it an you know a
front end is it a back end or is it a
simple copy job what's the service name
of the service goes here again this you
can edit it and here's a security group
as of now i'm allowing 480 to the whole
world if i want to restrict to a certain
ip i can do that the default option for
load balancing is a no load balancer but
i can also choose to have a load
balancer and use port 80 to map that 480
to the container put 80 right i can do
that the default is no load balancer all
right let's do one thing let's use load
balancer let's use load balancer and
port 80 that receives information on
port 80 http uh what's going to be the
cluster name we're in the last step what
is the cluster name cluster name can be
simply learn ecs demo next we done and
we can create so it's launching a
cluster as you can see and it's picking
the task definition file that we've
created and it's using that to launch
and service and then these are the log
groups that we discussed and it's
creating a vpc remember ecs clubs well
with the vpc it's creating a vpc and
it's creating two subnets here for high
availability it's creating that security
group port 80 allowed to the whole world
and then it's putting it behind and load
balancer it generally would take like
five to ten minutes so we just need to
be patient and let it complete its
creation and once this is complete we
can simply access these servers using
the load balancer url and when this is
running let me actually take you to
the other products or the other services
that are integrated with the ecs it's
getting created our service is getting
created as of now ecr repository this is
where all our images are stored now as
of now i'm not pulling my image from ecr
i'm pulling it directly from the
internet docker docker hub but all
custom images all custom images they are
stored in this repository so you can
create a repository call it
app1 create a repository so here's my
repository so any image that i create
locally or any docker image that i
create locally i can actually push them
push those images using these commands
right here and they get stored here and
i can make my ecs connect with ecr and
pull images from here so they would be
my custom images and as of now because
i'm using a default image it's directly
pulling it from the internet let's go to
ec2 and look for
a load balancer because we wanted to
access the application from behind a
load balancer right so here is a load
balancer created for us
and anytime i put the url so cluster is
now created you see there's one service
running all right let's click on that
cluster here is the name of our
application and here is the tasks the
different containers that
we are running and if you click on it we
have an ip right ip of that container
and it says it's running it was created
at such and such time and started at
such and such time and this is the task
definition file that it this container
uses meaning the template the details
the all the version details they all
come from here and it belongs to the
cluster called
simply learn ecs demo right and you can
also get some logs container logs from
here so let's go back and there are no
ecs instances here because remember this
is forget you're not managing any ecs
instance all right so that's why you're
not seeing any ecs instance here so
let's go back to task and go back to the
same page where we found the ip pick
that ip put it in the browser and you
have this
sample html page running from an
container so let me go back to load
balancer ec2 and then under ec2 i'll be
able to find a load balancer find that
load balancer pick that dns name put it
in the browser and now it's accessible
to the load balancer url right now this
url can be mapped to other services like
dns this url can be embedded in any of
your application if you want to make
that application connect with this
container now using ip is not all that
advisable because these containers can
die and then a new container gets
created and when a new container gets
created it gets a new ip right so a hard
coding ip is
not hard coding dynamic ips are not
advisable so you would be using load
balancer and putting that url in that
application that you want to make it
interact with this container instance it
was a wonderful experience in walking
you through this ecs topic and in here
we learned about what aws is and why we
using ecs
and what is easiest in general what is
docker in specific and we also learn
about the advantages of ecs the
architecture the different components of
ecs and how ecs works when they're all
connected together and we also looked at
the companies that use ecs and their use
cases and finally a lab how we can
launch ecs for gate through the portal
in this section
we are going to talk about
basics of aws and then we're going to
immediately dive into
why
why we need amazon route 53 and then
we're going to expand and talk about the
details of amazon route 53 the benefits
it provides over its competitors and the
different types of routing policy it has
and some of amazon ralph 53's key
features and we're going to talk about
how to access route 53 i mean the
different ways the different methods you
can access route 53 and finally we're
going to end with an a wonderful demo in
drop 53 so let's talk about what is aws
amazon web services or aws in short is a
cloud provider that offers a variety of
services such as a variety of id
services or infrastructure services such
as a compute power database content
delivery and other resources that helps
us to scale and grow our business and
aws is hard aws is picking up aws is
being adapted by a lot of customers
that's because aws is easy to use even
for a beginner and talking about safety
the the aws infrastructure is designed
to keep the data safe irrespective of
the size of the data with small data be
it very minimal data be it all the data
that you have in terabytes and in
petabytes amazon can keep it safe in
their environment and the wonderful
thing and the most important reason why
a lot of customers move into the cloud
is that the pay-as-you-go pricing there
is no long-term commitment and it's very
cost effective what this means is that
you're not paying for a resource that
you're not using in on premises you do
pay for resources you're not using a lot
meaning you go and buy a server you do
the estimate for the next five years and
only after like three or four years
you'll be hitting the peak capacity but
still you would be buying that capacity
before four years right and then you
will gradually be you know utilizing it
from you know 40 percent date 60 days 70
80 and then 100. so what you have done
is that even though you're not using the
full capacity you still have bought it
and are and are paying for it from day
one but in the cloud it's not like that
you only pay for the resources that you
use anytime you want more you scale up
the resource and you you pay for the
scaled up resource and anytime you want
less you scale down the resource and you
pay less for that scaled down resource
let's talk about why amazon
route 53 let's take this scenario where
rachel is trying to open her web browser
and
the url that she hit isn't working a lot
of reasons behind why the url isn't
working it could be the server
utilization that went high it could be
it could be the uh memory usage that
went high a lot of reasons and she
started to think is there an efficient
way to scale resources according to the
user requirements or is there an
efficient way to kind of mask all those
failures and kind of divert the traffic
to the appropriate active you know
active resource or active service that's
running our application you always want
to hide the failures right in it kind of
mask the failure and direct the customer
to another healthy service that's
running right none of your customers
would want to see a server not available
or you know none of the customers your
customers would want to see your service
not working not impressive to them and
this is tom tom is an i.t guy and he
comes up with an idea and he's answering
rachel yes we can scale resources
efficiently using amazon rod53 in a
sense he's saying that yes we can mask
the failure and we can keep the services
up and running meaning we can provide
more high availability to our customers
with the use of route
and then he goes on and explains amazon
drop 53 is a dns servers that gives
developers an efficient way to connect
users to internet applications without
any downtime now downtime is the key
amazon route 53 helps us to avoid any
downtime that customers will experience
you still will have downtime in your
server and your application but your
customers will not be made aware of it
and then rachel is kind of interested
and she's like yeah that sounds
interesting i want to learn more about
it and tom goes on and explains the
important concepts of amazon rock 53
that's everything that i'm gonna explain
it to you as well all right so what is
amazon rat53 amazon drop 53 is a highly
scalable dns or domain name system web
service this service this amazon rock 53
it functions three main things or it has
three main functions so the first thing
is if a website needs a name route 53
registers the name for the website
domain let's say you want to buy
google.com you want to buy the domain
name let's say you want to buy that
domain name you buy that through route53
secondly a route53 is the service that
actually connects your
server which is running your application
or which is holding which is serving
your web page so that's the service that
actually route 53 is the service that
connects the user to your server when
they hit google.com in the browser or
whatever domain name that you have
purchased so you bought a domain name
and the user types in
yourdomainname.com and then roth53 is a
service that helps the user to connect
their browser to the application that's
running in an ec2 instance or any other
server that you are using to serve that
content and not only that route53 checks
health of the resource by sending
automated requests over the internet to
a resource so that's how it identifies
if there is any resource that has failed
can i say resource i'm referring to any
infrastructure failure any application
level failure so it kind of keeps
checking so it understands it first
before the customer notices it and then
it does the magic kind of shifts the
connection from a one server to the
other server we call it routing we will
talk about that as we progress so the
benefits of using rough 53 it's highly
scalable meaning suddenly let's say the
number of requests the number of people
trying to access your website through
that domain name that you have bought
let's say it has increased ralph 53 is
highly scalable right it can handle even
millions and millions of requests
because it's highly scalable and it's
managed by amazon uh the same thing it's
reliable it's a highly scalable it can
handle large queries without the users
without you interacting without the user
who bought it interact with it you don't
have to scale up you know when you're
expecting more requests it automatically
uh scales and it is very reliable in a
sense that
it's very consistent it has the ability
to route the users to the appropriate
application through the logic that it
has it's very easy to use when we do the
lab you're gonna see that it's very easy
easy to use you buy the domain name and
then you simply map it to the
application you simply map it to the
server by putting in the ip or if you
you can simply map it to another load
balancer by putting in the load balancer
url you can simply map it to another
s3 bucket by simply putting the s3
bucket name or the sd bucket url it's
pretty straightforward easy to set up
and it's very cost effective in a way
that we only pay for the service that we
have used so no wastage of money here so
the billing is set up in such a way that
you are paying only for the amount of
requests that
you have received right the amount of
traffic the amount of requests that you
have received and couple of other things
the the number of uh
posted zones that you have created right
and a couple of other things it it's
very cost effective in such a way that
you only pay for the service that you
are using and it's secure in a way that
access to raw 53 is
integrated with identity and access
management iam so you only have
authorized users
gain access to route 53 the trainee who
just joined yesterday won't get access
and the contractor or the consultant the
third party consultant you have given
access or who is using your environment
you can block access to that particular
person because he's not the admin or
he's not a privileged user in your
account so only privileged users and
admin gain access to route 53 through
iam now let's talk about the routing
policies so when you create a record in
in route 53 recorder is nothing but an
entry so when you do that you choose a
routing policy right routing policy is
nothing but it determines how route 53
responds
to your queries how the dns queries are
being responded right that's that's a
record or that's a routing policy so the
first one is a simple routing policy so
we use simple
routing policy for a single resource in
other words simple routing allows to
configure dns with no special route 53
routing it's kind of one to one you use
an single resource that performs a given
function to your domain for example if
you want to simply map an url to a web
server that's pretty straightforward
simple routing so it routes traffic to a
single resource example web server to a
website and with simple routing multiple
records with the same name cannot be
created
but multiple values can be created in
the same record the second type of
routing policy is failover routing so we
would be using failover routing when we
want to configure
active passive failover if something
failed right you want to fail over to
the next resource which was previously
the backup resource now the active
resource or which was previously the
backup server now it's an active server
so you would be failing over to that
particular resource or that particular
ip if you want to do that we use
failover routing so failover routing
routes traffic to a resource when the
resource is healthy or to a different
resource when the previous resource is
unhealthy in other words anytime a
resource goes unhealthy i mean it does
all that's needed to shift the traffic
from the primary resource to the
secondary resource in other words from
the unhealthy resource to the healthy
resource and this records can draw
traffic to
anything from an
amazon
s3 bucket or you can also configure a
complex tree of records now when we
configure the records it will be more
clear to you so as of now just
understand that route53 can route or
this routing policy the failover routing
policy can route traffic to amazon s3
bucket or to a website that has complex
tree of records geolocation routing
policy now geolocation routing just like
the name says it takes that routing
decision based on the geographic
location of the user in other words you
know when you want to roll traffic based
on the location of the user that's your
primary criteria for you know sending
that request to the appropriate server
we will be using geo location routing so
it localizes the content and presents a
part or the entire website in the
language of the user for example a user
from us
you would want to direct them to an
english website and a user from german
if you want to send them to the german
website and a user from france you know
you want to send those requests or you
want to show content specific to a
customer who lives in france a french
website so this is if that's your
condition this is the routing policy we
would be using and the geographic
locations are specified by either
continent or by country or by state in
the united states so only in the united
states you can actually split it to
state level and for the rest of the
countries you can do it on a country
level on a high level you can also do it
on a continent level the next type of
routing policy would be your proximity
routing geoproximity routing policy when
we want to route traffic based on the
location of our resource and optimally
shift traffic from resources in one
location to resource in another location
we would be using geoproximity
routing so geoproximity routing routes
traffic to the resources based on the
geographic location of the user and the
resources they want to access and it
also has an option to route more traffic
or less to a given resource by
specifying a value known as a bias kind
of weight but we also have weighted
routing that's different so we've chosen
different name bias you can send more
traffic to a particular resource by
having a bias on that particular routing
condition and a bias expands or shrinks
the size of the geographic region from
which traffic is routed to a resource
and then we have latency based routing
just like the name says we use latency
based routing if we have resources in
multiple aws regions and if you want to
route traffic to the region that
provides the best latency at any given
point of time so
let's say if one single website needs to
be installed and hosted on multiple aws
regions then latency routing policy is
what is being used it improves the
performance of the users by serving the
request from the aws region that
provides the lowest
latency so at any given point if
performance is your criteria and at any
given point of time irrespective of what
happens in amazon infrastructure
irrespective of what happens in the
internet if you want to route your users
to the best performing website best
performing region then we would be using
latency based routing and for using
latency based routing we should create
latency records for the resources in
multiple aws regions and then the other
type of
a routing policy is a multi-value
routing policy where we can make route
53 to respond to dns queries with up to
eight healthy records selected at
random so you're not kind of loading
one particular server we can define
eight records and on a random basis
route 53 will respond to queries from
these eight records so it's not one
server that gets all the requests but
eight servers
gets the request in a random fashion so
it's multi-value routing policy and what
we get by this is that we are
distributing the traffic to many servers
instead of just one server so
multi-value routing configures rod 53 to
return multiple values in response to a
single or multiple dns queries it also
checks the health of
order sources and returns the multiple
values only for the healthy resources
let's say out of the eight servers we
have define one server is not doing
healthy it will not respond to the query
with the details of the unhealthy server
right so now it's gonna treat it as only
seven servers in the list because one
server is unhealthy and it has the
ability to return multiple health
checkable ip addresses to improve
availability and
load balancing the other type of routing
policy is weighted routing policy and in
here we use
to route traffic or this is used to
route traffic to multiple resources in a
proportion that we specify so this is an
weighted routing and weighted routing
routes multiple resources to a single
domain name or a sub domain and control
the traffic that's routed to each
resources so this is very useful when
you're doing load balancing and testing
new versions of the software so when you
have a new version of the software you
really don't want to send 100 of the
traffic to it so you want to get
customers feedback about the new
software that you've launched new
version or new application that you've
launched so you would kind of send only
20 of the traffic to that application
get customer feedback and if all is good
then we would move the rest of the
traffic to that new application so any
software launches application launches
will be using weighted routing now let's
talk about the key benefits or key
features of route53 some of the key
features of rouse53 are a traffic flow
it routes end users to the endpoint that
should provide the best user experience
that's what we discussed in the routing
policies right it uses a routing policy
a latency based routing policy and jio
based routing policy and then failover
routing policy so it kind of improves
the user experience and the key feature
the other key feature of route 53 is we
can buy domain names using roth 53 using
route 53 console we can buy it from here
and use it in route53 previously it was
not the case but now we can buy it
directly from amazon through route 53
and we can assign it to any resources
that we want so anybody browsing that
url the connection will be directed to
the server in aws that runs our website
a health checks it monitors health and
performance of the application so it
comes with an health check attached to
it health check are useful to make sure
that the unhealthy resources are retired
right the unhealthy resources are taken
away or your customers are not kind of
hitting the unhealthy resources and they
see an
service down page or something like that
we can have weighted
round robin load balancing that's
helpful in spreading
traffic between
several services or servers we are round
robin algorithm so no one server is
fully hit or no one server kind of fully
absorbs all the traffic you know you can
shift you can split and shift the
traffic to different servers based on
the weight that you would be configuring
and also weighted routing also helps
with
a soft launch soft launch of your new
application or the new version of your
website there are different ways we can
access amazon route 53 so you can access
amazon rot 53 through aws console you
can also access amazon route 53 using
aws sdks and we can access it using we
can configure it using the apis and we
can also do it through the command line
interface that's linux type linux flavor
aws command line interface we can also
do that using windows command line
windows powershell flavored command line
interface as well now let's look at some
of the companies that are using ros 53
so some of the famous companies that use
route 53 are
medium medium is an online publishing
platform and
it's more like a social
journalism it's kind of having hybrid
collection of
professionals people and publications or
exclusive blogs or publishers on medium
it's kind of an blog website and that
uses rot53 for the dns service a reddit
is an uh social news aggregation or web
content rating and discussion website
that uses route 53 so these are some
websites that that are accessed
throughout the world and they are using
roth 53 and it's highly scalable
suddenly there is a new news right their
website will be accessed a lot and
they need to keep their service up and
running all the time more availability
otherwise
customers will end up in a broken page
and
the number of customers who will be
using the website will come down so it's
very critical these sites these
companies are very critical you know
they're being highly available their
page their site being highly available
and the internet is very critical and
crucial for them and they rely and use
route 53 to meet that particular demand
and airbnb is
another company uh instacart kozara is
another company stripe is another
company that uses route53 to as their
dns
provider for their dns
service they use route53 so their
customers get best performance they use
raw 53 so their website is highly
available they use route 53 to kind of
shift to the traffic between the
resources so their resources are
properly used with all the weighted
routing the resources are properly
used now let's quickly look at a demo
i'm in my aws console and i'm in route53
so let me click on rot53 so in this lab
we're actually going to simulate buying
a domain name and then we're going to
create an s3 static website and we're
going to map that website to this
dns name right so the procedure is the
same for mapping load balancer the
procedure is the same for mapping
cloudfront the procedure is the same for
mapping ec2 instances as well we're
picking s3 for simplicity right but our
focus is actually on route53 so let's go
in here and i will see if we can but we
will buy a domain name here so let's
first check the availability of a domain
name called simply learn hyphen demo
hyphen route53 let's check its
availability it is available for 12 so
let me add it to cart and then come back
here and then once you continue it will
ask for personal information once you
give the personal information you
finally check out and then it gets added
to your shopping list once you pay for
it amazon takes like 24 to 40 hours to
make that a dns name available so the
next stage would be contact details and
then the third stage would be
verify and purchase
so once we have bought the domain name
it will become available in our dns
portal and so i can go to hosted zone
and simply start creating i can go to
hosted zone and then here it's going to
list all the domain names for me right
click on the domain name and then click
on the record set and here i can
actually map elastic load balancer s3
website vpc endpoint api gateway and
cloudfront elastic bean stock domain
names right all that gets mapped through
this portal quite simple like four or
five step
button clicks and then it'll be done so
i have an
domain name bot and then i'm gonna go to
s3 and i'll show you what i've done in
s3 so i've created a bucket name called
as a dns name let me clear the content
in them so i've created a bucket and
then permissions i've turned off public
access blocking and then i've created
and a bucket policy so this bucket is
now publicly accessible and then i went
on the properties and created the static
website hosting right and i've pointed
that this is the file that's my index
file that i'm going to put or name of
the file that's going to be my index
file that i'm going to put in this s3
bucket so put the index file.html saved
it
and
we're going to create a file now we're
going to create an index file so this is
a sample code it says amazon.53 getting
started routing internet traffic to s3
bucket for your website and then a
couple of other information so save it
as an
index.html file in my desktop so let me
upload that from my desktop into this
bucket so that's index.html and it's in
capital i so let me go to properties and
go to static website hosting and make
sure that i spell it properly right it's
case sensitive and then save it so now
this means that my website should be
running through this url and it does
it's running through the static website
url we're halfway through so now let me
go back to route53 go back to route53 go
back to hosted zones go into the domain
name and then create a record set and
it's going to be an alias record and
i i see my s3 static website endpoint
there right so click on it and create it
has now created an
record that's pointing my domain name to
the s3 endpoint that i have created and
my static website is running from it so
let me test it right so let me go to the
browser put the domain name in there and
sure enough the domain name when my
browser queried for the domain name a
route 53 returned a response saying this
domain name is actually mapped to the s3
bucket static website hosting enabled s3
bucket and this is the url for that
static website hosting and then my
browser was able to connect to that s3
bucket and download the details and show
it in my browser right so it's that
simple and pretty straight forward let
me help you understand aws elastic bean
stock so what's in it for you we'll be
discussing about what is aws why we
require aws elastic bean stock what is
aws elastic bean stock the advantages
disadvantages the components of uh mean
stock along with that the architecture
and the companies that are primarily
using the aws bean stock so let's get
started and first understand what is aws
aws stands for amazon web services it's
a cloud provider and that offers a
variety of services such as compute
power database storage content delivery
and many other resources so we know that
aws is the largest
cloud provider in the market and so many
services are available in the aws where
you can apply the business logics and
create the solutions using the cloud
platforms now why aws elastic means
stock now what happened earlier and that
whenever the developer used to create
the software or the modules related to
the softwares it has to be joined
together to create a big application now
one developer creates a module that has
to be shared with another developer and
if the developers are geographically
separated then it has to be shared over
a medium probably an internet so that is
going to take some time it would be a
difficult process and in return it uh
makes the application or a software
development a lender process the
building of the software development
lender process so there were challenges
uh which the developers were facing
earlier and uh to overcome that uh we
have the beanstalk as a service
available in the aws so why aws elastic
bean stock is required uh aws elastic
being stock has made the life of the
developers quite easy uh in terms of
that they can share the applications
across different devices at a shorter
time duration now let's understand what
is aws elastic bean stock
aws elastic bean stock is a service
which is used to deploy and scale web
applications by developers not only web
application any application that is
being developed by the developers this
is a simple representation of the aws
elastic bean stock now along with that
the aws elastic bean stock supports the
programming language the runtime
environments that are java.net php
node.js python rubygo and docker and in
case if you're looking for any other
programming language or a runtime
environment then you can make a request
with aws to arrange that for you now
what are the advantages associated with
the elastic bean stock first advantage
is that it's a highly scalable service
now when we talk about a scalability it
means that whenever we require the
resources in demand we can scale up the
resources or we can scale down the
resources so that is kind of a
flexibility we get in terms of changing
the type of resources whenever we need
it and in that case the elastic bean
stock is a highly scalable service now
that is something which is very
difficult to achieve in case of an
on-prem environments because you have to
plan for the infrastructure and in case
if you're short of the resources within
that infrastructure then you have to
procure it again the second advantage
associated with the beanstalk is that
it's a fast and simple to begin now when
we say it's fast and simple that means
that you just have to focus on the
development of an application building
an application and then you can just
deploy the application directly using
the beanstalk what the beanstalk is
going to do that every networking aspect
is being taken care by the bean stock it
deploys your application in the back end
on the servers and then you can directly
access your application using the url or
through the ip address the third
advantage is that it offers the quick
deployment that is what we discussed in
the fast and simple to begin as well so
why it offers a quick deployment you
don't have to bother about the
networking concepts you just have to
focus on the application development and
then you can just upload your
application deploy that and then you're
good to go the other advantage is that
it supports multi-tenant architecture
when we talk about tenants or
multi-tenants that means we can have a
virtual environments for separate
organizations or the divisions within
the organizations that will be virtually
isolated so likewise you can have uh
virtually isolated environments created
on the bean stock and they can be
separated used as a separate entities or
a separate divisions within the
organization and we know that it's a
flexible service since it's a scalable
then it is a flexible also now coming to
the simplifies operations as an
advantage now once the application is
deployed using the beanstalk then it
becomes very easy to maintain and
support that application using the
beanstalk services itself and the last
advantage that we can have from the
beanstalk is that it's a cost efficient
service the cost efficient as we know
that many of the aws services are cost
effective the cost optimization can be
better managed using the aws mean stock
as compared to if you are developing or
if you are deploying any kind of an
application or a solution on the on-prem
servers now there are some components
that are associated with the aws
beanstalk and it has to be created in
the form of a sequence manner so aws
elastic bean stock consists of few
important components which are required
while developing an application now what
are these components these are four
components one is application the second
is application version the third is
environment and the fourth one is the
environment tier and we have to progress
while deploying our applications or the
softwares using the same sequence now
let's understand what are the different
components of the mean stock r the
application it refers to a unique label
which is used as a deployable code for a
web application so generally you deploy
your web application or you create your
application and that is something which
is basically
used as a unique label then the second
component is application versions so it
resembles a folder which stores a
collection of components
such as environments versions and
environment configurations so all these
components are being stored using the
application version the third most
important component is the environment
in the environment only the current
versions of the applications runs now
remember that elastic means stock
supports multiple versions as well and
using the environment you can only run
the current version of the application
for if you wanted to have another
version of an application to be running
then you have to create another
environment for that then comes the
environment here and in the environment
here it is basically it designates the
type of application that the environment
runs on now generally there are two
types of environment here one is the web
and the other one is the worker node and
that's something which we'll be
discussing later as well now let's
understand how does elastic beam stock
in aws works so first we have to create
an application and this is a task that
would be done by the developers and for
that you can actually select any runtime
environment or a programming language
like java docker ruby gopal or python as
well and once you select that
environment
you can
develop your application using that
runtime environments now after that once
the application is created then you have
to upload the version of an application
on the aws and after that
once the version is uploaded and then
you have to launch your environment so
just have to click on the buttons that's
it nothing more you have to do once the
environment is
launched then you can actually view that
environment using a web url or using the
ip address now what happens in that case
is when you launch an environment in the
back end the elastic bean stock runs
automatically runs an ec2 instance and
using a metadata the mean stock deploys
our application within that ec2 instance
that is something which you can look
into the ec2 dashboard as well so you
don't have to take care of the security
groups you don't have to take care of
the ip addressing and even you don't
have to log in into the instance and
deploy your application it would be done
automatically by the bean stock it's
just that you just have to monitor the
environment and the statistics will be
available there itself in the beanstalk
dashboard otherwise you can view those
statistics in the
cloudwatch logs as well now in case if
you wanted to update any kind of a
version then you just upload a new
version and then just deploy that and
then monitor your environment so these
are the essentials to create a local
applications for any platform whether
it's a node.js python etc these are the
things that you have to actually take
care and this is the sequence you have
to follow while creating an environment
so you can say that it's a four steps
creation offer or deployment of your
application that's it now after users
upload their versions the configuration
is automatically deployed with a load
balancer yes and with the load balancer
that means you can access the
applications using the load balancer dns
also and apart from load balancer if you
wanted to put any other feature that
includes the auto scaling for example if
you wanted to create your ec2 instances
where the application will be deployed
within the virtual private cloud or in a
particular subnet within the vpc all
those features that are available and
you can select them using the mean stock
itself you don't have to move out to the
vpc you don't have to actually go to the
ec2 dashboard and select all those
separately everything would be available
within the beanstalk dashboard so that's
what it says in the presentation that
after creating an application the deploy
service can be specifically accessed
using the url so once the environment is
created there will be a url defined now
you can put a url name also that is
something which you wanted to put for
your application you can define that you
can check for the availability of that
url and then you have to use that url to
access your application or the browser
now once it is done then in the monitor
environment it says the environment is
monitored provided capacity provisioning
load balancing auto scaling and hand
multi features all those features are
available there itself in the mean stock
now let's understand the architecture of
aws elastic green stock now there are
two types of environments that you have
to select you can select one is the web
server environment and the other one is
the worker environment so based on the
client requirement beanstalk gives you
two different types of environment that
you have to select generally the web
server environment is the front end
facing that means the client should be
accessing this environment directly
using a url so mostly web applications
are deployed using that environment the
worker environment is the backend
applications or on the micro apps which
are basically required to support the
running of the web applications now it
depends on the client requirement what
kind of an environment you wanted to
select now in the web server environment
it only handles the http request from
the client so that's why we use the web
application which works on the http
https request so it's not only the http
you can use the https as well the worker
environment it process background task
and minimizes the consumption of
resources so again it is just like a
kind of a micro service or an
application services that are running in
the back end to support the web server
environment now coming to the
understanding of the aws mean stock so
this is how the architecture of the aws
bean stock is designed and you can refer
to that image also now in the web server
environment let's say if we select a web
server environment and it says that if
the application receives client request
the amazon route 53 sends these requests
to the elastic load balancer now
obviously we discussed here that the web
server environment is primarily an
environment which receives the http
request it's a kind of a client-facing
environment now if the application
receives a client request amazon from
the amazon note 53 this route 53 is a
service which is primarily used for dns
mapping it's a global service and it may
route you can route the traffic from the
route 53 matching your domains towards
the load balancer and from the load
balancer you can point that traffic to
the web server environment obviously the
web server environment is nothing it's
just the ec2 instances that would be
running in the back end now here in the
diagram you can see that there are two
web server environments and they are
created in the auto scaling group that
means there is some kind of scaling
options that are defined as well and
these instances are created in an
availability zone or they can be created
in a different availability zone also
for the redundancy as well and these web
application servers are further
connected to your databases which
primarily will be in a different
security groups probably it can be an
rds database also so all these
functionalities all these features are
basically available on the elastic mean
stock dashboard itself now what happens
in that case is if the application
receives client requests amazon route 53
send these requests to the load balancer
later the load balancer shares those
requests among the ec2 instances how
does that happen it happens using a
predefined algorithm the equal
distribution of a load is distributed to
both the ec2 instances or n number of
ac2 instances running in the
availability zone now in the
availability zones every ec2 instance
would have its own security group they
can have a common security group also
they can have their own security group
as well now after the security group the
load balancer is then connected to the
amazon ec2 instance which are part of
the auto scaling group so that's
something which we have discussed
already now this auto scaling group is
would be defined from the bean stock
itself and there will be some scaling
options that will be created it could be
a possibility that it might be the
minimum number of instances that would
be running as of now and based on the
threshold defined it may increase the
number of ec2 instance and the load
balancer will keep on distributing the
load to as many instances that will be
created inside the availability source
obviously there will be an internal
health check that the load balancer will
be first doing before distributing the
real-time traffic to this instances
created by the mean stock now what does
auto scaling group does it automatically
starts the additional ec2 instance to
accommodate increasing load on your
application that's something which we
know that and also it monitors and
scales instances based on the workload
as well so depends on what kind of a
scaling threshold you have defined in
the auto scaling groups and when the
load of an application decreases the ec2
instance will also be decreased so
whenever we talk about the auto scaling
generally it comes in our mind is that
we scale up the resources that means we
it increases the ec2 instances in the
auto scaling you might have the scaled
down option also scaled down policy also
created in which if the load minimizes
it can terminate the additional ec2
instances as well so that is something
which will be automatically managed all
these features can be achievable using
the elastic beanstalk and with this
feature accommodated it gives you the
better cost optimization in terms of
managing your resources now it says that
elastic bean stock has a default
security group and the security group
acts as a firefall for the instances now
here in this diagram it says about the
security group auto scaling also you
might create it in a default vpc also
you might create it in your custom vpc
also where you find here before the
security groups so that would give you
the additional filtering option or the
firewall option now it says that with
these groups with these security groups
it allows establishing security groups
to the database server as well so every
database would also have its own
security group and the connection can be
created between the web servers
environment that is created by the
beanstalk to the database security
groups as well now let's discuss about
the worker environment now understanding
the worker environment what happens is
that the client the web server
environment is the client facing the
client sends a request for an access to
the web server and in this diagram the
web server further sends it to the sqs
which is a simple queue service and the
queue service sends it to the worker
environment and then whatever the worker
environment is created for doing some
kind of a processing or some kind of an
application that is running in the back
end that environment initiates and then
send back
the results to this sqs and vice versa
so let's understand the architecture of
aws elastic bean stock with the worker
environment so when a worker environment
here is launched aws elastic meanstalk
installs the server on every ec2
instance so that is in the case of a web
server environment also and later the
server passes the request to the simple
queue service now this service is an
asynchronous service instead of a simple
queue service you can have other
services also it is not necessary that
you need to have the sqs also this is an
example that we are discussing about and
the sqs shares those message via a post
request to the http path over the worker
environment and there are many case
studies also with respect to this kind
of an environment that is being created
that has been done on many customers
and you can search for these kind of a
case studies available on the internet
now the worker environment executes the
task given by the sqs with the http
response after the operation is
completed now here what happens is a
quick recap the client request for an
access of an application to a web server
using an http request the web server
passes that request to the queue service
the queue service shares the message
with the worker probably a worker might
be
the manual worker and generally it's an
automated worker so it would be shared
by the worker environment only and the
worker sends back the response with the
http response back to the queue that
response can be viewed directly from the
queue service by the client using the
web server so this is one of the example
likewise as i said that there can be
many other examples also where you can
have the worker environments defined now
what are the companies that are using
the elastic bean stock these are few of
the companies that are primarily using
on zillow jelly button games
then you have league of women waters
ebery
these are some of the few listed
companies and obviously you search on
the aws site and you'll find many more
organizations that are using the elastic
bean stock primarily for deploying their
applications now the next thing is to go
with the practicals that how actually we
use the elastic bean stock so let's look
into the demo using the aws elastic bean
stock now first you have to login into
the aws console and i'm sure that you
might be having the accounts created or
you can use the im credentials as well
and then you have to select the region
also now i am in the north virginia
region likewise you can select any of
the regions that are listed here now
click on the services and you have to
search for the elastic bean stock you
can find the elastic bean stock under
the compute section so here itself
you'll find the elastic bean stock as a
service now open this service and there
it will give you an option to create an
environment you have to specifically
select an environment probably a worker
environment or a web service environment
so let's wait for the service to open so
we have the dashboard now available with
us this is how the elastic bean stock
looks and this is the symbol
representation of a beanstalk now what
you have to do is we have to click on
get started and that will load and you
have to create a web app so instead of
creating a web app what we'll do we'll
create a new application so just click
on create a new application put an
application name let's say we put
something like x y z you can put any
description to your application let's
say it's a demo app and click on create
now it says you have to select an
environment
now the environment the application name
xyz is created you just have to select
the nav environment so click on create
one now and it is going to ask you that
what kind of an environment here you
wanted to select so as we discussed that
there are two types of environments one
is the web server and the other one is
the current one let's look into it what
is defined by the aws aw says that it
has two types of environment tiers to
support different types of web
applications web servers are standard
applications that listen for and then
process http request typically over port
number 80. workers are specialized
application that have a background
processing task that listens for message
on an amazon sqs queue workers
application post those messages to your
application by using the http response
so that's what we saw in the case of the
beanstalk slides also now the usability
of a worker environment can be anything
now we'll do a demo for creating a web
server environment so just click on
select and you we have the environment
name created now we can define our own
domain it ends with the region dot
elastic beanstalk.com let's say i look
for a domain which is xyz only that's
the environment name now i'll check for
the availability whether that domain
name is available with us or not and it
says we don't have that domain name so
probably i'll try to make it with some
other name and let's look for the
availability xyz abc and it says yes it
is available now once i deploy my
application i would be able to access
the application using this complete dns
so you can put a description it's a demo
app that we are creating and then you
have to define a platform as well now
these are the platforms that are
supported by the aws let's say i wanted
to run a node.js environment so i'll
just click on the node.js platform the
application codes is something
which is basically developed by the
developers and you can upload the app
application right now or you can do that
later as well once the environment is
ready now either you can select to
create an environment if you wanted to
go with all the default otherwise if you
wanted to customize it more you can
click on configure more options so let's
click on configure more options and here
you would be able to define various
different features like the type of an
instance for example what kind of an ec2
instance or a server that should be
running so that the bin stock can deploy
your applications over it if you wanted
to modify just click on a modify button
and here you can modify your instances
with respect to the storage as well now
apart from that if you wanted to do some
modification in the case of monitoring
in the case of databases in the case of
security or in the case of a capacity
let's look into the capacity so here you
can actually do the modification so in
the capacity you can select the instance
type also by default it is t2.micro but
in case if your application requires a
larger type of an instance then you can
actually go for the instance type as
well similarly you can define your emi
ids also because obviously for the
application to run you would require the
operating system also so you can select
that particular ami id for your
operating system as well let's cancel
that likewise you have many other
features
that you can actually define here from
the dashboard and you don't have to go
to the ec2 dashboard to do the
modifications now let's go and create an
environment let's assume that we are
going with the default configuration so
this is going to create our environment
the environment is being created and you
can get the environment and the
logs defined in the dashboard itself so
you'll see that the beanstalk
environment is being initiated the
environment is being started and in case
if there would be any errors or if it is
deployed correctly you'll get all the
logs here itself now the environments
are basically color coded so there are
different color codings that are defined
if you get the environment in a green
color that means everything is good to
go so here you can see that
it has created an elastic ip it has
checked the health of the environment
now it has created the security groups
and that would be an auto security
groups created by the bean stock and the
environment
creation has been started you can see
that
elastic bean stock has amazon s3 storage
bucket for your environment data as well
this is the url through which you will
be accessing the environment but right
now we cannot do it since the
environment is being created let's click
on the application name and here you can
see that it is in a gray color that
means right that's what we are familiar
with and let's see what's there in the
dashboard so here you can see one
running instance let's open that and the
xyz environment which was created from
the beanstalk is being initiated the
instance is being initiated and that is
something which is being done by the
bean stock itself we have not gone to
the dashboard and created it manually
now in the security groups if you see
that here the aws mean stock security
groups are defined it has the elastic
ips also defined so everything is being
created by the beanstalk itself right
now let's go back to the beanstalk and
let's look into the status of our
environment whether the color coding has
been changed from gray to green or not
and here you can see the environment is
successfully created and we have that
environment colored in green we will
access the environment and it says it's
a web server environment its platform is
node.js running on 64-bit amazon linux
ami and it says amp
sample application health status is okay
now the other thing is that if you do
not want to use the web console the
management console to access the main
stock then the bean stock offers you the
elastic bean stock cli as well so you
can install the command line interface
cli commands that you can actually look
into now let's look into the environment
let's click on the environment and we'll
be represented with the url it says
health is okay
these are the logs that you have to
follow in case if there are any issues
the platform is nodejs that is what we
selected now the next thing is you just
have to upload and deploy your
applications so just click on upload and
deploy select the version label or the
name select file and wherever your
application is hosted at just select
that upload it and deploy your
application you'll see that the like
your environment is created similarly
your application will be deployed
automatically on the instance and from
this url you will be able to view the
output it is as simple as just like you
have to follow these four steps now
let's see whether the node.js
environment is running on our instance
before deploying an application so we'll
just click on this url since the
beanstalk has already opened up the
security groups or http from the url so
we have the node.js running that's
visible here and after that you just
have to upload and deploy your
application and then from that url you
can get the output now this url you can
map it with the root 53 service so using
the route 53 dns services the domain
names can be pointed to the elastic
beanstalk url and from there it can be
pointed to the applications that are
running on the ec2 instance whether you
wanted to point it to the url directly
using the mean stock you can do that
otherwise as we saw in the slides you
can use the root 53 pointed to the load
balancer and then point it to the
instances directly also once it is
created by the mean stock so that was
the demo guys with respect to the bean
stock and how we can actually run the
environments apart from that the
operational tasks like system operations
you can manage all these things from the
environment dashboard inspirations you
have the logs you can actually check the
health status of your environment you
can do the monitoring and you can
actually get the alarms and the events
here so let's say if i wanted to if i
wanted to see the logs i can request for
the logs here itself and i'll be
represented with the full log report and
i can now download that log file and i
can view the logs so it's in the so we
have this bundle locks in the zip file
all right so if you want to see some
kind of
logs with respect to elastic bean stock
activity it's in the form of a notepad
and here you can see what all
configurations the beanstalk has done on
your environment on your instance
similarly you can go for the health
monitoring alarms events and all those
things in this lesson you'll learn all
about virtual private clouds and
understand their concept
you'll know the difference between
public private and elastic ip
addresses you'll learn about what a
public and private sudden there is
and you'll understand what an internet
gateway is and how it's used
you'll learn what route tables are and
when they are used
you'll understand what and that gateway
is
we'll take a look at security groups and
their importance
and we'll take a look at network acls
and how they're used in amazon vpc
we'll also review the amazon vpc best
practices
and also the costs associate amazon
cloud
welcome to the amazon virtual private
cloud and subnet section
in this section we're going to have an
overview of what amazon vpc is and how
you use it
and we're also going to have a
demonstration of how to create your own
custom virtual private cloud
we're going to look at ip addresses and
the use of elastic ip addresses in aws
and finally we'll take a look at subnets
and there'll be a demonstration about
how to create your own subnets in an
amazon vpc
and here are some other terms that are
used in vpcs
there's subnets
root tables elastic ip addresses
internet gateways nat gateways network
acls and security groups and in the next
sections we're going to take a look at
each of these and build our own custom
vpc that we'll use throughout this
course
amazon defines a vpc as a virtual
private cloud that enables you to launch
aws resources into a virtual network
that you've defined
this virtual network closely resembles a
traditional network that you'd operate
in your own data center
but with the benefits of using the
scalable infrastructure of aws
a vpc is your own virtual network in the
amazon cloud which is used as the
network layer for your ec2 resources
and this is a diagram of default vpc now
there's a lot going on here so don't
worry about that what we're going to do
is break down each of the individual
items in this default vpc over the
coming lesson
but what you need to know is that a vpc
is a critical part of the exam and you
need to know all the concepts and how it
differs from your own networks
throughout this lesson we're going to
create our own vpc from scratch
which you'll need to replicate at the
end of this so you can do well in the
exam
each vpc that you create is logically
isolated from other virtual networks in
the aws cloud
it's fully customizable you can select
the ip address range create subnets
configure route tables set up network
gateways define security settings using
security groups and network access
control lists
so each amazon account comes with a
default vpc that's pre-configured for
you to start using straight away so you
can launch your ec2 instances without
having to think about anything we
mentioned in the opening section a vpc
can span multiple availability zones in
a region
and here's a very basic diagram of a vpc
this simple in reality
and as we saw in the first section
here's the default amazon vpc
which looks kind of complicated
but what we need to know at this stage
is that the cidr block for the default
vpc is always a 16 subnet mask so
in this example it's 172.31.0.0.16.
what that means is this vpc will provide
up to 65536
private ip addresses so in the coming
sections we'll take a look at all of
these different items that you can see
on this default vpc but why wouldn't you
just use the default vpc
well the default vpc is great for
launching new instances when you're
testing aws
but creating a custom vpc allows you to
make things more secure and you can
customize your virtual network as you
can define your own ip address range you
can create your own subnets that are
both private and public and you can
tighten down your security settings
by default instances that you launch
into a vpc can't communicate with your
own network
so you can connect your vpcs to your
existing data center using something
called hardware vpn access
so that you can effectively extend your
data center into the cloud and create a
hybrid environment
now to do this you need a virtual
private gateway
and this is the vpn concentrator on the
amazon side of the vpn connection
then on your side in your data center
you need a customer gateway which is
either a physical device or a software
application that sits on your side of
the vpn connection so when you create a
vpn connection a vpn tunnel comes up
when traffic is generated from your side
of the connection
vpc peering is an important concept to
understand
appearing connection can be made between
your own bpcs
or with a vpc in another aws account as
long as it's in the same region
so what that means is if you have
instances in vpca they wouldn't be able
to communicate with instances in vpc b
or c unless you set up appearing
connection
peering is a one-to-one relationship a
vpc can have multiple peering
connections to other vpcs
but and this is important
transitive peering is not supported
in other words
vpca can connect to b and c in this
diagram but c wouldn't be able to
communicate with b unless they were
directly paired also vpcs with
overlapping cidrs cannot be paired so in
this diagram you can see they all have
different ip ranges which is fine but if
they had the same ipo ranges they
wouldn't be able to be paired
and finally for this section
if you delete the default vpc you have
to contact aws support to get it back
again
so be careful with it and only delete it
if you have good reason to do so and
know what you're doing this is a
demonstration of how to create a custom
vpc
so here we are back at the amazon web
services management console and this
time we're going to go down to the
bottom left where the networking section
is i'm going to click on the pc
and the vpc dashboard will load up now
there's a couple of ways you can create
a custom vpc there's something called
the vpc wizard
which
will build vpcs on your behalf from a
selection of different configurations
for example a vpc with a single public
subnet or a vpc with public and private
subnets now this is great because you
click a button type in a few details and
it does the work for you however you're
not going to learn much or pass the exam
if this is how you do it so
we'll cancel that and we'll go to your
vpcs
and we'll click on create a vpc
and we're presented with the create the
vpc window
so let's give our vpc a name
i'm going to call that simply learn
underscore
vpc and this is the kind of naming
convention i'll be using throughout this
course
next we need to give it the cidr block
or the classless interdomain routing
block
so we're going to give it a very simple
one 10.0.0.0
and then we need to give it the subnet
mask so you're not allowed to go larger
than 15. so if i try to put 15 in it
says no
not going to happen
for a reference subnet mask of 15 would
give you
around 131 000 ip addresses
and
subnet 16 will give you 65
536 which is probably more than enough
for what we're going to do
next you get to choose the tenancy
there's two options default and
dedicated if you select dedicated then
your ec2 instances will reside on
hardware that's dedicated to you so your
performance is going to be great but
your cost is going to be significantly
higher
so i'm going to stick with default
and we just click on yes create
it'll take a couple of seconds
and then in our vpc dashboard we can see
our simply learn vpc has been created
now if we go down to the bottom here to
see the information about our new vpc we
can see it has a root table associated
with it
which is our default root table
so there it is and we can see that it's
only allowing local traffic at the
moment
we go back to the vpc again
we can see it's been given a default
network
acl and we'll click on that and have a
look
and you can see this is very similar to
what we looked at in the lesson
so it's allowing all traffic from all
sources inbound and outbound now if we
go to the subnet section
and just
widen the vpc area here
you can see there's no subnets
associated with the vpc we just created
so that means we won't better launch any
instances into our vpc
and to prove it i'll just show you we'll
go to the ec2 section
so this is a glimpse into your future
this is what we'll be looking at in the
next lesson
and we'll just quickly try and launch an
instance we'll select any instance it
doesn't matter
any size not important so here the
network section
if i try and select simply learn vpc
it's saying
no subnets found
this is not going to work
so we basically need to create some
subnets in our vpc
and that is what we're going to look at
in the next lesson
now private ip addresses are ip
addresses that are not reachable over
the internet
and they're used for communication
between instances in the same network
when you launch a new instance is given
a private ip address and an internal dns
host name that resolves to the private
ip address of the instance but if you
want to connect to this from the
internet it's not going to work
so then you'd need a public ip address
which is reachable from the internet you
can use public ip addresses for
communication between your instances and
the internet
each instance that receives a public ip
address is also given an external dns
host name
public ip addresses are associated with
your instances from the amazon pool of
public ip addresses
when you stop or terminate your instance
the public i p address is released and a
new one is associated when the instance
starts
so if you want your instance to retain
this public ip address
you need to use something called an
elastic ip address
an elastic ip address is a static or
persistent public ip address that's
allocated to your account and can be
associated to and from your instances as
required an elastic ip address remains
in your account until you choose to
release it there is a charge associated
with an elastic ip address if it's in
your account but not actually allocated
to an instance
this is a demonstration of how to create
an elastic ip address
so we're back at the amazon web services
management console we're going to head
back down to the networking vpc section
and we'll get to the vpc dashboard on
the left hand side we'll click on
elastic ips
now you'll see a list of any elastic ips
that you have associated in your account
and remember
any the elastic ip address that you're
using that isn't allocated to something
you'll be charged for so i have one
available and that is allocated to an
instance currently so we want to
allocate a new address
and it reminds you that there's a charge
if you're not using it i'm saying yes
allocate
and it takes a couple of seconds
and there's our new elastic ip address
now we'll be using this ip address
to associate with the nat gateway when
we build that
aws defines a subnet as a range of ip
addresses in your vpc
you can launch aws resources into a
subnet that you select
you can use a public subnet for
resources that must be connected to the
internet and a private subnet for
resources that won't be connected to the
internet
the net mask for the default subnet in
your vpc is always 20 which provides up
to 4096 addresses per subnet and a few
of them are reserved for aws use
a vpc can span multiple availability
zones but the subnet is always mapped to
a single availability zone this is
important to know
so here's our basic diagram which we're
now going to start adding to
so we can see the virtual private cloud
and you can see the availability zones
and now inside each availability zone
we've rated a subnet
now you won't be able to launch any
instances unless there are subnets in
your vpc
so it's good to spread them across
availability zones for redundancy and
failover purposes
there's two different types of subnet
public and private
you use a public subnet for resources
that must be connected to the internet
for example web servers
a public subnet is made public because
the main route table sends the subnets
traffic that is destined for the
internet to the internet gateway and
will touch on internet gateways next
private subnets are for resources that
don't need an internet connection or
that you want to protect from the
internet for example database instances
so in this demonstration we're going to
create some subnets a public and a
private subnet and we're going to put
them in our custom vpc in different
availability zones
so we'll head to networking and vpc
wait for the vpc dashboard to load up
we'll click on subnets
we'll go to create subnet
and i'm going to give the subnet a name
so it's good to give them meaningful
names
so i'm going to call this first one for
the public subnet 10.0.1.0
and i'm going to put this one in
the us east
one
b availability zone
and i'm going to call that simplylearn
public
so it's quite a long name i understand
but at least it makes it clear for
what's going on in this example so we
need to choose a vpc so we obviously
want to put it in our simply learn vpc
and i said i wanted to put it in us east
1b i'm using the north virginia region
by the way
so we click on that
then we need to give it the cidr block
now as i mentioned earlier when i typed
in the name
that's the range i want to use and then
we need to give it the subnet mask
and we're going to go with
24 which should give us 251
addresses in this range which obviously
is going to be more than enough if i try
and put a different value in that's
unacceptable to amazon it's going to say
it's going to give me an error and tell
me not to do that let's go back to 24
and click on the cut and paste this by
the way just because i need to type
something very similar for the next one
click create
it takes a few seconds
okay so there's our new subnet and i
just widen this
you can see so that's
the ip range that's the availability
zone
it's for simply learn and it's public
so now we want to create
the private
so put the name in i'm going to give the
private the ip address block
of that
i'm going to put this one in u.s east 1c
and it's going to be the private
subnet
obviously i want it to be in the same
vpc
where the bit is the zone of us east 1c
and we're going to give it
10.0.2.0.
24.
and we'll click yes create
again it takes a few seconds
okay
so we sort by name
so there we are we can see now we've got
our private subnet and our public server
let me just type in simply then there we
are so now you can see them both there
and you can see they're both in the same
vpc
simply learn vpc
now if we go down to the bottom you can
see the root table associated with these
vpcs
and you can see that they can
communicate with each other internally
but there's no internet access
so that's what we need to do next in the
next lesson you're going to learn about
internet gateways and how we can make
these subnets have internet access
welcome to the networking section
in this section we're going to take a
look at internet gateways root tables
and nat devices
and we'll have a demonstration on how to
create each of these aws vpc items
so to allow your vp
you need to attach an internet gateway
and you can only attach one internet
gateway per vpc
so attaching an internet gateway is the
first stage in permitting internet
access to instances in your vpc now
here's our diagram again and now we've
added the internet gateway which is
providing the connection to the internet
to your vpc
but before you can configure internet
correctly there's a couple more steps
for an ec2 instance to be internet
connected you have to adhere to the
following rules
firstly you have to attach an internet
gateway to your vpc which we just
discussed
then you need to ensure that your
instances have public ip addresses or
elastic ip addresses
so they're able to connect to the
internet
then you need to ensure that your
subnets root table points to the
internet gateway
and you need to ensure that your network
access control and security group rules
allow relevant traffic to flow to and
from your instance so you need to allow
the rules to let in the traffic you want
for example http traffic
after the demonstration for this section
we're going to look at how route tables
access control lists and security groups
are used
in this demonstration we're going to
create an internet gateway and attach it
to our custom vpc
so let's go to networking vpc
bring up the vpc dashboard
and on the left hand side we click on
internet gateways
so here's a couple of internet gateways
i have already
um but i need to create a new one so
create internet gateway
i'll give it a name which is going to be
simply learn
internet gateway igw and i'm going to
click create so this is an internet
gateway c has no internet access
so there it's created
simply then i gw
but its state is detached because it's
not attached to anything so let me try
and attach it to a vpc
and it gives me an option of all the
vpcs that have no
internet gateway attached to them
currently
so i only have one which is simply then
vpc
yes attach
now you can see our vpc has internet
attached and you can see that down here
so let's click on that and it will take
us to our vpc
but before any instances in our vpc can
access the internet we need to ensure
that our subnet root table points to the
internet gateway
and we don't want to change the main
route table we want to create a custom
route table and that's what you're going
to learn about next
a root table determines where network
traffic is directed
it does this by defining a set of rules
every subnet has to be associated with a
root table and a subnet can only be
associated with one root table
however multiple subnets can be
associated with the same root table
every vpc has a default root table and
it's good practice to leave this in its
original state and create a new route
table to customize the network traffic
routes associated with your vpc
so here's our example
and we've added two route tables the
main route table and the
the new root table or the custom root
table will tell the internet gateway to
direct internet traffic to the public
subnet
but the private subnet is still
associated to the default route table
the main route table which does not
allow internet traffic to it
all traffic inside the private subnet is
just remaining local
in this demonstration we're going to
create a custom route table
associated with our internet gateway and
asset with it
so let's go to networking and vpc
the dashboard will load and we're going
to go to
route tables
now our vpc only has its main route
table at the moment the default one it
was given at the
time it was created
so we want to create a new route table
and we want to give it a name so we're
going to call that simplylearn
and we call it root table rtb for sure
and then we get to pick which vpc we
want to put it in so obviously we want
to use simply learn vpc
so we click create
which will take a couple of seconds and
here you are here's our new route table
so what we need to do now
is change its route so that it points to
the internet gateway so if we go down
here to roots
at a minute you can see it's just like
our main route table it just has local
access
so we want to click on edit
and we want to add another route
so the destination is
the internet which is all the zeros
and our target and we click on this it
gives us the option of our internet
gateway which we want to do
so now we have internet access to this
subnet sorry to this route table
and we click on save
save was successful so now we can see
that as well as local access we have
internet access
now at the moment if we click on subnet
associations
you do not have any subnet associations
so basically both both our subnets the
public and private subnets are
associated with the main route table
which doesn't have internet access so we
want to change this we'll click on edit
and we want our public subnet to be
associated
with this root table so click on save
it's just saving that
so now we can see that our public subnet
is associated with this route table
and this route table
is associated with the internet gateway
so now anything we launch into the
public subnet will have internet access
but what if we wanted our instances in
the private subnet to have internet
access
well there's a way of doing that with a
nat device and that's what we're going
to look at in the next lecture
you can use a nat device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to the internet or other aws services
but prevent the internet from initiating
connections with the instances in the
private subnet
so we talked earlier about public and
private subnets to protect your assets
from be directly connected to the
internet
for example your web server would sit in
the public subnet in your database in
the private subnet which has no internet
connectivity
however your private subnet database
instance might still need internet
access
or the ability to connect to other aws
resources
if so you can use a network address
translation device or in that device to
do this
and that device forwards traffic from
your private subnet to the internet or
other aws services
and then sends the response back to the
instances
when traffic goes to the internet the
source ip address of your instance is
replaced with the nat device address
and when the internet traffic comes back
again then that device translates the
address to your instance's private ip
address
so here's our diagram which is getting
ever more complicated and if you look in
the public subnet you can see we've now
added a nat device and you have to put
that devices in the public subnet so
that they get internet connectivity
aws provides two kinds of nat devices
and that gateway and a nat instance
aws recommends a nat gateway as it's a
managed service that provides better
availability and bandwidth than that
instances
each nat gateway is created in a
specific availability zone and is
implemented with redundancy in that zone
and that instance is launched from a nat
ami and amazon machine image and runs as
an instance in your vpc so it's
something else you have to look after
whereas in that gateway being a fully
managed service means once it's
installed
you can pretty much forget about it
and that gateway must be launched into a
public subnet because it needs internet
connectivity
it also needs an elastic ip address
which you can select at the time of
launch once created you need to update
the route table associated with your
private subnet to point internet bound
traffic to the nat gateway
this way the instances in your private
subnets can communicate with the
internet
so if you remember back to the diagram
when we had the custom route table which
was pointed to the internet gateway
now we're pointing our main route table
to the nat gateway so the private subnet
also gets internet access but in a more
secure manner
welcome to the create and that gateway
demonstration where we're going to
create a nat gateway so that the
instances in our private subnet can get
internet access
so we'll start by going to networking
and vpc
and the first thing we're going to do is
take a look at our subnets
and you'll see why shortly so here are
our simply learn subnets so this is the
private subnet that we want to give
internet access but if you remember from
the section
nat gateways need to be placed in public
subnets so i'm just going to copy the
name of this subnet id
for the public subnet and you'll see why
in a moment
so then we go to nat gateways on the
left hand side
and we want to create a new nat gateway
so we have to put a subnet in there so
we want to choose our public subnet as
you can see
it truncates a lot of the subnet names
on this option so it's a bit confusing
so we know that we want to put it in our
simply learn vpc
in the public subnet but you can see
it's truncated so it's actually this one
at the bottom but what i'm going to do
is just paste in
the subnet id which i copied earlier
so there's no confusion
then we need to give it an elastic ip
address now if you remember from the
earlier demonstration we created one so
let's select that but if you hadn't
allocated one you could click on the
create new eip button
so
we'll do that
okay so it's telling me my nat gateway
has been created and in order to use you
on that gateway ensure that you edit
your route table to include a route with
a target of and then on that gateway id
so it's given us the option to click on
our edit root tables so we'll go
straight there
now here's our here's our root tables
now
here's the custom route table that we
created earlier and this is the
default the main route table which was
created when we launched our when we
created our vpc
so we should probably give this a name
so that we know what it is so let me
just call this simplylearn
rtb main
so now we know that's our main route
table
so if you take a look at the main route
and the subnet associations
you can see that our private subnet is
associated with this table
so what we need to do is put a route in
here that points to the nat gateway so
if we click on routes and edit
and we want to add another route
and we want to say that all traffic
can
either go to the simply an internet
gateway which we don't want to do we
want to point it to our nat instance
which is this nat id here
and we click save
so now any instances launched in our
private subnet will be able to get
internet access via on that gateway
welcome to the using security groups and
network acl section
in this section we're going to take a
look at security groups and network acls
and we're going to have a demonstration
on how you create both of these items in
the amazon web services console
a security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances
you add rules to each security group
that about traffic to or from its
associated instances
basically a security group controls the
inbound and outbound traffic for one or
more ec2 instances
security groups can be found on both the
ec2 and vpc dashboards in the aws web
management console we're going to cover
them here in this section and you'll see
them crop up again in the ec2 lesson
and here is our diagram and you can see
we've now added security groups to it
and you can see that ec2 instances are
sitting inside the security groups and
the security groups will control what
traffic flows in and
out so let's take a look at some
examples and we'll start with a security
group for a web server
now obviously a web server needs http
and https traffic as a minimum to be
able to access it so here is an example
of the security group table and you can
see we're allowing http and https
the ports that are associated with those
two
and the sources and we're allowing it
from the internet we're basically
allowing all traffic to those ports
and that means any other traffic that
comes in on different ports would be
unable to reach the security group and
the instances inside it
let's take a look at an example for a
database server security group
now imagine you have a sql server
database
then you would need to open up the sql
server port so that people can access it
which is port 1433 by default so we've
added that to the table and we've
allowed the source to come from the
internet now because it's a windows
machine you might want rdp access so you
can log on and do some administration
so we've also added rdp access to the
security group now you could leave it
open to the internet but that would mean
anyone could try and hack their way into
your box so in this example we've added
a source ip address of
10.0.0.0 so only ipa ranges from that
address
can rdp to the instance
now there's a few rules associated with
security groups
by default security groups allow all
outbound traffic so if you want to
tighten that down you can do so in a
similar way to you can define the
inbound traffic
security group rules are always
permissive
you can't create rules that deny access
so you're allowing access rather than
denying it
security groups are stateful so if you
send a request from your instance the
response traffic for that request is
allowed to flow in regardless of the
inbound security group rules
and you can modify the rules of a
security group at any time and the rules
are applied immediately
welcome to the create security group
demonstration where we're going to
create two security groups one the host
db servers and one the host web servers
now if you remember from the best
practices section it said it was always
a good idea to tear your applications
into security groups and that's exactly
what we're going to do
so if we go to networking and vpc to
bring up the vpc
dashboard on the left hand side under
security we click on security groups
now you can also get to security groups
from the ec2 dashboard as well
so here's a list of my existing security
groups but we want to create
a new security group and we're going to
call it
simply learn
web server
sg security group and we'll give the
group name as the same and our
description is going to be simply learn
web servers
security groups
okay and then we need to select our vpc
now it defaults to the default vpc but
obviously we want to put it in our
simply learn vpc so we click yes create
takes a couple of seconds
and there it is there's our new security
group now if we go down to the
rules the inbound rules
you can see there are none so by default
a new security group has no inbound
rules
but what about outbound rules
if you remember from the
lesson a new security group by default
allows all traffic to be outbound
and there you are all traffic
has destination of everywhere so all
traffic is allowed we're going to add
some rules so let's click on inbound
rules click on edit
now this is going to be a web server so
if we click on the drop down
we need to give it http
so you can either choose custom tcp rule
and type in your own port ranges or you
can just use the ones they have for you
so http
this pre-populates the port range and
then here you can add the source
now if i click on it it's giving me the
option of saying
allow
access from different security groups
so you could create a security group and
say i only accept traffic from a
different security group which is a nice
way of securing things down you could
also put in here just your ip address so
that only you could do http request to
the instance but because it's a web
server
we want
people to be able to see our website
otherwise it's not going to be much use
so we're going to say all traffic so all
source
traffic can access our instance on port
http 80.
i want to add another rule because we
also want to do https
which is
hiding from me
there we are
and again we want to do
the same
and also because this is going to be a
linux instance we want to be able to
connect to the linux instance to do some
work and configuration so we need to
give it ssh access
and again it would be good practice to
tie it down to your specific ip or an ip
range
but we're just going to do all for now
and then we click on save
and there we are there we have our
ranges
so now we want to create our security
group for our db servers so let's click
create security group
and then we'll go through and give it a
similar name
simply learn
db servers
sg
and the description is going to be
simply learn db servers security group
and our vpc is obviously going to be
simply learn vpc
so let's click yes create wait a few
seconds
and here's our new security group as you
can see it has no inbound rules by
default and outbound rules allow all
traffic
so this is going to be a sql server
database server
and so we need to allow sql server
traffic into the instance
so we need to give
it microsoft sql port access now the
default port for microsoft sql server is
1433.
now in reality i'd probably change the
port the sql server was running on to
make it more secure
but we'll go with this for now and then
the source so we could choose the ipa
ranges again but what we want to do is
place the db server in the private
subnet and allow
the traffic to come from the web server
so the web server will accept traffic
and the web server will then go to the
database to get the information it needs
to display on its web on the website or
if people are entering information into
the website we want the information to
be stored in our db server so basically
we want to say that this the db servers
can only accept sql server traffic from
the web server security group
so we can select the simply then web
server security group as the source
traffic
for microsoft sql server data
so we'll select that now our sql server
is obviously going to be a windows
instance so from time to time we might
not might we might need to log in
and configure it so we want to give rdp
access
now again you would probably put a
specific ip range in there
we're just going to do all traffic for
now
then we click save
and there we are so now we have two
security groups
db servers and web servers
a network acl is a network access
control list
and it's an optional layer of security
for your vpc that acts as a firewall for
controlling traffic in and out of one or
more of your subnets
you might set up network acls with rules
similar to your security groups in order
to add an additional layer of security
to your vpc
here is our network diagram and we've
added network acls to the mix now you
can see they sit somewhere between the
root tables and the subnets
this diagram makes it a little bit
clearer and you can see that a network
acl sits in between a root table and a
subnet and also you can see an example
of the default network acl
which is configured to allow all traffic
to flow in and out of the subnets to
which is associated
each network acl includes a whose rule
number is an asterix
this rule ensures that if a packet
doesn't match any of the other numbered
rules it's denied
you can't modify or remove this rule
so if you take a look at this table you
can see on the inbound
some traffic would come in and it would
look for the first rule which is 100 and
that's saying i'm allowing all traffic
from all sources
so that's fine the traffic comes in
if that rule 100 wasn't there it would
go to the asterix rule and the aztecs
rule is saying
traffic from all sources is denied
let's take a look at the network acl
rules
each subnet in your vpc must be
associated with an acl
if you don't assign it to a custom acl
it will automatically be associated to
your default acl
a subnet can only be associated with one
acl
however an acl can be associated with
multiple subnets
an acl contains a list of numbered rules
which are evaluated in order starting
with the lowest as soon as a rule
matches traffic it's applied regardless
of any higher numbered rules that may
contradict it
aws recommends incrementing your rules
by a factor of 100 so there's plenty of
room to implement new rules at a later
date
unlike security groups acls are
stateless
responses to allowed inbound traffic as
subject to the rules for outbound
traffic
welcome to the network acl demonstration
where we're just going to have an
overview of ocls where they are in the
dashboard
now you don't need to know a huge amount
about them for the exam you just need to
know how they work and where they are
so let's go to networking and vpc
and on when the dashboard loads on the
left hand side under security there's
network acls so let's click on that
now you can see some acls that are in my
my aws account so we want the one that's
associated with our simply learn vpc so
if we extend this
column
that's our network acl simply then vpc
now let's give it a name because
it's not very clear to see otherwise
also i'm kind of an obsessive tagger so
let's call it simply learn acl and click
on the tick so there we are so now it's
much easier to see
so we click on inbound rules
so this is exactly what we showed you in
the lesson
the rule is 100 so that's the first rule
that's going to get evaluated and it's
saying allow all traffic from all
sources
and the outbound rules are the same
so if you wanted to
tighten down the new rule you could
click edit we'd give it a new rule
number say which would be 200 so you
should always increment them in 100 so
that means if you had 99 more rules you
needed to put in place you'd have space
to put them in in between these two
and then you could do whatever you
wanted you could say
you know we are allowing http access
from
all traffic
and we're allowing or you could say
actually you know what we're gonna deny
it so this is the way of blacklisting
traffic into your vpc
now i'm not going to save that because
we don't need it
but this is where network acls sit and
this is where you would make any changes
it's also worth having a look at the
subnet associations with your acl
so we have two subnets in our
simplylearnvpc so we would expect to see
both of them associated with this
network acl because it's the default
and there they are this both are public
and our private subnets are associated
and you can also see up here on the on
the dashboard it says default so this is
telling us this is our default acl
if you did want to create a new network
acl you would click create network acl
you'd give it a name
just say new acl and then you would
associate it with your vpc so we would
say simply then dpc
takes a few seconds
and there we are there we have our new
one
now you can see this one says default no
because it obviously isn't the default
acl for our simply learn vpc
and it has no subnets associated with it
so let's just delete that because we
don't need it but there you are there's
a very brief overview of network acls
welcome to the amazon vpc best practices
and costs
where we're going to take a look at the
best practices and the costs associated
with the amazon virtual private cloud
always use public and private subnets
you should use private subnets to secure
resources that don't need to be
available to the internet such as
database services
to provide secure internet access to the
instances that reside in your private
subnets you should provide a nat device
when using that devices you should use a
nat gateway over nat instances because
they're a managed service and require
less administration effort
you should choose your cidr blocks
carefully
amazon vpc can contain from 16 to 65
536 ip addresses so you should choose
your cidr block according to how many
instances you think you'll need
you should also create separate amazon
vpcs for development staging test and
production or create one amazon vpc with
separate subnets with a subnet each for
production development staging and test
you should understand the amazon vpc
limits there are various limitations on
the vpc components for example you're
allowed 5 vpcs per region
200 subnets per vpc
200 route tables per vpc
500 security groups per vpc
50 in and outbound rules per vpc
however some of these rules can be
increased by raising a ticket with aws
support
you should use security groups and
network acls to secure the traffic
coming in and out of your vpc
amazon advises to use security groups
for white listing traffic and network
acls for blacklisting traffic
amazon recommends tiering your security
groups you should create different
security groups for different tiers of
your infrastructure architecture inside
vpc
if you have web tiers and db tiers you
should create different security groups
for each of them
creating toy security groups will
increase the infrastructure security
inside the amazon vpc
so if you launch all your web servers in
the web server security group that means
they'll automatically all have http and
https open
conversely
the database security group will have
sql server ports already open
you should also standardize your
security group naming conventions
following a security group naming
convention allows amazon vpc operation
and management for large-scale
deployments to become much easier
always span your amazon vpc across
multiple subnets in multiple
availability zones inside a region
this helps in architecting high
availability inside your vpc
if you choose to create a hardware vpn
connection to your vpc using virtual
private gateway you are charged for each
vpn connection hour that your vpn
connection is provisioned and available
each partial vpn connection hour
consumed is billed as a full hour
you'll also incur standard aws data
transfer charges for all data
transferred via the vpn connection
if you choose to create a nat gateway in
your vpc you are charged for each nat
gateway hour that your nat gateway is
provisioned and available
data processing charges apply for each
gigabyte processed through and that
gateway
each partial nap gateway hour consumed
is billed as a full hour
this is the practice assignment for
designing a custom vpc where you'll
create a custom vpc using the concepts
learnt in this lesson
using the concepts learnt in this lesson
recreate the custom vpc as shown in the
demonstrations
the vpc name should be simply learn vpc
the cidr block should be 10.0.0.0.16
there should be two subnets one public
with a range of 10.0.1.0
and one private with a range of 10.0.2.0
and they should be placed in separate
availability zones
there should be one internet gateway and
one that gateway and also one custom
route table for the public subnet
also create two security groups simply
learn web server security group and
simply learn db server security group
so let's review the key takeaways from
this lesson
amazon virtual private cloud or vpc
enables you to launch aws resources into
a virtual network that you've defined
this virtual network closely resembles a
traditional network that you'd operate
in your own data center but with the
benefits of using scalable
infrastructure of aws
there are three types of ip address in
aws
a private ip address this is an ip
address that's not reachable over the
internet and it's used for communication
between instances in the same network
a public ip address is reachable from
the internet which you can use for
communication between your instances and
the internet
and there's an elastic ip address this
is a static public persistent ip address
that persists after an instance restarts
whereas a public ip address is raised
associated after each restart
amazon defines a subnet as a range of ip
addresses in your bpc
you can launch aws resources into a
subnet that you select and a subnet is
always mapped to a single availability
zone
use a public subnet for resources that
must be connected to the internet and a
private subnet for resources that won't
be connected to the internet
to allow your vpc the ability to connect
to the internet you need to attach an
internet gateway to it and you can only
attach one internet gateway per vpc
a route table determines where network
traffic is directed it does this by
defining a set of rules
every subnet has to be associated with a
route table and a subnet can only have
an association with one root table
however multiple subnets can be
associated to the same root table
and you can use a nat device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to the internet or other aws services
but and that device will prevent the
internet from initiating connections
with instances inside your private
subnet
a security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances
you add rules to each security group
that allow traffic to or from its
associated instances
a network access control list or network
acl is an optional layer of security for
your vpc that acts as a firewall for
controlling traffic in and out of one or
more of your subnets
let's look into what we have in audition
so what's in it for you we would be
covering what is aws
why do we need aws sagemaker
what is aws sagemaker services
what are the benefits of using the aws
sagemaker
machine learning with aws sagemaker how
to train a model with aws stagemaker how
to validate a model with aws
and the companies that are using aws
shmaker along with that we will be
covering up one live demo on the aws
platform
now let's understand what is aws so
what is aws it's an amazon web services
it's a largest
or
most widely used public cloud platform
offered by amazon it provides services
over the internet
aws services can be used to build
monitor
and deploy any type of application in
the cloud
aws also uses the subscription pricing
model that means you only pay for
whatever the services you use for
now why do we need aws sagemaker let's
look into it so
let's consider an example of one of the
company that is proquest
now before aws age maker
the proquest is a global information
content and technology company
that provides valuable content such as
ebooks newspapers etc to the users
before awschmaker
the proquest requirement was to have a
better user experience maximum relevant
search results now after aws shmaker
they were able to achieve those
results
so they achieved more appealing video
user experience they achieved more
relevant search results for the users
now what do we mean by aws age maker why
this service is primarily used
so
amazon sage maker is a cloud machine
learning platform
that helps users in building training
tuning and deploying machine learning
models in a production ready hosted
environment
so it's kind of a machine learning
service which is already hosted on the
aws platform now what are the benefits
of using aws sagemaker
uh the key benefits of using aws
sagemaker are
it reduces machine learning data cost so
you can do the cost optimization
while running
this particular service on the aws
all ml components are stored in a
particular place in a dashboard so they
can be managed together
highly scalable so it can be scalable on
you can scale
this particular service on the fly
it trains the models quite faster
maintains the uptime so you can be
assured that your workloads will be
running all the time it will be
available all the time
high data security so security becomes a
major concern on the cloud platforms and
it ensures that you have the high data
security along with that you can do a
data transfer to different aws services
like s3 bucket and all
with these simple data transfer
techniques
now machine learning with aws sagemaker
let us look into it
so machine learning with aws sagemaker
is a three-step function
so one is to build second is to test and
tune the model and third is to deploy
the model now with the build it provides
more than 15 widely used ml algorithms
for training purpose
now to build a model you can collect and
prepare training data or you can select
from the amazon s3 bucket also choose
and optimize the required algorithm so
some of the algorithms that you can
select are k-means linear regressions
logistic regression sage maker helps
developers to customize ml instances
with the jupyter notebook interface
in the test and tune you have to set up
and manage the environment
for training so you would need some
sample data to train the model
so train and tune a model
with the amazon sage maker sage maker
implements hyper parameter tuning
by adding a suitable combination of
algorithm parameters also it divides the
training data and stores that in the
amazon s3 s3 is a simple storage service
which is primarily used for storing the
objects and the data hence it is used
for storing and recovering data over the
internet and
below you can see that aws sagemaker
uses amazon s3 to store data as it's
safe and secure also it divides the
training data and stores in amazon s3
where the training algorithm code is
stored in the ecr ecr stands for elastic
container registry which is primarily
used for containers and dockers ecr
helps users to save monitor and deploy
docker and the containers later sage
maker sets up a cluster for the input
data
trains it and stores it in the amazon s3
itself so this is done by the sage maker
itself after that you need to deploy it
so suppose you want to predict limited
data at a time
you use amazon sage maker hosting
services for that okay but if you want
to get prediction for an entire data set
prefer using amazon sage maker batch
transform now the last step that is to
deploy the model so once tuning is done
models can be deployed to sagemaker
endpoints
and in the end point real time
prediction is performed so you would
have some data
which you would reserve and
validate your model whether it is
working correctly or not now evaluate
your model and determine whether you
have achieved your business goals
now the
other aspect is how we can train a model
with aws stage maker
so this is basically a flow
diagram which shows you how to train a
model with the aw sagemaker and
here we have used couple of services of
an aws to get that done
so model training in aws age maker is
done on machine learning compute
instances
and here we can see there are two
machine learning compute instances used
as helper code and the training code
along with that we are using 2s3 buckets
and the ecr for the container registry
now let's look into what are the ways to
train the model as per the slides
so below are the following requirements
to train a model so here in the diagram
you can see these are the following
requirements to train a model
the url of an amazon s3 bucket where the
training data is stored that is
mentioned
the compute resources on machine
learning compute instances so these are
all your machine learning compute
instances
then the url of an amazon s3 bucket
where the output will be stored
and the path of aws elastic container
registry
where the code data is
safe the inference code image lies in
the
elastic container registry now what are
these calls these are called as the
training jobs
now when a user trains a model in amazon
sagemaker he she creates a training job
so we need to first create a training
job and then the input data is fetched
from the specified amazon s3 bucket
once the training job is built amazon
sage maker launches the ml compute
instances so these compute instances
will be launched once the training job
is built then it trains the model with
the training code and the data set and
it shows the output and model rt crafts
in the aws s3 bucket so this is done
automatically now here the helper code
performs a task when the training code
fails the interference code which is in
the elastic container registry
consists of
multiple linear sequence containers
that process the request for inference
on data
the ec2 container registry is a
container registry that helps users to
save monitor and deploy container images
whereas container images are the ready
applications
once the data is trained the output is
stored in the specified amazon s3 bucket
so here you can see the output will be
stored here to prevent your algorithm
being deleted save the data in amazon
sagemaker critical system
which can process you on your ml compute
instances now how to validate a model
let's look into it so you can evaluate
your model
using offline or using the historical
data so first thing is that you can do
the offline testing to validate a model
you can do an online testing with the
live data so if you have a live data
coming or real time streams coming you
can validate a model from there itself
you can validate using a hold out set
and also you can validate using the k
fold validation now use historical data
to send requests to the model
through the jupiter notebook in amazon
sagemaker for the evaluation online
testing with livedata deploys multiple
models into the endpoints of amazon
sagemaker and directs live traffic to
the model for validation validating
using a holdout set
is part of the data is set aside
where which is called holdout set so
the part of the data is left
which is basically called as the holdout
set
this data is not used for the model
training
so later when the model is trained
with the remaining input data and
generalize the data based on what is
learnt initially so whatever the data
which is left out
will be used for validating a model
because we have not used the data
while training a model the k-fold
validation
is
the input data is split into two parts
one part is called k
which is the validation data for testing
the model and the other part is k minus
which is used as a training data
now based on the input data the machine
learning model evaluates the
final output now
the companies that are using aws
sagemaker one is the adp so you must be
knowing about adb zelando
dow jones which is on the stock market
proquest
and the intuit
now let's look into the demo that how we
can actually run the aws sagemaker
so we'll use the r algorithm and then
package the algorithm as a container for
building training and deploying a model
we are going to use the jupiter notebook
for that for model building for model
training for model deployment
and the code for the demo is in the
below link so you can see here that from
this link you can get the code for the
demo
let's try to
do a demo on the aws
now i would be using a link which is
provided by amazon to build train and
deploy the machine learning model on the
sage maker as you can see on my screen
and in this tutorial you would have some
steps where you can put those steps and
the code python codes into your
awschmaker jupiter lab
so in this tutorial you will learn how
to use amazon sagemaker to build train
and deploy a machine learning model and
for that we will use the popular xt
boost ml algorithm for this exercise
so first of all what you need to do is
you have to go to the aws console and
there you have to create a notebook
instance
so in this tutorial you will be creating
a notebook instance you will prepare the
data train the model to learn from the
data
deploy the model evaluate your ml
model's performance and once all those
activities are done then we will see how
we can actually remove all the resources
in order to prevent the extra costing
now the first step is we have to enter
to the amazon sage maker console so here
you can see i'm already logged into the
sagemaker console you can click on the
services
search for the sagemaker here
and here you get the amazon sagemaker
service
now the next step is
that we have to create a notebook
instance so
we will select the notebook instance
from the sagemaker service
and then
after the notebook instance is selected
we'll put a name to our instance
and we'll create a new im role for that
so let's wait for the sage maker studio
to open
so here you can see the studio is open
and you just have to click on the
notebook instances
and here you have to create a notebook
instance so here you can see couple of
notebook instances have already been
created one of them is in service so
this is the notebook instance that we
are going to use for
creating the
demo model
i'll show you how you can create a
notebook instance you just have to click
on create notebook instance button
and put your notebook instance name so
you can put something like demo dash
sage maker 987 or we can put it as model
we'll go with notebook instance type as
default which is ml t2.medium
and in the permission and encryptions
under the im role we will click on
create a new im role
now why we are creating a new im rule so
that we can allow the sage maker
to access any s3 bucket that has been
created on our account
just click on create a role and here you
would see
that the new im role will be created
with the set of permissions
then rest of the things will keep it as
default and then you just have to click
on create a notebook instance
the notebook instance creation takes
some time so you just have to wait for a
couple of minutes to get that in service
we already have one of the notebook
instance that has been created so we
will be using uh that to create a demo
now going back to the steps so these are
the steps that we have already performed
now once the notebook instance is
created then we have to prepare the data
so in this step we will be using the
sagemaker notebook instance to
pre-process the data that would require
to train the machine learning model
and for that we would be opening up the
jupiter notebook
and then we have to select an
environment a kernel environment in the
jupiter notebook that would be conda
underscore python 3.
so let's
follow these steps
go back to the sage maker click on the
notebook instances
select the running notebook instance and
here you would select the open jupiter
lab
now here you would see that the
sagemaker would try to open up the
jupiter notepad
and we would be performing all our
inputs into that jupiter notebook
and executing the results there itself
so just wait for the notebook to open
now here you can see the jupiter lab
notebook has been open so i would be
selecting one of the notebook that has
been created
so this one so likewise you can create
your own notebook also how you can do
that first of all let me select the
kernel environment so i would be
selecting corner underscore python 3
and just click on select
so how you can create your own notebook
just have to click on file click on new
and here you can select the notebook
just name your notebook select the
environment conda underscore python 3 to
run this demo
so i have my notebook open so in the
tabs i would be putting up the python
codes and i would be executing those
codes to get the output directly
so the next step is
to prepare the data train the ml model
and deploy it we will need to import
some libraries
and define a few environment variables
in the jupyter notebook environment
so i would be copying this code
which you can see that would try to
import numpy pandas these are all
required to run the python
syntax
so just
copy
this code
and paste it into your
notebook
right so once you do that execute your
code
and here you can see
that
you get the output which is
that it has imported all the necessary
libraries that have been defined in the
code
now the next step is we would create an
s3 bucket
into the s3 service
and for that you have to copy this
python code
just that you have to edit it so you
have to specify
this
bucket name that you want to get created
so here i would
provide the bucket name which should be
unique
should not overlap
so something like sage maker
dash
demo
is the name that i have selected for the
bucket and now you have to execute that
code it says that the s3 bucket has been
created successfully with the name sage
maker dash demo 9876 so this is
something which you can verify so you
can go to the s3 service and there you
can verify whether the bucket has been
created or not now the next task is that
we need to download the data
to the aws sagemaker instance and load
it into the data frame and for that we
have to
follow this url so from this url
which is
built train deploy machine learning
model would have a data in the form of
bank underscore clean.csv
and this will be deployed onto our
sagemaker instance
we'll copy this code
and paste it here
and execute the code
so it says that it has successfully
downloaded bank underscore clean.csv
which is which has the data inside it
and that has to be loaded into the
sagemaker data frame successfully
now we have a data to
build and
train our machine learning model
so what we are going to do we are going
to shuffle the data and we are going to
split it one into the training data set
and the other one into test data set
so for the training data set we are
going to use 70 of the customers that
are listed in the csv file and 30
of the customers in the csv file data we
will be using it as a test data to train
the model
so we'll copy the following code into a
new code cell and then we are going to
run that
code cell
so i'll just
copy it
for training the data so that we can
segregate
the data model 70
for building the model and
30 for
testing the data so click on
run the execution and here you can see
that we got the output successfully
now
we have to train the model from that
data so how we are going to train that
model and for that we will use sagemaker
pre-built xg boost model which is an
algorithm
so you will need to reformat the header
and first column of the training data
and load the data from the s3 bucket so
what i'll do is i'll copy
this syntax
and paste it
in the note cell
so it has the trained data it would
train
the model
click on run execution
now it is
changing the s3 input class which will
be the rename to training input because
now we are training the model with the
training data
so we just have to wait for some time
till it gets executed completely
now the next thing is that we need to
set up the amazon sagemaker session to
create an instance of the xgboost model
so here we are going to create this
sagemaker session say we are going to
create an instance of the xt boost model
which is an estimator
so just copy that
copy that code
and paste it here
execute it
and here you can see that
it will start it has basically changed
the parameter image name to the
image underscore uri in this sagemaker
python sdk v2
now we will follow the next step that is
with the data loaded in the xt boost
estimator we will set up train the model
using gradient optimization
and
we'll copy the following code and that
would actually start the training of
the model
so copy
this code
and
this would actually
start
training the model
using our input data that we have
reserved 70 of that data that we have
reserved for training the model
so just copy that
again initiate the execution and it will
start the training job
now we'll deploy the model and for that
i would copy the deploy code put that in
the cell
and execute it
so
it says parameter image will be renamed
to image uri and using already existing
models so xd boost was deployed already
if you have not done that
if you're doing it the first time so it
will initiate another xd boost instance
so where you can find your xt boost
endpoints created you just have to
scroll down and here under the inference
click on the end points
and you should find the extreme boost
endpoints defined here
so here you can see that today i have
created one xt boost
point
and that is now in process of
creating so just refresh it
so it is
still created it is going to take some
time to get that in service
now our end is in service state so now
we can use it so
going forward with the next steps we'll
try to predict whether the customer in
the test data enroll for the bank
product or not for that we are going to
copy this code put that in the jupyter
cell function
and execute it
so here it gives you the output that it
has actually evaluated and the same
output we got in the screenshot
of the demo as well now we are going to
evaluate the model performance so what
we are going to do we are going to get
the prediction done so based on the
prediction we can conclude that you
predicted a customer that will enroll
for a certificate of deposit accurately
for 90 of the customers in the test data
with the precision of 65 percent for
enrolled and 90
which are which haven't enrolled for it
so for that we are going to copy this
code
and execute it here in the cell
so if it is predicted correctly that
means our model is working absolutely
fine so here you can say the overall
classification rate is 89.5 percent and
there is the accurate
prediction that has been made by the
model and that's what the output we can
see here
in the screenshot of a model so that
means our model is absolutely working
fine it has been built deployed and
trained correctly
now the next thing is that once you are
done with that you terminate your
resources and for that you just have to
copy
this code and put that in the cell
function so that the additional
resources and the endpoints and the
buckets that have been created by the
jupiter notepad should be
terminated so that you would not be
incurred with the extra costing so just
execute it and here you would see that
it has tried to it would try to
terminate all the additional resources
that we have created from the jupyter
notebook
let's look into what we have in the
cloud front
so what's in it for you
we would be covering up the concept of
what is aws
what was earlier uh before aws
cloudfront after aws cloudfront what
were the services that were introduced
how it benefited what do we mean by aws
cloudfront benefits of the using aws
cloudfront and how aws cloudfront
actually is known as a content delivery
service the name of the companies that
are using aws cloudfront and we would be
covering up on live demo
now aws is the amazon web services it's
a cloud service provider that basically
offers a multiple services variety of
services such as
compute power database storage
networking and other resources so that
you can
create your solutions on the cloud and
help the business grow now with aws you
only pay for whatever the services you
use so for example if you're using a
service for a couple of hours then you
pay for only that many hours that you
have used that service
before aws cloud front so there is an
example that we are going to talk and
that is you must be
aware of an application called spotify
so when you used to access spotify and
when you click on it it kept on loading
and at the end you used to get the error
and the error was that the connection
failed and why you receive that error
because of a latency issue probably a
network error
so how you can solve these kind of a
latency issues and that is also going to
these kind of an issues are also going
to impact the performance of an
application so
with the introduction of aws cloud from
this problem of loading the application
got resolved so after aws cloud front
with the help of adult based cloud front
spotify gives the facility of updating
new features taxes to million songs that
you can access instantly
so with the use of aws cloud front or
the latency issues were solved and
successfully you can
basically access your application now
what we mean by aws cloudfront so aws
cloudfront is a globally distributed
network that is offered by aws amazon
web services which securely delivers
content to the end users across any
geography
with a higher transfer speed and an
improve or a low latency now what are
the benefits of aws cloudfront there are
multiple benefits one is the cost
effective so
it helps you to do the cost optimization
when you use the cloud front it is time
saving so
it is implemented easily
and also lot of issues with respect to
accessing the application
with respect to latency and all can be
resolved
content privacy so
the content is placed to the end users
and also to
the cloudfront servers
in a secured manner in a secured way
it is highly programmable and you can
make the changes amend the changes on
the fly
and you can target any location any
geography across the globe along with
that it helps you to get the content
deliver quickly
now how aws cloudfront delivers the
content let's look into the architecture
so
this is a flow and the flow is with
respect to how the user is going to get
a content from the cloud front now the
client first access a website by typing
a url on the browser
and in the step one it acts tries to
access the application
then the client requests
when the website is open the client
request for an object to download such
as for example a particular file
now
at that time the dns
routes user request to download that
file to aws cloudfront
the aws cloud front connects to the
nearest edge locations edge locations
are basically the servers
where it caches
the files documents and the web codes
aws front connects to its nearest edge
location in order to serve the user
the request
at edge location
aws cloud front looks for its requested
cache file
once the file is found let's say if the
file is available in the case of an edge
location
aws cloudfront then sends the file
to the user
otherwise if the file is not found in
the cache memory of an edge location
aws cloudfront compares the requirement
with the specification and share it with
a respected server that means a web
server or a server where the file is
actually available the server the web
server responds
to the edge location by sending the file
back to the cloudfront edge location
and then as soon as the aws cloudfront
receives the file
it shares with the client also adds the
file to the cache of an edge location
for a future reference this is how the
flow of a cloud front is now
the name of the companies that are using
the aws cloud front
so one of them is jio7
app which is which is a very popular app
so it uses amazon cloudfront to deliver
15 petabytes of audio and video to its
subscribers globally which is a huge
data sky news it uses the service in
order to unify the content for faster
distribution to scrub subscribers
or the discovery communications also
uses the cloud front it uses the service
for delivering api
static asset and also the dynamic
content
and then
the tv one eu streaming europe is
basically also uses the cloudfront
service that helps in improving latency
and performance
that results in fastest delivery of
content
now let's look into the demo how to use
cloudfront to serve
private s3 bucket as a website
now i'm going to
run a cloudfront distribution demo on
the aws console
and
we basically try to deliver the content
from a private s3 bucket
and then map that with the domain name
using the root 53 service
so what we need for this demo we would
need
a domain url we would need
a route 53 service
we would need cloud front uh we have to
create a cloud front distribution
and that will be linked with our s3
bucket the private s3 bucket
right
and in the s3 bucket we would have
one html file the index.html file so
let's uh move into aws console
so right now i have opened up the
cloudfront distribution
and here you can see
that couple of distributions have
already been created
so what i'm going to do i'm going to
create a distribution
now there are two types of delivery
method for your content one is the web
distribution and the other one is
rtmp
rtmp stands for real-time
audio or video distribution
it's basically
used for
distribution of a media content or a
media file which are available in the s3
bucket
here
we are going to select a web
distribution because primarily we will
be using files which uses protocols http
or the https
so you have to click on get started
and
in the origin domain name you have to
specify
the bucket where your code is available
so
i have a bucket already created
here you can see and what you need to do
is you have to create a bucket
with the url name or the domain name
which you would be mapping with the
route 53 service
so this is a bucket that has already
been created let me show you in a new
tab
so
here you have to go to the storage under
the storage
you have to select the s3 bucket
let's open the link in the new tab and
let's look into
how we can create the s3 buckets
now here are a couple of buckets already
created i have created one bucket with
the domain name that i'm going to use
and map it with the root 53 service
so that is basically mapped to a region
which is in ohio
and if you open up this bucket
here you will find an html webpage the
index.html has been
already added
right so similarly you have to create a
bucket with a domain and an index.html
page needs to be uploaded there now
again we'll go to the cloud front we
will try to create a distribution
just have to click on create
distribution
select a web delivery method
select an origin domain which is
sunshinelearning.n
and origin path you don't have to
specify origin id is this one
so basically when you define an origin
domain name automatically the origin id
appears
you can customize this origin id as per
your requirement also
so rest of the things primarily we keep
it as a default settings only until and
unless if we require some customized
settings to be done
so let's say if you have to change the
cache behavior settings you can do that
otherwise we'll keep it as default
now in the distribution setting you can
either
select use all edge locations for the
best performance so what does aws
basically do here
it uses all the edge locations
which are associated with aws across the
globe
otherwise you can specify based on the
regions also right
apart from that if you want to enable
firewalls or the access control list you
can specify here
and then
what you need to do is in the default
root object here you have to specify
your index.html
page which is in the s3 bucket
the distribution state has to be enabled
and if you want to use ipv6 as well you
need to enable it click on create
distribution
now you you can see here
a distribution has been created it's in
progress and it is enabled
[Music]
and it takes around 15 to 20 minutes to
get that distribution
completed the reason is that the web
codes the web pages will be
distributed across all the edge
locations across the globe so hence it
takes time to get that done
right now let's move on to root 53
service
and let's create the hosted zones
so we'll type root 53 here scalable dns
and domain name registration
and what we are going to do here is
we are going to map our url the domains
pointed to
the name servers that will be provided
by the root 53 so we have to create a
hosted zone
let's wait for it
so now
the route 53 dashboard is open and you
can see one hosted zone is already
created so just click on the hosted
zones
and in order to point the traffic from
the external domains towards the aws
you have to first point the domains
traffic to the
hosted zone in the route 53
so
i'll click on create hosted zone but
before that i will
first delete the existing one
and then i'll
create another record
another hosted zone
right
put your domain name let's say i put us
sunshine learning dot in
and it is acting as a public hosted zone
rest of the things will be default click
on create hosted zone
now it gives you four name servers and
these four name servers has to be
updated
in the domain so you have to update
these name servers in a platform from
where you have purchased the domain
right so this is half of the work done
then what you need to do is you have to
go and create records
now in the records you can select a
routing policy so right now what we are
targeting we are targeting basically
that the traffic from the domain should
be pointed directly towards the
cloudfront distribution
hence we are going with a simple routing
right now
click on next
here you have to specify the record sets
so we are going to create the records
uh just click on default simple record
put here as world wide web
and you have to select an end point so
end point we are selecting for the
cloudfront distribution so we have to
specify
alias for the cloudfront distribution
now here we are going to put uh
the cloudfront distribution url
and then we are going to define the
simple report set
so what we need is we need a cloudfront
distribution url
which you can find it
from the cloudfront service itself
and you can find the domain name here
itself
you just have to copy that
and then
paste it here in the distribution
just click on define simple records
again click on create records
and here you can see
the record set has been updated
now this domain is basically
pointed towards these name servers which
are further pointed
towards the cloudfront distribution
right now the only thing which is left
is that
within the domain from wherever you have
purchased the domain
you should update these phone name
servers and
then you can see the live traffic coming
on this domain
will have an output from the cloud front
distribution
let's begin with our tutorial and let's
look into what we have in aws auto
scaling so
i would be covering up
why we require aws auto scaling
what is aws auto scaling
what are the benefits
of
using the scaling service
how this auto scaling works
the different scaling plans we have
uh what is the difference between the
snapshot and the ami
what is the load balancer and how many
types of load balancers we have and
along with that i would be covering up a
real life demo on the aws
let's begin with why we require aws auto
scaling
now before aws cloud scaling there was a
question in the mind of enterprises that
they were spending a lot of
money on the purchase of the
infrastructure
if they have to set up some kind of a
solution so they have to purchase an
infrastructure and one time cost was
required
so that was a burden for them in terms
of procuring a server hardware software
and then
having a team of experts to manage all
those infrastructure
so they used to think that no longer
they require these resources
if there was a cost efficient solution
for their project that was the project
manager used to think
now after the aws cloud scaling that was
introduced
automatically the auto scaling maintains
the application performance
based on the user requirements at the
lowest possible price
so what does the auto scaling does is
that whenever there is a scalability
required it manages it automatically
and hence the cost optimization became
possible
now what is aws auto scaling let's look
into deep so aws auto scaling is a
service that helps users to monitor
their applications and the servers
and automatically adjust the capacity of
their infrastructure
to maintain the steadiness so they can
increase the capacity they can even
decrease the capacity also for the cost
optimization
and also predictable performance at the
lowest possible cost
now what are the benefits of auto
scaling
it gave the better fault tolerance
applications you can get the servers
created and you can have a clone copy of
the servers so that you don't have to
deploy the applications again and again
better cost management because the
scalability is decided by the aws
automatically based on some threshold
parameters
it was a reliable service and
whenever the scaling is created or
initiated you can get the notifications
onto your mail ids or to your cell
phones
scalability as i mentioned is always
there in the auto scaling it can scale
up it can scale down as well
and it has the flexibility the
flexibility in terms of whenever you
want to schedule it if you want to stop
it if you want to keep the size of the
servers at a fixed number
uh you can always make the changes on
the fly
and the better availability
now
with the use of the auto scaling we come
around with the terminology called
snapshot and the ami let's look into the
difference between the snapshots and the
ami
snapshots versus ami
so in a company there was one of the
employee that was facing an issue with
launching the virtual machines
so he asked his colleague a question
is it possible to launch multiple
virtual machines with a minimum amount
of time because it takes a lot of time
in terms of creating the virtual
machines
the other colleagues said that yes it is
possible to launch multiple ec2 instance
and that can be done at a lesser time
and with the same configuration
and this can be done either you use a
snapshot or the ami on the aws
then the colleague said that what are
the differences between the snapshot and
ami
let's look into the difference now the
snapshots basically kind of a backup of
a single ebs volume
which is just like a virtual hard drive
that is attached to the ec2 instance
whereas the ami it is basically used as
a backup of an ec2 instance only
the snapshots
opts for this when the instance contain
multiple static ebs when you opt for the
snapshot whenever the instance contains
multiple static evs volumes
ami this is widely used to replace the
failed
ec2 instance
in the snapshots here you pay only for
the storage of the modified data
whereas with the ami you pay only for
the storage that you use
the snapshots are non-bootable images on
abs volume
whereas ami are bootable images on the
ec2 instance
however creating an ami image will also
create the evs snapshots
now how does aws auto scaling work let's
look into it
so for the awa sort of scaling to work
you have to configure single unified
scaling policy for application resource
and this scaling policy with that you
can explore the applications also
and then
select the service you want to scale
also for the optimization select do you
want to optimize the cost or do you want
to optimize the performance
and then keep track of scaling by
monitoring or getting the notifications
now what are the different scaling plans
we have
so
in the auto scaling a scaling plan
basically helps a user to configure a
set of instructions
for scaling based on
the particular software requirement
the scaling strategy basically guides
the service of aws auto scaling on how
to optimize resources in a particular
application so it's basically uh kind of
the parameters that you set it up so
that how the resource optimization can
be achieved in the auto scaling
with the scaling strategies users can
create their own strategy based on their
required metrics and thresholds and this
can be changed on the fly as well
what are the two types of scaling
policies we have so there are basically
dynamic scaling and the predictive
scaling
now what is dynamic scaling it basically
guides the service of aws auto scaling
on how to optimize the resources
and it is helpful in optimizing
resources for availability and
particular price
now with scaling strategies users can
create their plan based on the required
metrics and thresholds so a metric can
be like let's say a network in network
out or it can be a cpu utilization
memory utilization likewise
now in the predictive scaling its
objective is to predict future workload
based on daily and weekly trends and
regular forecast future network traffic
so it is kind of a forecast that happens
based on the previous past experiences
it uses a machine learning technique for
analyzing that network graphic and this
scaling is like how weather forecast
works
right it provides schedule scaling
actions to ensure the resource capacity
is available for application requirement
now
with the auto scaling you would need the
load balancers also because if there are
multiple instances that are created then
you would need a load balancer to
distribute
the load to those instances
so
let's understand what do we mean by a
load balancer
a load balancer basically acts as a
reverse proxy
and it is responsible for distributing
the network or the application traffic
across multiple
servers
with the help of a load balancer you can
achieve a reliability you can achieve a
fault tolerance of an application that
is basically it increases the fault
tolerance and the reliability
so for example
when there is a high network traffic
that is coming to your application and
if that much traffic comes to your
application to the instances your
instances may crash
so how you can avoid that situation
so you need to manage the network
traffic that is coming to your instances
and that can be done with the load
balancer so thanks to the aws load
balancers which helps in distributing
network traffic across backend servers
in a way that it increases performance
of an application here in the image you
can see the traffic coming from a
different resources landing on to the
ec2 instance and the load balancer is
actually distributing that traffic to
all the three instances hence managing
the network traffic quite properly
now what are the types of load balancers
we have there are three types of load
balancers on the aws one is the classic
load balancer second is the application
load balancer and the third one is the
network load balancer
let's look into what we have in the
classic load manager so the classic load
balancer is the most basic form of load
balancing and we call it as a primitive
load balancer also and it is widely used
for the ec2 instances
it is based on the ip address and the
tcp port and it routes network traffic
between end users as well as in between
the backend servers
and it does not support host-based
routing and it results in low efficiency
of resources
let's look into what we have in the
application load balancer
this is one of the advanced forms of
load balancing it performs a task on the
application level in the osi model
it is used when there are http and https
traffic routing is required
and also it supports the host based and
path-based routing and performs well
with the microservices of the backend
applications
the network load balancer performs the
task at layer 4 of the connection level
in the osi model
the prime role of the network load
balancer is to route the tcp traffic
and it can manage a massive amount of
traffic and is also suitable to manage
the low latencies
let's look into the demo uh and see how
practically we can
create the auto scale
hi guys let's look into the demo for how
we can create an auto scaling on the aws
console
so right now i'm logged in into the aws
console and i am in the mumbai region
what you need to do is you have to go to
the compute section and under that click
on the easy to service
let's wait for the ec2 servers to come
now just scroll down
and under the load balancing there is an
option called auto scaling so there
first you have to create a launch
configuration and then after that you
have to create the auto scaling groups
so click on launch configuration
and then you have to click on create
launch configurations
so click on create launch configuration
now this launch configuration is
basically this set of parameters that
you define while launching an auto
scaling so that this uniformity is
maintained with all the instances
so that includes let's say if you select
a windows os or a linux os that
particular type of an operating system
will be implemented in all the instances
that will be part of an auto scaling
so there are certain set of parameters
that we have to specify during the
launch configuration so that we can have
a uniformity in terms of launching the
servers
so here i would select an amazon linux
ami
and then i would select the type of
server which will be t2.micro
click on configure details
put the name to the launch configuration
let's say we put it as a demo
and the rest of the things we'll keep it
default
click on add storage
since it's a linux ami we can go with
the 8gb storage that should be fine
click on configure security group
let's create a new security group which
has the ssh port opened and that is open
for
anywhere which is basically source ipv4
and ipv6 ips any ip would be able to
access
that click on review
just review your launch configuration if
you want to make changes you can do that
otherwise click on create a launch
configuration
you would need the key pair and this key
pair will be a unique key pair which
will be used with all the instances that
are part of the auto scaling group
so we can select an existing key pair if
you have that otherwise you can create a
new key pair
so i have an existing key pair i'll go
with that acknowledge it and click on
create launch condition
now we have successfully launched the
configuration of an auto scaling the
next thing is to create an auto scaling
group
so click on create an auto scaling group
using this launch configuration
put a group name let's say we put
something like test
and the group size to start with
it says one instance so that means at
least a single instance will always be
running and it will be initiated and
running 24 cross 7 till the auto scaling
is available
you can increase the size of the minimum
base instances also let's say you can
change it to 2 also so you would get at
least two servers running all the time
so we'll go with the one instance
the network would be the vpc default and
in the vpc particular region we can
select
the availability zones so let's say if i
select availability zone 1a
and then availability zone 1b
so how the instances will be launched so
one instance will be launched in one a
the other one in the one b the third one
in the one a fourth one and the one b
likewise
it will
be equally spread among the availability
zones
next part is to configure the scaling
policies so click on it
if you want to keep this group at its
initial size let's say if you want to go
with only a single instance or two
instances and you don't want the scaling
to progress you can put it
keep this group at its initial size so
this is basically a way to hold the
scaling
but we'll use the scaling policies to
adjust the capacity of this group so
click on it and we would scale between
let's say minimum one instance that we
have and we'll scale it between one two
four instances
and
what condition on what basis these
instances will be scaled up or scaled
down would be defined in the scale group
size
so the scaling policies you can
implement
based on
a scale group size or using the simple
scaling policies using the steps
so in the scale group size you have a
certain metrics you can use average cpu
utilization you can define a metric
related to average networking average
network out
or the load balancer request counts per
target
and if you create the simple scaling
policies using steps then you need to
create the alarms and there you can get
some more metrics that you can add up
as a parameter for the auto scaling
let's go with the scaling group size
let's go with the metric type as average
cpu utilization and the target value
here you have to specify what would be
the threshold that when the instance cpu
utilization is crossed then a new
instance should be initiated
so you can put a reasonable threshold
for that let's say we put something like
85 percent
and whenever the instance cpu
utilization is crossed 85 threshold you
will see that there will be a new
instance created
let's go to the next configure
notifications
and here you can add notifications so
let's say if there is a new instance
that is initiated and you want to
basically be notified so you can get
notifications over your email ids or you
can get it on the cell phones so for
that for adding the notification you
would need the sns service that is
called as a simple notification service
and
you have to create a topic there you
have to subscribe for the topic using
your email id and then you should get
the notifications
click on configure tags
the tags are not mandatory you can
basically
put a tag let's say if you want to
identify the instance what purpose it
was created otherwise you can leave it
blank also click on review
and review your scaling policies
notification tags
as well as the scaling group details
click on create auto scaling group
and here you go your scaling has been
launched click on close
and you should get at least a single
instance initiated automatically by the
auto scaling
so let's wait for the details to appear
so here you can see our launch
configuration name demo
auto scaling group name test
minimum instance we want
one the maximum instances we want four
we have selected two availability zones
ap south one ap south 1b
and
the instance one has been initiated and
if you want to verify where exactly this
instance has been initiated just click
on the instances here
and here you will see
that
our single instance has been initiated
that is in service
and that has been initiated in ap south
1b
now once the threshold of this instance
crosses 85 percent that is what we have
defined in the scaling policies
then you should see that another
instance will be initiated
so likewise this is basically
i have created steps to
initiate a scaling policy that means to
increase the number of servers whenever
the threshold crosses likewise here
itself you can add another policy to
scale down
the resources in case if the cpu
utilization goes to a
normal value so let's begin with amazon
redshift and let's see what we have for
today's session so what's in it for you
today we'll see what is aws uh why we
require amazon redshift what do we mean
by amazon redshift the advantages of
amazon redshift the architecture of
amazon redshift some of the additional
concepts associated with the redshift
and the companies that are using the
amazon redshift and finally we'll cover
up one demo which will show you the
practical example that how you can
actually use the redshift service now
what is aws as we know that aws stands
for amazon web service it's one of the
largest cloud providers in the market
and it's basically a secure cloud
service platform provided from the
amazon also on the aws you can create
and deploy the applications
using the aws service along with that
you can access the services provided by
the aws over the public network that is
over the internet they are accessible
plus you pay only whatever the service
you use for now let's understand why we
require amazon redshift so earlier
before amazon redshift what used to
happen that the people used to or the
developers used to fetch the data from
the data warehouse so data warehouse is
basically a terminology which is
basically represents the collection of
the data so a repository where the data
is stored is generally called as a data
warehouse now
fetching data from the data warehouse
was a complicated task because might be
a possibility that the developer is
located at a different geography and the
data data warehouse is at a different
location and probably there is not that
much network connectivity or
some networking challenges internet
connectivity challenges security
challenges might be and a lot of
maintenance was required to manage the
data warehouses so what are the cons of
the traditional data warehouse services
it was time consuming to download or get
the data from the data warehouse
maintenance cost was high and there was
the possibility of loss of information
in between the downloading of the data
and the data rigidity was an issue now
how these problems could overcome and
this was basically solved with the
introduction of amazon redshift over the
cloud platform now we say that amazon
redshift has solved traditional data
warehouse problems that the developers
were facing but how what is amazon
redshift actually is so what is amazon
redshift it is one of the services over
the aws amazon web services which is
called as a data warehouse service so
amazon redshift is a cloud-based service
or a data warehouse service that is
primarily used for collecting and
storing the large chunk of data so it
also helps you to get or extract the
data analyze the data using some of the
bi tools so business intelligence tools
you can use and get the data from the
redshift and process that and hence it
simplifies the process of handling the
large scale data sets so this is the
symbol for the amazon redshift over the
aws now let's discuss about one of the
use case so dna is basically a
telecommunication company and they were
facing an issue with managing their
website and also the amazon s3 data
which led down to slow process of their
applications now how could they overcome
this problem let's say that so they
overcome this issue by using the amazon
redshift and all the company noticed
that there was a 52 increase in the
application performance now did you know
that amazon redshift is basically cost
less to operate than any other cloud
data warehouse service
available on the cloud computing
platforms and also the performance of an
amazon redshift is the fastest data
warehouse we can say that that is
available as of now so in both cases one
is that it saves the cost as compared to
the traditional data warehouses and also
the performance of this red shift
service or a data warehouse service the
fastest available on the cloud platforms
and more than 15 000 customers primarily
presently they are using the amazon
redshift service now let's understand
some of the advantages of amazon
redshift first of all as we saw that it
is one of the fastest available data
warehouse service so it has the high
performance second is it is a low cost
service so you can have a large scale of
data warehouse or the databases combined
in a data warehouse at a very low cost
so whatever you use you pay for that
only scalability now in case if you
wanted to increase the nodes of the
databases in your redshift you can
actually increase that based on your
requirement and that is on the fly so
you don't have to wait for the
procurement of any kind of a hardware or
the infrastructure it is whenever you
require you can scale up or scale down
the resources so this scalability is
again one of the advantage of the amazon
redshift availability since it's
available across multiple availability
zones so it makes this service as a
highly available service security so
whenever you create whenever you access
redshift you create a clusters in the
redshift and the clusters are created in
the you can define a specific virtual
private cloud for your cluster and you
can create your own security groups and
attach it to your cluster so you can
design the security parameters based on
your requirement and you can get your
data warehouse or the data items in a
secured place flexibility and you can
remove the clusters you can create under
clusters if you are deleting a cluster
you can take a snapshot of it and you
can move those snapshots to different
regions so that much flexibility is
available on the aws for the service and
the other advantage is that it is
basically a very simple way to do a
database migration so if you're planning
that you wanted to migrate your
databases from the traditional data
center over the cloud on the redshift it
is basically a very simple to do a
database migration you can have some of
the inbuilt tools available on the aws
access you can connect them with your
traditional data center and get that
data migrated directly to the redshift
now let's understand the architecture of
the amazon redshift so architecture of
an amazon redshift is basically it
combines of a cluster and that we call
it as a data warehouse cluster in this
picture you can see that this is a data
warehouse cluster and this is a
representation of amazon redshift so it
has
some of the compute nodes which does the
data processing and a leader node which
gives the instructions to these compute
nodes and also the leader node basically
manages the client applications that
require the data from the redshift so
let's understand about the components of
the redshift the client application of
amazon redshift basically interact with
the leader node using jdbc or the odbc
now what is jdbc it's a java database
connectivity and the odbc stands for
open database connectivity the amazon
redshift service using a jdbc connector
can monitor the connections from the
other client applications so the leader
node can actually have a check on the
client applications using the jdbc
connections whereas the odbc allows a
leader node to have a direct interaction
or to have a live interaction with the
amazon redshift so odbc allows a user to
interact with data of amazon redshift so
it has a direct connectivity direct
access of the applications as well as
the leader node can get the information
from the compute nodes now what are
these compute nodes these are basically
kind of our databases which does the
processing so amazon redshift has a set
of computing resources which we call it
as a nodes and the nodes when they are
combined together they are called it as
a clusters now a cluster a set of
computing resources which are called as
nodes and this gathers into a group
which we call it as a data warehouse
cluster so you can have a compute node
starting from 1 to n number of nodes and
that's why we call that the redshift is
a scalable service because we can scale
up the compute nodes whenever we require
now the data warehouse cluster or the
each cluster has one or more databases
in the form of a nodes now what is a
leader node this node basically manages
the interaction between the client
application and the compute node so it
acts as a bridge between the client
application and the compute nodes also
it analyzes and develop designs in order
to carry out any kind of a database
operations so leader node basically
sends out the instructions to the
compute nodes basically perform or
execute that instruction and give that
output to the leader node so that is
what we are going to see in the next
slide that the leader node runs the
program and assign the code to
individual compute nodes and the compute
nodes execute the program and share the
result back to the leader node for the
final aggregation and then it is
delivered to the client application for
analytics or whatever the client
application is created for so compute
nodes are basically categorized into
slices and each node slice is alerted
with specific memory space or you can
say a storage space where the data is
processed these node slices works in
parallel in order to finish their work
and hence when we talk about a redshift
as a fast faster processing capability
as compared to other data warehouses or
traditional data warehouses this is
because that these node slides work in a
parallel operation that makes it more
faster now the additional concept
associated with amazon redshift is there
are two additional concepts associated
with the redshift one is called as the
column storage and the other one is
called as the compression let's see what
is the column storage as the name
suggests column storage is basically
kind of a data storage in the form of a
column so that whenever we run a query
it becomes easier to pull out the data
from the columns so column storage is an
essential factor in optimizing query
performance and resulting in quicker
output so one of the examples are
mentioned here so below example show how
database tables store record into disk
block by row so here you can see that if
we wanted to pull out some kind of an
information based on the city address
age we can basically create a filter and
from there we can put out the details
that we require and that is going to
fetch out the details based on the
column storage so that makes data more
structured more streamlined and it
becomes very easier to run a query and
get that output now the compression is
basically to save the column storage we
can use a compression as an attribute so
compression is a column level operation
which decreases the storage requirement
and hence it improves the query
performance and this is one of the
syntax for the column compression now
the companies that are using amazon
redshift one is lya the other one is
equinox the third one is the pfizer
which is one of the famous
pharmaceuticals company mcdonald's one
of the burger chains across the globe
and philips it's an electronic company
so these are one of the biggest
companies that are basically relying and
they're putting their data on the
redshift data warehouse service now in
another video we'll see the demo for
using the amazon redshift let's look
into the amazon redshift demo so these
are the steps that we need to follow for
creating the amazon redshift cluster and
in this demo what we'll be doing is that
we'll be creating an im role for the
redshift so that the redshift can call
the services and specifically we'll be
using the s3 service so the role that
we'll be creating will be giving the
permission to redshift to have an access
of an s3 in the read-only format so in
the step one what we require we'll check
the prerequisites and what you need to
have is the aws credentials if you don't
have that you need to create your own
credentials and you can use your credit
and the debit card and then in the step
2 we'll proceed with the im role for the
amazon redshift once the role is created
we'll launch a sample amazon redshift
cluster mentioned in the step 3 and then
we'll assign a vpc security groups to
our cluster now you can create it in the
default vpc also you can create a
default security groups also otherwise
you can customize the security groups
based on your requirement now to connect
to the sample cluster you need to run
the queries and you can connect to your
cluster and run queries on the aws
management console query editor which
you will find it in the redshift only or
if you use the query editor you don't
have to download and set up a sql client
application separately and in the step 6
what you can do is you can copy the data
from the s3 and upload that in the
redshift because the redshift would have
an access a read-only access
for the s3 as that will be created in
the im role so let's see how we can
actually use the redshift on the aws so
i am already logged in into my account i
am in north virginia region i'll search
for redshift service and here i find
amazon redshift so just click on it
let's wait for the redshift to come now
this is a redshift dashboard and from
here itself you have to run the cluster
so to launch a cluster you just have to
click on this launch cluster and once
the cluster is created and if you wanted
to run queries you can open query editor
or you can basically create queries and
access the data from the red shift so
that's what it was mentioned in the
steps also that you don't require a
separate sql client application to get
the queries run on the data warehouse
now before creating a cluster we need to
create the role so what we'll do is
we'll click on the services and we'll
move to i am role section so im rule i
can find here under the security
identity and compliance so just click on
the identity access management and then
click on create roles so let's wait for
i am page to open so here in the im
dashboard you just have to click on the
rules i already have the role created so
what i'll do is i'll delete this role
and i'll create it separately so just
click on create role and under the aws
services you have to select for the
redshift because now the redshift will
be calling the other services and that's
why we are creating the role now which
other services that the redshift will be
having an access of s3 why because we'll
be putting up the data on the s3 and
that is something which needs to be
uploaded on the redshift so we'll just
search for the redshift service and
we can find it here so just click on it
and then click on red shift customizable
in the use case now click on next
permissions and here in the permissions
give the access to this role assign the
permissions to this role in the form of
an s3 read-only access so you can search
here for the s3 also let's wait for the
policies to come in here it is let's
type s3 and here we can find amazon s3
read-only access so just click on it and
assign the permissions to this role tags
you can leave them blank click on next
review put a name to your role let's put
my redshift role and click on a create
role now you can see that your role has
been created now the next step is that
we'll move to redchat service and we'll
create one cluster so click on the
services click on amazon redshift you
can find that in the history section
since we browsed it just now and from
here we are going to create a sample
cluster now to launch a cluster you just
have to click on launch this cluster
whatever the uncompressed data size you
want in the form of a gigabyte terabyte
or petabyte you can select that and
let's say if you select in the form of
gb how much db memory you want you can
define it here itself this also gives
you the information about the costing on
demand is basically pay as you use so
they are going to charge you 0.5 dollars
per r for using the two node slices so
let's click on launch this cluster and
this will be a dc2 dot large kind of an
instance that will be given to you it
would be in the form of a solid state
drive ssds which is one of the fastest
way of storing the information and
the nodes two are mentioned by default
that means there will be two node slices
and that will be created in a cluster
you can increase them also let's say if
i put three node slices so it is going
to give us 3 into 0.16 db per node
storage now here you have to define the
master username password for your
redshift cluster and you have to follow
the password instructions so i would put
a password to this cluster and if it
accepts that means it does not give you
any kind of a warning otherwise it is
going to tell you about you have to use
the ascii characters and all and here
you have to assign this cluster the role
that we created recently so in the
available im rules you just have to
click on my redshift role and then you
have to launch the cluster if you wanted
to change something in with respect to
the default settings let's say if you
wanted to change the vpc from default
vpc to your custom vpc and you wanted to
change the default security groups to
your own security group so you can
switch to advanced settings and do that
modification now let's launch the
cluster and here you can see the
redshift cluster is being created now if
you wanted to run queries on this
redshift cluster so you don't require a
separate sql client you just have to
follow
the simple steps to run a query editor
and the query editor you will find it on
the dashboard so let's click on the
cluster and here you would see that the
red shift cluster would be created with
the three nodes in the us east1b
availability zone so we have created the
redshift cluster
in the ohio region and now what we'll do
is we'll
see how we can create the tables inside
the redshift and we'll see how we can
use the copy command so that we can
directly move the data uploaded on the
s3 bucket to the red shift database
tables and then we'll query the results
of a table as well so how we can do that
first of all after creating the redshift
cluster we have to
install sql workbench slash j
this is not a mysql which is managed by
oracle and you can find this
on the google you can download it from
there and
then you have to connect this client
with the redshift database how you can
do click on file click on connect window
and after connecting a window
you have to paste the url which is a
jdbc driver this driver link you can
find it onto the aws console so if you
open up a redshift cluster there you
would find the jdbc driver link let's
wait for it so this is our cluster
created let's open it and here you can
find this jdbc url and also make sure
that in the security groups of a
redshift you have the port 5439 open for
the traffic incoming traffic you also
need to have the amazon redshift driver
and this is the link where you can
download the driver and specify the path
once you are done with that you provide
the username and the password that you
created while creating the redshift
cluster click on ok so this connects
with the database and now the database
connection is almost completed now what
we will be doing in the sql workbench we
will be
first creating the sales table and then
in the sales table we will be adding up
the entries copied from the s3 bucket
and then move it to the redshift
database and after that we'll query the
results in the sales table now whatever
the values you are creating in the table
the same values needs to be in the data
file and
i have taken up this sample data file
from this link which is
docs.aws.amazon.com redshift sample
database creation and here you can find
a download file ticketdb.zip file this
folder has basically multiple
data files sample data files which you
can actually use it uh to practice
uploading the data on the redshift
cluster so i have extracted one of the
files
from this folder and then i have
uploaded that file in the s3 bucket now
we'll move into the s3 bucket let's look
for the file that has been uploaded on
the s3 bucket so this is the bucket
sample and sales underscore tab dot text
is the file that i have uploaded this
has the entries data entries that will
be uploaded using a copy command onto
the red shift cluster now after
executing after putting up the command
for creating up the table then
we'll use a copy command
and
copy command we have to define the table
name the table name is sales and we have
to define the path from where the data
would be copied over to the sales table
in the redshift now path is the s3
bucket and this is the redshift bucket
sample and
it has to look for the data inside the
sales underscore tab.text file also we
have to define the
role arn that was created previously and
once it is done then the third step is
to query the results inside the sales
table to check whether our data has been
uploaded correctly on the table or not
now what we'll do is we'll execute all
these three syntax it gives us the error
because we have to connect it again to
the database let's wait for it
execute it
it's again gives us the error let's look
into the name of the bucket it's
redshift bucket sample so we have two
t's mentioned here right
let's connect with the database again
and now execute it so table sales
created and we got the error the
specified bucket does not exist uh
redshift bucket sample let's view the
bucket name redshift bucket sample let's
copy that put it here connect to the
window connect back to the database
right and now execute it so table sales
created
the data in the table has been copied
from the s3 bucket
to sales underscore tab.text to the
redshift and then the query of the
results the results
from the table has been queried in this
section you'll learn what elastic load
balancing is
elastic load balancing automatically
distributes incoming application traffic
across multiple amazon ec2 instances
it enables you to achieve increased
levels of fault tolerance for your
applications by seamlessly providing the
required amount of load balancing
capacity needed to distribute the
application traffic
you can distribute incoming traffic
across your ec2 instances in a single
availability zone or multiple
availability zones
elastic load balancing automatically
scales its request handling capacity in
response to incoming traffic
elastic load balancing can also detect
the health of your amazon ec2 instances
when it detects an unhealthy instance
it'll spread the load across the
remaining instances and no longer route
traffic to the unhealthy instance
when you're using vpc you can create and
manage security groups associated with
elastic load balancing to provide
additional networking and security
options
you can also create a load balancer
without a public ip address so it serves
as an internal ie non-internet facing
load balancer
elastic load balancing also supports the
ability to stick user sessions to
specific ec2 instances using cookies
if you remember from lesson two when we
talked about session affinity this is a
version of that
in this demonstration we're going to
create a load balancer for our simply
learned web servers
so to do that we'll go to the compute
ec2 section
and i want to show you that before we
can configure load balancing there's a
couple of things we need to do so if we
go to load balancers on the left hand
side
and then click on create load balancer
so we want to create the load balancer
inside simply learn vpc now i want to
show you this warning that comes up says
please select at least two subnets in
different availability zones to provide
high availability for your load balancer
and you could think well that's great we
have two subnets we have a public subnet
and a private subnet and they're both in
different availability zones so if we
add them both
we get another warning so this is an
internet facing elastic load balancer
but there is no internet gateway
attached to the subnet you have just
selected so obviously our private
gateway private subnet only has a nat
gateway to provide its internet access
so it's not a public internet facing
subnet so what that means is we need to
create a new
public subnet in a different
availability zone for our load balancer
so we already have
this one public in us east 1b we're
going to create a public subnet in us
east 1c as well
so to do that let's go back
to the networking vpc section
and this is going to be a quick review
of the vpc lesson
so we'll go to subnets
we'll sort by vpc so here are our two
existing subnets
so we'll create a new subnet and we're
going to call it let me just paste what
i copied we're going to call it 10.0.3.0
u.s
east1c
simply learn pub
and we're going to put it in our simply
learn vpc
and we want to put it in the us east 1c
availability zone so it's different to
our existing public subnet
and we're going to put it in
that cidr block
so let's click create
so there we are now we have
three subnets in our simply then bbc two
of them are public now if you remember
when you create a new subnet it will get
attached to your default root table
by default
so
that's no good because our default root
table doesn't have internet access so we
need to go to root tables we click on
our main default root table and have a
look at subnet associations we can see
that our new subnet
is in here so we need to move it
into our custom root table
so it will be the same as our existing
public subnet so if we click on edit
we just tick the box next to our new
public subnet
and click save
so now our new public subnet is in
this route table so it has internet
access so now we're good to go
so let's go back to the ec2 section and
we want to launch a new web server
into this new public subnet
we'll go to
well we'll launch it from our ami
because we've already configured our web
servers as an ami so we'll click launch
we'll choose t2 nano
we'll configure our instance details
so we're going to place it in the
simplylandvpc
we're going to place it in our new
public subnet in the us east1c
availability zone
we're going to enable the public ip
we're going to give it the administrator
i am role
and we're going to protect against
accidental termination
the storage is fine
we're going to tag this one as
simply learn web server 3.
we'll configure the security group so
we'll put it in an existing group which
will be
the
web service group
and we'll launch it
using our existing simply learn key pair
which i have possession of
okay so that's launching
so we can
see our simply learn web servers
so there we are they've got three of
them we've got one two which are already
up and running and number three which is
coming online
so now we're ready to create our load
balancing so let's go to load balances
again
and create load balancer
we want to put it in our vpc and we'll
give it a name so this is the kind of
internal name we can tag it differently
later on
because you can't put any underscores or
hyphens in this section
so we'll call it simply learn lb simply
learn vpc if we wanted to create an
internal load balancer so it was
balancing traffic that was just internal
to our aws vpc we could tick this box is
the listener configuration so what we
can do here is we're saying that any
http traffic that comes in on port 80
to the load balancer is being pushed to
port http 80
on our instances so what we could do is
you could change this you could have a
different port for the load balancer and
it maps it to
your web service you could protect your
web servers but we're just going to
leave it as it is
now we want to add the subnet so we're
going to add
both of our public subnets and that
warning is now gone so now we're good we
have two subnets and two availability
zones
next we assign security groups
so we could just use our existing web
server security group because that has
http port 80 open it also has https
open and ssh
so it's probably good practice to create
a new security group just for our load
balancer so i'll call it simply then
load balancer
sg
and we're simply going to have
http port 80 open from anywhere and
nothing else
i should probably just give it a quick
description so we know what it is
security group
for load balancing
okay so let's click next configure
security settings and it's just telling
us that our load balance security isn't
using a secure listener because we're
not using https or ssl which is fine for
this demonstration next we configure the
health check
so this is the check that the load
balancer is going to perform to see if
our instances are healthy
so it's using http port 80
and it's going to look for existence of
a file so we're going to tell it to look
for
our healthcheck.html file
and if that doesn't exist then
the instance isn't healthy now we can
configure some more details so the
response timeout is five seconds we'll
leave that the interval between checks
the default value is 30 so let's bring
that down because we want to want things
to happen quicker so that's 10 seconds
unhealthy threshold is set to two so if
it has two checks or it doesn't find the
file it's going to determine that the
instance is unhealthy and the healthy
threshold is ten we're also going to
bring that down we'll bring that down to
three
so after three consecutive healthy
checks it will say the instance is
healthy
okay so now we can add
our ec2 instances
so we'll add our three web servers
we've enabled cross zone load balancing
so it can push traffic across both
availability zones and the connection
draining setting will just leave as
default that's when it detects an
unhealthy instance that's how long
before it will start redirecting traffic
elsewhere
so next we'll click on add tags so we
can give
this a more meaningful name
simply learn
underscore load balancer and review and
create okay so we can review everything
we did
well if you should be okay so let's
click create
and our load balancer is now being
created
so let's have a look so here it is
we click on instances you can see the
instances and it's saying they're all
out of service at the moment so that's
because it's just configuring itself and
it will take a while to come up so i'm
going to pause the demonstration and
we'll come back when everything's up and
running
okay so the load balancer has configured
and you can see that two of our three
web servers are in service but our third
web server is out of service
so what do you think this is
well i'll tell you why it's because our
new web server simply learned web server
three has just come up and we haven't
done anything to it other than just
launch the ami
so let's go and check out what's going
on on the instance
so i've opened sessions to our three web
servers here and this is the
new one and it's because
the apache service
isn't started by default so we need to
start the apache service
okay so we get that weird error but the
it tells me it's okay so if we now go
back to the um the load balancer
and we wait a few seconds we should see
simply then web server number three come
online
there you are so now we're online so it
was as simple as just starting the
service
so that shows how load balancing works
today i'm joined by two giants of the
cloud computing industry they'll be
going head to head with each other to
decide who amongst them is better it's
going to be one hello fight now let's
meet our candidates on my left we have
aws who's voiced by a picture hi guys
and on my right we have microsoft azure
who's voiced by anjali hey there so
today we'll be deciding who's better on
the basis of their origin and the
features they provide their performance
in the present day and comparing them on
the basis of pricing market sharing
options free tier and instance
configuration
now let's listen to their opening
statements let's start with aws
launched in 2006 aws is one of the most
commonly used cloud computing platforms
across the world companies like adobe
netflix airbnb htc pinterest and spotify
have put their faith in aws for their
proper functioning it also dominates the
cloud computing domain with almost 40
percent of the entire market share so
far nobody's even gotten close to
beating that number aws also provides a
wide range of services that covers a
great number of domains domains like
compute networking storage migration and
so much more
now let's see what azure has to say
about that azure was launched in 2010
and is trusted by almost 80 percent of
all fortune 500 companies the best of
the best companies in the world choose
to work only with azure azure also
provides its services to more regions
than any other cloud service provider in
the world azure covers 42 regions
already and 12 more are being planned to
be made azure also provides more than
100 services spanning a variety of
domains now that the opening statements
are done let's have a look at the
current market status of each of our
competitors this is the performance
round here we have the stats for the
market share of aws azure and other
cloud service providers this is for the
early 2018 period amazon web services
takes up a whopping 40 percent of the
market share closely followed by hdr at
and other cloud services adding 30
this 40
indicates most organizations clear
interest in using aws
we are number one because of our years
of experience and trust we've created
among our users
sure you're the market leader but we are
not very far behind let me remind you
more than 80 percent of the fortune 500
companies trust azure with their cloud
computing needs so it's only a match of
time before azure takes the lead the
rest of the 30 percent that is in aws or
azure accounts to the other cloud
service providers like google cloud
platform backspace ibm software and so
on now for our next round the comparison
route first we'll be comparing pricing
we'll be looking at the cost of a very
basic instance which is a virtual
machine of two virtual cpus and 8gbs of
ram for aws this will cost you
approximately
0.0928 us dollars per hour and for the
same instance in azure it will cost you
approximately 0.096 us dollars per hour
next up let's compare market share and
options
as i mentioned before aws is the
undisputed market leader when it comes
to the cloud computing domain taking up
40 percent of the market share by 2020
aws is also expected to produce twice
its current revenue which comes close to
44 billion dollars not to mention aws is
constantly expanding its already strong
roaster of more than 100 services to
fulfill the shifting business
requirements of organizations all that
is great really good for you but the
research company gardner has released a
magic quadrant that you have to see you
see the competition is now nectar
between azure and aws it's only a matter
of time before azure can increase from
its 30 market share and surpass aws this
becomes more likely considering how all
companies are migrating from aws to
azure to help satisfy their business
needs azure is not far behind aws when
this comes to services as well azure
service offerings are constantly updated
and improved on to help users satisfy
their cloud computing requirement
now let's compare aws and azure's free
offerings aws provides a significant
number of services for free helping
users get hands-on experience with the
platform products and services the free
tier services fall under two categories
services that will remain free forever
and the others that are valid only for
one year the always free category offers
more than 20 services for example amazon
sms sqs cloud watch etc and the valid
for a year category offers approximately
20 services for example amazon s3 ec2
elastic cache etc
both types of services have limits on
the usage for example storage number of
requests compute time etc but users are
only charged for using services that
fall under the valid for a year category
after a year of their usage a show
provides a free tier as well it also
provides services that belong to the
categories of free for a year and always
free there are about 25 plus always free
services provided by azure these include
app service functions container service
active directory and lots more and as of
the valid for a year there are eight
services offered there's linux or
windows virtual machines blob storage
sql database and few more azure also
provides the users with credits of 200
us dollars to access all their services
for 30 days now this is a unique feature
that azure provides where users can use
their credits to utilize any service of
a choice for the entire month now let's
compare instance configuration the
largest instance that aws offers is that
of a whopping 256 gb of ram and 16
virtual cpus the largest that azure
offers isn't very far behind either 224
gbs of ram and 16 virtual cpus and now
for the final round now each of our
contestants will be shown facts and they
have to give explanations for these
facts we call it the rapid fire round
first we have features in which aws is
good and azure is better aws does not
cut down on the features it offers its
users however it requires slightly more
management on the user's part azure goes
slightly deeper with the services that
fall under certain categories like
platform as a service and infrastructure
as a service
next we have hybrid cloud where aws is
good and azure is better okay although
aws did not emphasize on hybrid cloud
earlier they are focusing more on
technology now azure has always
emphasized on hybrid cloud and has
features supporting it since the days of
its inception for developers aws is
better and azure is good of course it's
better because aws supports integration
with third-party applications well azure
provides access to data centers that
provide a scalable architecture for
pricing both aws and azure are at the
same level it's good for aws because it
provides a competitive and constantly
decreasing pricing model and in the case
of azure it provides offers that are
constantly experimented upon to provide
its users with the best experience
and that's it our contestants have
finished giving their statements now
let's see who won surprisingly nobody
each cloud computing platform has its
own pros and cons choosing the right one
is based entirely on your organization's
requirements we're going to talk about
the best cloud computing platform
available amazon web services uh rahul i
think you said something wrong here the
best cloud computing platform is
obviously google cloud platform no it
isn't aws has more than 100 services
that span a variety of domains all right
but google cloud platform has cheaper
instances what do you have to say about
that well i guess there's only one place
we can actually discuss this a boxing
ring if getting your learning started is
half the battle what if you could do
that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
hi guys this is rahul from simply learn
and today we'll be talking about one of
the fastest growing and second largest
cloud computing platform in the market
right now i'm talking about microsoft
azure now before we begin let's talk
about what we'll be covering in this
video first we'll talk about why you
should be interested in cloud computing
what exactly is cloud computing what is
microsoft is your some of its services
and the uses of azure now let's start
with why you should be interested in
cloud computing now let's say you have
an idea for a revolutionary application
an idea that ticks both the boxes when
it comes to good applications one it has
great user experience and two it'll be
highly profitable now for it to be
successful you'll have to release it on
the internet people need to use it they
need to spread the word and then it'll
become truly famous however for that
you're going to need servers storage
developers a dedicated network and
application security to ensure your
application works the way it does now
these are a lot of components and that's
where the problem lies there are two
major disadvantages to this approach the
initial setup is very expensive and
risky which means this requires a huge
amount of capital up front to ensure
that it works properly and the downside
is if your application does not become
famous or it doesn't return as much as
you expect it to you're probably not
going to get the money back which means
it provides a huge amount of risk and
then on the flip side if it does become
famous your number of users have
increased which means that you'll have
to buy more servers and storage systems
to keep up with your demand and this
problem can be solved with the help of
cloud computing now that you know why
you should be interested in cloud
computing let's go into the details of
what exactly is cloud computing now
cloud computing is basically a platform
that gives you access to a number of
computing resources and this is possible
with the help of the internet now as a
user all you need to do is go to a cloud
service provider through your laptop or
your computer through the internet of
course connect to that cloud service
provider and then there you go you have
access to computing resources now
computing resources may include you know
serverless computing virtual machines
storage and so much more now let's dig a
little deeper now basically these cloud
service providers actually have massive
data centers now in these data centers
what you have are hundreds of servers
also included are storage systems and
mainly several organizations critical
components so these are very secure safe
locations where a large amount of data
is stored hence the name data centers
now it is to these data centers that
users actually connect to collect their
data or use it so actually users can
access any service based on their
requirement now like i told you there's
a number of services the user can use
for example now if you want a
notification every time someone sends
you a message or perhaps once you get an
email you need a copy of it created now
for all of this there are services and
most importantly almost every cloud
service provider has this option where
users only pay for the service that they
use so there's no charge up front where
they tell you that you need to pay x
amount of money so that you can use our
services you're only paying for the
amount of time that you're using these
services now cloud computing is used for
a wide variety of reasons firstly
there's machine learning and data
analysis now basically there are
services that analyze your data and tell
you how you can work with this data
better then there's data storage and
backup streaming media content for
example did you know that the shows that
you watch on netflix actually all of
them are in the cloud so you're
connected to the internet and you browse
through netflix and you get access to
the videos these are possible with the
help of cloud service providers this
creating and testing applications
automating software delivery which is a
component in devops and hosting blogs
and applications so now what is azure
what's the big cloud service provider
all about so azir is a cloud computing
platform provided by microsoft now it's
basically an online portal through which
you can access and manage resources and
services now resources and services are
nothing but you know you can store your
data and you can transform the data
using services that microsoft provides
again all you need is the internet and
being able to connect to the azure
portal then you get access to all of the
resources and their services in case you
want to know more about how it's
different from its rival which is aws i
suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch the aws versus your
video so that you can clearly tell how
both these cloud service providers are
different from each other now here are
some things that you need to know about
azure it was launched in february 1st
2010 which is significantly later than
when aws was launched it's free to start
and has a pay-per-use model which means
like i said before you need to pay for
the services you use through azure and
one of their most important selling
points is that 80 percent of fortune 500
companies use azure services which means
that most of the bigger companies of the
world actually recommend using azure and
then azure supports a wide variety of
programming languages the c-sharp
node.js java and so much more another
very important selling point of azure is
the amount of data centers it has across
the world now it's important for a cloud
service provider to have many data
centers around the world because it
means that they can provide their
services to a wider audience now azure
has 42 which is more than any cloud
service provider has at the moment it
expects to have 12 more in a period of
time which brings its total number of
regions it covers to 54. now let's talk
about azure services now azure services
have 18 categories and more than 200
services so we clearly can't go through
all of them it has services that cover
compute and machine learning integration
management tools identity devops web and
so much more you're going to have a hard
time trying to find a domain that azure
doesn't cover and if it doesn't cover it
now you can be certain they're working
on it as we speak so first let's start
with the compute services first virtual
machine with this service what you're
getting to do is to create a virtual
machine of linux or windows operating
system it's easily configurable you can
add ram you can decrease ram you can add
storage remove it all of it is possible
in a match of seconds now let's talk
about the second service cloud service
now with this you can create a
application within the cloud and all of
the work after you deploy it deploying
the application that is is taken care of
by azure which includes you know
provisioning the application load
balancing ensuring that the application
is in good health and all of the other
things are handled by azure next up
let's talk about service fabric now with
service fabric the process of developing
a micro service is greatly simplified so
you might be wondering what exactly is a
micro service now a micro service is
basically an application that consists
of smaller applications coupled together
next up functions now with functions you
can create applications in any
programming language that you want
another very important part is that you
don't have to worry about any hardware
components you don't have to worry what
ram you require or how much storage you
require all of that is taken care of by
his year all you need is to provide the
code to azure and it'll execute it and
you don't have to worry about anything
else now let's talk about some
networking services first up we have
azure cdn or the content delivery
network now the azure cdn service is
basically for delivering web content to
users now this content is of high
bandwidth and can be transferred or can
be delivered to any person across the
world now these are actually a network
of servers that are placed in strategic
positions across the world so that the
customers can obtain this data as fast
as possible next up we have express r
now with this you can actually connect
your on-premise network onto the
microsoft cloud or any of the services
that you want through a private
connection so the only communication
that happens is between your on-premise
network and the service that you want
then you have virtual network now with
virtual network you can have any of the
azure services communicate with each
other in a secure manner in a private
manner next we have azure dns so azure
dns is a hosting service which allows
you to host their dns or domain name
system domains in azure so you can host
your application using azure dns now for
the storage services first up we have
disk storage with this storage you are
given a cost effective option of
choosing hdd or solid state drives to go
along with your virtual machines based
on your requirements then you have blob
storage now this is actually optimized
to ensure that they can store massive
amounts of unstructured data which can
include text data or even binary data
next you have file storage which is a
managed file storage and can be
accessible via the smb protocol or the
server message block protocol and
finally you have queue storage now with
queue storage you can provide durable
message queuing for an extremely large
workload and the most important part is
that this can be accessed from anywhere
in the world now let's talk about how
azure can be used firstly for
application development it could be any
application mostly web applications then
you can test the application see how
well it works you can host the
application on the internet you can
create virtual machines like i mentioned
before with the service you can create
these virtual machines of any size or
ram that you want you can integrate in
sync features you can collect and store
matrices for example how the data works
how the current data is how you can
improve upon it all of that is possible
with these services and you have virtual
hard drives which is an extension of the
virtual machines where these services
are able to provide you a large amount
of storage where data can be stored i'm
sam an azure cloud architect working for
simply learn and i'm more than glad to
walk you through this session where
we're gonna talk about azure in great
length and breadth and without any
further delay let's get started
everybody like story is it so let's get
started with the story in a city not so
far away a ceo had plans to expand his
company globally and called one of his
id personnel for an i.t opinion and this
guy has been in the company for a long
time and is very seasoned with the
company's infra and he nicely answered
the questions with what he foresaw and
he said i have a good news and a bad
news for us to go global and he starts
with the good news he said sir we're
well on our way to become one of the
world's largest shipping company and the
bad news is however our data centers
have almost run out of space and setting
up new ones around the world would be
too expensive and very time consuming
now the i.t personal let's call him mike
now he explains the situation from how
he saw it but the ceo had done some
homework about how he was going to do it
and he answered mike saying don't worry
about that mic i've come up with a
solution for a problem and it's called
microsoft azure well mike is an
hard-working and harnessed i.t
professional working for that company
but he did not spend time on learning
the latest technologies and he asked
this question very honestly oh how does
it solve a problem and the ceo begins to
explain azure to mike and he starts with
what is cloud computing and then he goes
on and talks about azure and the service
is offered by azure and why azure is
better than the other cloud providers
and what are the great companies that
uses azure and how they got benefited
out of it and then he winds it all up
with the use cases of azure so he begins
his explanation saying microsoft azure
is known as the cloud service provider
and it works on the basis of cloud
computing now microsoft azure is
formerly known as windows azure and it's
a microsoft's public cloud computing
platform it also provides a range of
cloud services including some of them
are compute analytics storage and
networking we can always pick and choose
from these services to develop and scale
our applications or even plan on running
existing applications in the public
cloud microsoft azure is both a platform
as a service and infrastructure as a
service let's now fit their conversation
out and let's talk about what is cloud
computing azure services offered by
azure how is azure leading when compared
to other cloud service providers and
what are the companies that are using
azure let's talk about that in simple
terms cloud computing is being able to
access compute services like servers
storage database networking software
analytics intelligence and lot more over
the internet which is the cloud with the
uh flexibility of the resources that we
use like anytime i wanna reserves i can
use one and it becomes available
immediately and anytime if i wanna
retire and resource i can simply retire
at resource and not pay for it and we
also
typically pay only for these services
that we use and this helps greatly with
our operating costs to run our
infrastructure more efficiently and
scale our environment up or down
depending on the business needs and
changes and all the servers and storages
and databases and networking all that
are accessed through the network of
remote systems or remote computers
hosted in the internet typically in the
provider's data center which is azure in
this case now we don't use any physical
server or an on-premises server here
well we still use physical servers and
vms you know hosted on a hardware or a
physical server but they're all in the
provider's environment and none of them
sit on premises or in our data center we
only access them remotely it looks and
feels the same except for the fact that
they are in a remote location we access
them remotely do all the work remotely
and when we're done we can shut it down
and not pay for them so some of the use
cases
some of the use cases of cloud computing
are creating applications and services
the other use cases are storing or using
cloud for storage alone
if there is one thing that ever grows in
their organization is the storage every
new day there is a new storage
requirement and it's very dynamic it's
very hard to predict and if we go out
and buy a big storage capacity up front
until we use the storage capacity fully
the empty storages you know we're
wasting money on them so instead i can
go for a storage with scales dynamically
that's in the cloud put storage or put
data in the cloud and pay only for what
you're storing and for the next month if
you have deleted or flushed out some
files or data pay less for it so it's a
very dynamic storage in the cloud and a
lot of companies are getting benefited
from storing data in the cloud because
of its uh dynamic in nature and the cost
that comes along with it the cheap cost
that comes along with it and also they
give a lot of the providers like azure
they give a data replication for free
they promise an sla along with the data
we store in the cloud so there's an sla
attached to it and they also provide
data recoveries as well if in case
something goes wrong with the physical
disk where our data is stored azure
automatically makes our data available
from the redundant or
other places where it had stored our
data because of the sla they wanted to
keep the other use case for azure is
hosting websites and running blogs using
the compute service
be it storing music and letting your
users stream the music azure is a good
place to store music and stream the
music with the benefit of cdn content
delivery network which allows us to
stream a video or audio files with great
speed you know with that with azure our
audio or video application works
seamlessly because they are provided to
the client with very low latency and
that improves the customer experience
for our application azure compute
service is a good place for delivering
software on demand there are a lot of
software's embedded softwares that we
can buy using azure and everything on a
pay-as-you-go service model so anytime
we need a software we can go out and
immediately buy the software for the
next one or two hour let's say and use
them and then return it back
we're not bound to any yearly licensing
cost by that azure computing services
has analytic available for us with which
we can analyze get a good visualization
of what's going on in a network be it
logs be the performance be the metrics
you know instead of looking at logs and
searching logs and trying to do manual
things over the heaps and heaps of logs
that we have saved azure analytics
services helps us to get a good visual
of what's going on in the network where
have we dropped where have we increased
or what's causing what's the major
driver what is the top 10 errors that we
get in the server in the application
stuff like that those can be easily
gathered from the azure analytic
services
now cloud is really a very cool term for
the internet a good analogy would be
looking back anytime we look at a
diagram when we do not know how things
are transferred we simply draw a cloud
right for example a male gets sent from
a person in one country to a person in
the other country a lot of things
happening in between from the time you
hit the send button and the time the
other person hits the real button right
and we the simple and the easiest way of
putting it in a picture is simply draw a
cloud and on the one end one person will
be sending the email and on the other
end the other person will be reading the
email so a cloud is a really cool term
for the internet now that's some basics
about cloud computing now that we've
understood about cloud computing in
general let's talk about microsoft azure
as a cloud service
now microsoft azure is a set of cloud
services to build
manage and deploy applications on a
network with the help of microsoft
azure's frameworks now microsoft azure
is a computing service created by
microsoft basically for building testing
deploying and managing applications and
services through a global network of
microsoft managed data centers now
microsoft azure provides sas which is
software as a service and pass which is
platform as a service and ias
infrastructure as a service and they
support many different programming
languages tools and framework and those
tools and framework include both
microsoft specific and third-party
software now let me pick and talk about
a specific service for example
management azure automation provides a
way for us to automate the manual long
running and frequently repeated tasks
that are commonly performed tasks both
in cloud and enterprise environment it
saves us a lot of time and increases the
reliability and it kind of gives a good
administrative control and even
schedules the task automatically to be
performed on a regular basis
to give you a quick history of microsoft
azure it was launched on first february
and it was awarded or it was called
an industry leader for infrastructure
and platform as a service by a gartner
now gartner is the world's leading
research and advisory company this
microsoft azure supports a number of
programming languages like c sharp java
and python all these cool services we
get to use and pay only for how much we
use for example if we use for an r we
only get to pay for an r even the
costliest system available if you use
them for an r we only pay for that
particular r and then we're done no more
billing on the resource that we have
used a microsoft azure has spread itself
more than 50 regions around the world so
it's quite easy for us to pick a region
and start provisioning and running our
applications probably from day one
because the infrastructure and the tools
and technologies needed to run our
application are already available all
that we have to do is commit the code in
that particular region or build an
application and launch it in that
particular region and they become live
starting day one now because we have 50
regions around the world we can very
carefully design our environment to
provide low latency services to our
customers all right instead of in
traditional data center let's say you
know customers will have to or their
request will have to travel all the way
around the globe to reach the data
center which lives in the other side of
the planet and this adds more latency to
it and it is really not feasible to
build a data center
near
each customer location because of the
cost involved but with azure it's
possible azure already has data centers
around the world and all that we have to
do is just pick a data center build an
environment there they are available
starting day one number one and also the
cost is considerably saved because we
are using a public cloud instead of an
physical infrastructure to serve those
customers from a very local location and
these services that azure is offering is
ever increasing as of now as we speak we
have like 200 plus services offered and
they span through different domain or
different platform or different
technologies available within the azure
console portal now we're going to talk
about that later in this section so hold
your breath till we talk about it but
for now just know that we have like 200
plus services offered by azure
let's now talk about different services
and azure starting with artificial
intelligence plus machine learning where
we have a lot of tools and technologies
so the wide variety of services
available on azure includes artificial
intelligence plus machine learning plus
analytic services to get an or to give
us a good visual of how the data or how
the application is performing or the
type of the category of data stored and
to read from the logs and variety of
compute services different vms with
different size and different operating
systems different containers available
different type of databases available a
lot of developer tools that are
available for us
and identity service to
manage our users in the azure cloud and
those users can be integrated or
federated with let's say google facebook
you know linkedin so there are some
external federation services they can be
used to integrate with our identity
system iots iot services iot tools and
technologies available and management
tools to manage the users creating
identity is one and then managing them
on top of it is a totally different
thing and we have tools technologies to
manage the users
cool services for data migration data
migration is now made simple tools and
technologies available for mobile
application development and i can plan
my own network in the cloud with the
networking services i can implement my
own security both azure provider and
third-party security services on azure
cloud that's now possible and a lot of
storage options available in the cloud
so these are just a glimpse of the big
list of services available in azure
cloud so that was a glimpse of what's
available in the cloud let's talk about
the services in a specific let's take
compute for example you know whenever
we're building a new application or
deploying existing ones
the azure compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on demand we can also
containerize our application we have the
option of choosing windows or linux vm
machine and take the advantage of the
flexible options azure provides for us
to migrate our vms to azure and lot more
and these compute services also include
a full-fledged identity solution meaning
integration with active directory in the
cloud or in on-premises and lot more
let's look at some of the services that
this compute domain provides
some of the services the compute domain
provides are virtual machines and this
azure virtual machines gives us the
ability to develop and manage a virtual
computer environment or a virtualized
environment
inside azure's cloud environment that
too in a virtual private network now we
will talk about virtual private network
at a later point but as of now just i
know that there are a lot of services
available in azure compute servers that
we can get benefited from we can always
choose from a very wide range of compute
options
for example you know we have an option
to choose the operating system we have
the option to choose whether the system
should be in on-premises or in the cloud
or do we want to maintain the
environment both in on-premises and in
the cloud we have the option of choosing
the operating system whether we want to
use our own operating system with some
software attached to it or do we want to
go and buy the operating system from the
cloud from azure marketplace and these
are just a few of the options available
for us when we want to buy the compute
environment and these computer
environments are easily scalable meaning
we can easily scale our vm instances
from one instance to thousands of
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
or simply put in a couple of button
clicks and all these services are
available on a pay for what we use model
meaning there is no upfront cost we use
the service and then pay for the
services that we have used there's no
literal long term commitment when it
comes to using virtual machines in the
cloud and these most of the services are
built on a pay-per-minute
billing basis all right and at no point
because of the pay-per-minute billing
model at no point we will be overpaying
for any of the services that's that's
attractive isn't it now let's talk about
batch service now batch service is
always independent regardless of whether
you choose windows or linux it's going
to run fairly well and with batch
servers we can take advantage of the
environment's unique features and not
only that in short the batch service
helps us to manage the whole batch
environment and also it helps to
schedule the jobs now this azure batch
services actually runs on a large scale
parallel in high performance computing
because of that batch jobs are highly
efficient in azure and when we run bad
services this azure batch creates a pool
of computer nodes and installs the
needed applications that we want to run
and then it schedules jobs to those
individual nodes in those pools as a
customer there is no need for us to
install a cluster or there is no need
for us to install a software that
actually can use the jobs or even to
manage or even to scale those
infrastructure or the software because
everything is managed by azure and this
batch service is a platform as a service
there is no additional charge for using
this batch service except for i mean the
only charges that we'll be paying is for
the virtual machines that the service
uses and the storage that we will be
using of course and the networking
services that we would be using for this
batch service let's summarize this bad
service we have a choice of operating
system that we can pick and use and it
scales by itself now the alternative for
the batch would be queues but in queues
we'll have to pre-provision and pay for
the infrastructure even if we're not
using it but with a batch
we only pay for what we use and this bad
service helps us to manage the
application manage the scheduling as a
whole as if they are just one thing as
next thing in the compute domain let's
talk about this fabric service now this
fabric service is actually a distributed
system platform that helps us to package
deploy and manage a scalable and a very
reliable microservice and containers and
what does it help this azure fabric
service helps us or it helps the
developers and administrators so they
can avoid the complex infrastructure
problems and they can focus only on
implementing workloads or taking care of
their development taking care of their
application instead of spending time on
infrastructure so what service fabric
service fabric it provides runtime
capabilities and life cycle management
two applications that are composed of
micro services no infrastructure
management at all and with service
fabric we can easily scale the
application to tens or hundreds or even
to thousands of machines here machines
represent containers as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about virtual
machine scale set now this virtual
machine scale set it lets us to create a
group of identical load balanced vms i
just want to mention it again it helps
us to manage a group identical and load
balanced vms the number of instances or
the number of vm instances in an
in a scale set can increase or decrease
in response to
the demand or in response to schedule
that we define you know the resources
needed on a monday morning is not the
same as that would be required on a
saturday or a sunday morning all right
and even within the day the resources
that would be needed in the beginning of
the business hour is not the resources
that would be needed at noon or you know
after eight or nine in the evening so
the demands could actually vary in the
environment and the skill set helps us
to take care of the varying demand or
take care of the different
infrastructure requirement at a
different schedule throughout the day
throughout the week throughout the month
or could be throughout the year as well
the skill set also allows us to provide
high availability to our applications
and it helps us to centrally manage
configure and update a large number of
vms as if they they are just one thing
now you might ask well virtual machines
are enough why would we need a virtual
machine scale set just like i said this
virtual machine skill set helps us with
a greater redundancy and improved
performance for our applications and
those applications can be accessed
through a load balancer that actually
distributes the request to the
application instances so in a nutshell
this virtual machine scale set uh it
helps us to create a large number of
identical virtual machines number one
and with scale set we can increase or
decrease the virtual machines with
virtual machine scale set we can
centrally manage and configure and
update a big group of vms and it's a
great use case when it comes to big data
or container workloads as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about cloud
services now this azure cloud service is
actually a platform as a service and
it's very friendly in fact it is
designed for applications that support
scalability or an application that
requires scalability or reliability and
and on top of it you want them to be
very inexpensive to operate so azure
cloud service provides all these so
where would this cloud service run well
it runs on a vm but it's a platform as a
service vms are infrastructure as a
service and when we run applications on
vm through cloud service it becomes
platform as a service so here is how you
got to be thinking with infrastructure
as a service like vms we first create
and configure the environment and then
we run applications on top of it let's
look at the responsibility the
responsibility for us in vm is that we
manage everything end to end like
you know deploying new patches picking
the versions of the operating system and
making sure they are intact and all that
stuff it's all managed by us but on the
contrary with platform as a service it's
i mean it's as if the environment is
already ready all that you have to do is
deploy your application in it and manage
the platform i mean manage the platform
not as an administrator because all the
administration is taken care by azure
like deploying new versions of the
operating system it's all handled by the
azure so we deploy the application and
we manage the application that's it
infrastructure management is handled by
azure so what does cloud service provide
this cloud service provides a platform
where we can
write the
application code and we don't have to
worry about hardware simply hand over
the code and cloud service takes care of
it so no worry on the hardware at all so
responsibilities like patching what do
we do if something
crashes how do i update the
infrastructure how do i manage
the maintenance or the downtime in the
underlying infrastructure all that is
handled by azure it also provides a good
testing environment for us you know we
can simply run the code test it before
it's actually released to the production
i want to expand a bit on these testing
applications so this azure cloud service
it actually gives us an staging
environment for testing a new release
without it affecting the existing
release which actually reduces the
customer downtime so we can run the
application tested and anytime that's
ready for production all that's needed
for us to do to move it to production is
simply to swap the staging environment
into the production environment and the
old production environment will now
become the new staging environment where
we can
add more to it and then swap it back at
a later point so it kind of gives us
unswappable environment for testing our
applications and not only that it gives
us health monitoring alerts it helps us
to monitor the health and availability
of our application and there is a
dashboard we can benefit from when we
use azure cloud services and that shows
the key statistics all in one place and
we can also set up real-time alerts to
one when a service availability or a
certain metrics that we are concerned
about degrades as next thing in compute
domain let's talk about functions now
functions are serverless computing many
time if you heard about azure being
serverless a lot of time they are
referencing or the person who's talking
to you is referencing to serverless
computing or azure functions which is a
serverless computing service hosted on
microsoft azure the main motive of
a function is to accelerate and simplify
application development functions helps
us to run code on demand without
we need to pre-provision or manage any
azure infrastructure so azure functions
are script or
a piece of code that gets run in
response to an event that you want to
handle so in short we can just write a
code that you need for a problem at hand
without actually worrying about the
whole application or the infrastructure
that will be running that code and the
best of all the best is when we use
functions we only pay for the time that
our code runs
so what does functions provide or what
does azure functions provide azure
functions allow users to build
applications using serverless
simple functions with a programming
language of our choice so the current
programming languages that are supported
is c sharp f sharp node.js java and php
so here we really don't have to worry
about provisioning or maintaining
servers if a code requires more resource
yes azure functions handles or it
provides the additional resources needed
by the court and the best part is we
only pay for the amount of time the
functions are running not the resources
but the amount of time the function is
running as next thing and moving to the
new domain let's talk about the
container domain in azure now the
container domain or the container
service it allows us to quickly deploy a
production ready kubernetes or a docker
swamp cluster now what's a container a
container is a standard unit of software
that packages of code and all its
dependencies so the applications run
quickly and reliably from one computing
environment to another it could be a
testing uh to staging to developing
development environment to staging to
production or from one production to
another production or on-premises uh to
cloud or one cloud to another cloud vice
versa now imagine we had an option not
to worry about the vm and just focus on
the application well that's exactly what
containers helps us achieve so these
container instances enable us to focus
on applications and not worrying about
managing vms or not worrying about the
learning the new tools required to
manage the vms or even the deployment
and our applications that we create they
run in a container running in a
container is what helps us to achieve
all these not being able to manage or
not needing to manage the virtual
machines so these containers uh they can
be deployed into the cloud using a
single command if you're using a command
line interface and a couple of button
clicks if we are using the azure portal
and these containers are kept
lightweight but they are equally secure
as virtual machines let's talk about
container services next thing the
container service or
sometimes called as azure kubernetes
service it helps us to manage the
containers container is one thing and a
service that's used to manage the
container is another thing now this
kubernetes service or acs it helps us to
manage the containers so let's expand on
this a bit so this azure container
service or acs it it actually provides a
way to simplify the creation
configuration and management of a
cluster of virtual machines that are
pre-configured to run containerized
applications on top of them and
deploying them deploying these
containers might take like 15 to 20
minutes or deploying the virtual
machines that run containers in it might
take 15 to 20 minutes and once they are
provisioned we can actually manage them
by using simple ssh tunnel into them and
this acs when it runs application it
runs applications from docker images
what does that mean a docker images
makes sure that the applications the
container runs are fully portable images
are portable and acs also helps us to
orchestrate the container environment
not only that it also helps us to ensure
that these applications that we run in
containers can be scaled to thousands or
even tens of thousands of containers so
in a nutshell managing an existing
application into a container and running
it using aks or acs is really easy or
that's what it is all about to make the
application management or migration easy
now managing the container based
architecture and we discussed that
containers could be tens or even tens of
thousands of containers so managing them
is made
simple using this container services and
even training of model using a large
data set in a complex and resource
intensive environment this aks helps us
to simplify that environment all right
as next thing in container domain let's
talk about container registry we spoke
about registry a little bit when we
spoke about docker images so container
registry is a single place where we can
store our images which are docker images
when we use when we use containers it's
it's docker images that we use for our
image purposes so these container images
are a central registry that can be used
to ease container development by easing
the storage and management of container
images so there we can store all kind of
images like
docker swamp or the images used in
docker swamp are in kubernetes
everything can be stored in container
registry in azure now anytime we store a
container image it provides us an option
for geo replication what that means is
that we can efficiently manage a single
registry replicated across multiple
regions
now these geo replication it actually
enables us to manage global deployments
assuming we are having an environment
that
requires a global deployment so it helps
us to manage global deployments as one
entity because we are geo-replicating we
would be updating we would be editing
one image and that image gets replicated
throughout
the global replication centers we would
have set up and so just one editing
would have actually edited the global
images and those global images would
have provisioned at the global
application so one edit replication and
then provisioning of the applications
global wide and this replication also
helps us to
helps us network latency because you
know anytime an application needs to
deploy it does not have to rely on a
single source which which can be reached
only through high latency network
because we have global replications
around the world anytime the application
wants to check back it would check back
the application which is in a very
nearby location for the application
itself
global replication means that we are
managing it as a single entity that's
being replicated across the multiple
regions in the globe as next thing in
our learning let's talk about
azure databases now this azure databases
are
rational in fact they have many flavors
in them we're going to look at different
uh flavors no sql nosql cache type of
database that azure offers so we're
going to learn one at a time or we're
going to learn one by one so this azure
sql database is a relational database in
fact it's a regional database as a
service it's managed by azure we don't
get to do a lot of management in it so
it's a regional database as a service
based on microsoft
sql server database engine and this
database is a high performance database
it's very reliable and
it's very secure as well and this high
reliability high performance and for
this high security really don't have to
do anything it comes along with it and
it's managed by azure and there are two
things that i definitely need to mention
about azure sql database that is it's an
intelligent service number one it's
fully managed by azure and it also has
this one good thing which is it has
built-in intelligence that learns app
patterns and adapts to maximize
performance and reliability and data
protection of the application that's
something that's not found in
many of the other cloud providers that
i'm aware of so i thought i'll mention
it so it uses built-in intelligence to
learn about the user's database patterns
and helps improve performance and
protection and migration or importing
data is very easy when it comes to azure
sql database so it can be readily or
immediately
used for analytic reporting and
intelligent applications in azure as
next thing let's talk about azure
cosmodb now azure cosmodb is a database
service that is for no sql type and it's
it's created to provide low latency and
an application that scales dynamically
or that scales rapidly
now this azure cosmodb is an
a globally distributed service
and it's a multi-model
database this can be provisioned in a
click of a button that's all we got to
do if we need to provision and azure
cosmodb in the azure it helps with
scaling the database now we can
elastically and independently scale
throughput and storage across this
database
and in any of the azure geographic
regions it provides a good throughput it
provides good latency it provides good
availability and
it provides or
azure promises a comprehensive sla that
no other database can offer that's the
best part about cosmodb so this cosmodb
was built with a global distribution in
mind and it's built
with the horizontal scale in mind and
all this we can use by only paying for
what we have used and remember the
difference between azure cosmodb and the
sql database is that azure cosmodb
supports nosql whereas sql doesn't all
right few other things about azure
cosmodb is it allows users to use key
value graph column family and document
data it also gives users a number of ap
options like sql javascript mongodb and
and few others that you might want to
check the document at the time of
reading and the best part here is that
all that we mentioned we get to use only
by paying for the amount of storage and
throughput that are required and the
storage and the throughput can be
elastically scaled based on the
requirement of that r all right let's
talk about um that is cache discussion
about azure database won't be complete
without we talking about redis cache now
redis cache is a secure data cache it's
also called it's also sometimes called
as messaging broker that provides high
throughput and low latency access to
data for the applications now redis
cache is based on an a popular open
source caching product which is redis
sometimes called as that is cache now
what's the use case it's typically used
to cache uh to improve the performance
and scalability of a system that rely
heavily on backend data stores now
performance when we use zs cache is
improved by temporarily copying the
frequently accessed data to a fast
storage located very close to the
application now with redis cache this
fast storage is located in memory with
redis cache instead of being loaded from
the actual disk in the database itself
now this redis cache can also be used as
an in-memory data structure store not
only that it can be used as an
distributed non-relational database and
a message broker so there are variety of
use cases for this redis cache and by
using redis cache the application
performance is improved by taking
advantage of the low latency and the
high throughput performance that this
redis cache engine provides so to
summarize this redis cache when we use
redis cache data is stored in the memory
instead of the disk to ensure that there
is high throughput and low latency when
the application needs to read the data
it provides various levels of scaling
without any downtime or interference now
this redis cache is actually backed by
redux server and it supports
a string hashes linked list and various
other data structures now let's talk
about security and identity services now
identity management in specific is a
process of authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principles
and not only that identity management
involves controlling information about
those principal identities you might ask
now what's a principle identity now
identity or principle identity are
services applications users groups and a
lot more the speciality about this
identity management is that it not only
helps authenticate and authorize
principles in cloud it also helps
authenticate and authorize principles or
resources on premises especially when
you run an hybrid cloud environment so
all these services and features that
this identity management helps us to get
additional level of validation like
identity management can provide
multi-factor authentication it can
provide access policies based on
condition a permit or deny based on
condition it can also monitor suspicious
activity and not only that it can also
report it it can also help generate
alerts for potential security issues and
in a way to mitigate it can send us an
alert so we can get involved and prevent
and a security accident from happening
so let's talk more about identity
management so some of the services under
security and identity management or
azure security center now this azure
security center provides
security management and threat
protection across the workloads in both
cloud and in the hybrid environment it
helps control user access and
application control to stop any
malicious activity if present it helps
us to find and fix vulnerabilities
before they can be even exploited it
integrates very well with analytic
methods that helps us to identify or it
gives us the intelligent to identify or
deduct attacks and prevent them before
it can actually happen and it also works
seamlessly with hybrid environments so
you don't have to have one policy for
on-premises and one policy for the cloud
it's now a unified service both for
on-premises and the cloud the next
service and security and identity would
be key vault now a key vault is a
service or a feature that helps
safeguard the cryptographic keys and any
other secrets used by the cloud
applications and the services in other
words this azure key vault is a tool for
securely storing and accessing the
secrets of the environment i mean the
secret keys now a secret is anything
that you really want to have a very
tight control access like the
certificates like the passwords stuff
like that now if i tell you what keyword
actually solves that would actually
explain what keyword is now key vault is
used in secrets management it's helped
in securely storing the tokens the
passwords the certificates it helps in
key management and it really helps in
creating and controlling the encryption
keys that we would use to encrypt data
it helps in certificate management
talking about certification management
it helps us to easily provision manage
and deploy public and private ssl tls
certificates in azure and lot more so in
a nutshell
this keyword it provides users the
ability to provision new walls and keys
in just a matter of minutes all that in
a single command or all that in a couple
of button clicks it also helps users to
centrally manage their keys secrets and
policies
next in the list let's talk about azure
active directory now azure active
directory it helps us to create
intelligent driven access policies to
limit resource usage and manage user
identities but what does that mean now
this azure active directory is a cloud
based active directory and identity
management service now azure active
directory combines and it's actually a
combination of the core directory
services plus application access
management plus identity protection
and one good thing about this azure in
fact there are a lot of good things but
especially when you're running hybrid
environments you might wonder well how
this azure active directory is going to
behave now this azure active directory
is built to work on on-premises and
cloud environment as well not only that
it also works seamlessly with mobile
applications as well
so in a nutshell this azure active
directory it acts as an central point of
identity and access management for our
cloud environment it also provides good
security solutions that protect against
unauthorized access of our app and the
data
now that we've discussed about security
and identity let's talk about the
management tools that azure has to offer
azure provides built-in management and
account governance tools that helps
administrators and developers that helps
them to keep the resources secure and
very compliant and again it helps both
in on premises and in the cloud
environment and these management tools
help us to monitor the infrastructure
monitor the applications it also helps
in provisioning and configuring
resources it also helps in updating apps
it helps in analyzing threats taking
backup of the resources build
disaster recoveries
it also helps in applying policies and
conditions to automate our environment
we use azure management tools and it's
also used in cost control methods so
this azure management plays a wide role
across the azure services
and in the management tools first comes
the azure advisor now this azure advisor
it acts as a guide to educate us about
azure best practices it throws
recommendations that we can select on
the basis of the category of service and
it also provides the impact it can have
or the impact that would happen in our
environment if we follow the
recommendations given and
recommendations are
first one is the recommendations are
kind of templatized and it throws the
templatized recommendations not only
that it also provides customized
recommendations on the basis of the
configuration on the basis of our usage
patents and these recommendations are
not hard it's not like something that it
recommends and then just leaves us
hanging there these recommendations
provided are very easy to follow very
easy to implement and see results you
can think of as your advisor as an a
very personalized cloud consultant that
helps you to follow best practices to
optimize
our deployments it kind of analyzes our
resources our configurations our usage
and then it recommends a solution for us
that really helps in improving the cost
effectiveness improving the performance
improving high availability and
improving security in our azure
environment so with this azure advisor
we can get a proactive
actionable and personalized best
practice recommendations now you don't
have to be an expert just follow the
azure advisor and your environment is
going to be good it also helps in
improve the performance security high
availability of our environment and also
it helps in bringing down the overall
azure spend and the best part is it's a
free service that analyzes our azure
usage and provides recommendations how
we can optimize our azure resource to
reduce cost and reduce cost at the same
time boost the performance helps in
strengthening the security and improve
the overall reliability of our
environment
next in the list would be network
watcher now this network watcher helps
users identify and gain insights in the
overall network performance and the
health of the overall environment now
these azure watchers provides enough
tools to monitor to diagnose to view the
metrics and to enable or disable logs
which means regenerate and collect the
logs for resources in the azure virtual
network so with network watcher can
monitor and diagnose issues in
networking without even logging into the
virtual machines with just the logs
which are real time we can actually come
to a conclusion what could be wrong in a
certain resource in a vm or in a
database you know by just looking at the
logs and not only that it's used for
analytic or to gain some intelligence of
what's happening in our network we can
gain a lot of insight to the current
network traffic pattern using the
security group flow logs that this
network watcher offers it also helps in
investigating vpn connectivity issues
using detailed logs now you might or
might not know that you know vpn
troubleshooting requires both parties or
it involves two parties another person
the network administrator on this side
and the network administrator on the
other side and they will have to check
logs in their end and we'll have to
check logs and hour and stuff like that
but with the network watcher it kind of
takes it to the next level the logs
itself we could easily identify which
side is having the issue and suggest an
appropriate fix
and the next in the list would be
microsoft azure portal now this
microsoft azure portal it provides a
single unified console to perform
various number of activities like
building not only building managing and
monitoring the web applications that we
build now this portal can be used to
organize our environment or the
appearance of the environment or the
visual of the environment based on our
work style and using azure portal users
can control who gets to manage or access
the resources all from the azure portal
and this iso portal gives a very good
visibility on the spends that happen on
each resource right and if we can
customize it we can also identify spends
based on team spends based on days
spends based on department stuff like
that so it kind of gives us a good
visual of
where the money is spending or where is
the bill consumed within the azure
environment
next in the list would be azure resource
manager now azure resource manager
enables us to manage
the usage of the application resources
now we use resource manager to deploy
monitor and manage solution resources as
a group as if it's one single entity now
the infrastructure of our application is
typically made of various components
which includes virtual machine storage
virtual network web app database servers
some other third-party services that we
might use in our environment and they
are by nature separate services but with
azure resource manager we don't see them
as different components or different
entities instead we see them as
related services in a group that
supports an application now we kind of
get the relation between them instead of
you know letting them spread azure
resource manager identifies the relation
between them and helps us to visually
see them all as one or single entity not
only that azure resource manager helps
or it ensures that the resources that we
provision are deployed at a constant
rate along with the other application
it also helps users to visually see
their resources and how they are
connected and that helps in managing the
resources lot better
resource group also is used to control
who can access the resources within the
users organization kind of gives you the
fine grained control over who gets to
access and who does not get access and
the last one in the management tools
would be automation and this automation
gives us the ability to automate
configure and install upgrades across
hybrid environments
it provides a cloud-based automation and
configuration service not only that this
can be applied for non-azure
environments as well which is
on-premises
so some of the automation we could do is
process automation update management
automation configuration features
automation stuff like that and this
azure automation provides complete
control during the deployment operation
and also during the decommissioning of
the workloads and resources
with automation we can actually automate
a time consuming or
mundane or any task that's error prone
because of human errors those things can
be automated so irrespective of how many
times you run it it's going to run the
same way and that really helps in
reducing the overall time and also the
overhead cost because a lot of the
things are automated which means it's
human error free which means the
application is not going to break and
keep running for a longer time with
automation we can actually build a good
inventory of operating system resources
and configuration items all in one place
with ease and this really helps in
tracking the changes and investigating
the issue let's say something happened
because we have automation because it's
logging the configuration changes it's
easy to track easy to identify easy to
identify what has changed lately that
has broken the environment go back and
fix it or kind of roll it back that
solves the problem and that actually
summarizes the azure management tools or
management services now let's talk about
the networking tools or the networking
services available in azure there are
variety of services especially
networking services that azure offers
and i'm sure it's going to be an
interesting one let's begin our
discussion with content delivery network
now the content delivery network in
short cdn it allows us to perform secure
and a very reliable content delivery not
only that it also helps in accelerating
the delivery time or in other words
reducing the delivery time also called
as low times it also helps in saving
bandwidth and increases in
responsiveness to the application let's
expand on this the content delivery
network is actually a distributed
network of servers that can efficiently
deliver web content to users now cdns
we're going to use the word cdn here
cdns store cached content on global edge
servers also called as
pops point of presence locations that
are very close to the end users so the
latency is minimized it's like taking a
copy of the data or taking a multiple
copy of the data and storing it in
different parts of the world and whoever
is requesting it the data gets delivered
to them from a server which is very
locally to them so this cdn offers
developers a global solution for rapidly
delivering high bandwidth content to
users by caching the content in a
strategically placed location which is
very near to them so these content
delivery networks it really helps in
handling that's one advantage you get
for content delivery network that's we
can handle spikes and heavy loads very
efficiently and we can also run analytic
against the logs that gets generated in
content delivery network which helps in
gaining good insight on the workflow and
what would be the future business need
for that application and this just like
a lot of other services this is on a pay
as you go type so you use the results
first and then you only pay for what you
have used
the next one in networking would be
express route now express route is
actually a circuit or a link that
provides an a direct private connection
to azure and because it's direct it
gives low latency link to azure it gives
good speed and reliability for the azure
data transfer it could be on premises to
azure so it gives very good speed it
gives increased reliability and low
latency for that connection let's expand
on this a bit and now this express route
is an service that actually provides and
private connection between microsoft
data center and infrastructure in our
premises or in a different colocation
facility that we might have now these
express routes do not go over the public
internet and because they don't go over
the public internet they offer a high
security reliability and speed and low
latency compared to the connections
which are in the internet because it's
fast because it's reliable because it
has low latency it can be used as an
extension of our existing data center
you know users are not going to feel the
difference whether they are accessing
services from an on-premises or in the
cloud environment because latency is
minimized as much as possible users are
really not going to see the difference
and because it's a private line and not
an public internet line it can be used
to build hybrid applications without
compromising a privacy or the
performance now these virtual private
cloud these express routes can be used
for taking backups if assume a backup
going through the internet that would be
a nightmare if you use express route for
backups that's going to be fast and
imagine recovering a data through the
internet from the cloud through the
internet to the on premises in a time of
disaster that would be the worst
nightmare so these express routes can be
used not only to backup but also to
recover the data because it provides
good speed low latency recovering the
data is going to be a lot sooner the
next product or service we're going to
discuss in networking is azure dns
now azure dns allows us to host domain
name in azure and these domain names
come with an exceptional performance and
availability now azure dns is used to
set up and manage dns zones and records
for our domain name in the cloud now
this azure dns is a service for dns just
like the name says and it provides name
resolution by using azure's
infrastructure and by using this domain
we can actually manage the dns ourselves
through the azure portal with the same
credential imagine having a dns provider
which does not even belong in rit
imagine that environment you know we
would have a separate portal to manage
the dns environment now those are gone
and now we can actually manage the dns
in the very same azure portal where we
use the rest of the other services and
this azure dns very much integrates with
other dns service providers it uses a
global network of name servers to
provide fast response to dns queries
and these domains are having additional
availability compared to the other
domain service providers availability
promises these are going to have more
availability than the rest because most
of the servers are maintained by a
microsoft and it helps resolve sooner it
helps re-syncing let's say a server
fails it kind of helps re-syncing with
the rest of the servers so all the
microsoft's environment all the
microsoft global network of name servers
kind of ensures that our domain names
are resolved properly not only properly
but also are available most of the time
all right next in the list in networking
services is virtual network i'm sure
this is going to be very interesting and
i'm sure you're going to like it so this
networking or virtual networking in
azure it actually allows us to set up
our own private cloud in the public
cloud it gives us an isolated and highly
secure environment
for our application let's expand on this
so this azure virtual network helps us
to provision azure virtual machines and
it helps us to securely communicate with
other on-premises and internet networks
it also helps in controlling the traffic
that flows through or flows in and out
of this virtual network to other virtual
networks and to the internet now this
azure a virtual network sometimes called
as v-net is actually a representation of
our own network in the cloud it's
actually a logical isolation of the
azure cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments are
provisioned in a v-net that is separate
from another customer's units that way
we have that logical separation there so
this virtual network can also be used to
provision a vpns in the cloud so we can
connect the cloud and the on-premises
infrastructure and lot more especially
in a environment where we have hybrid
environment surely we will be using
virtual network because that's going to
require a vpn for secure data transfer
in and out of the cloud and in and out
of the on-premises environment
all right so it kind of gives us an
boundary for all the resources so all
the traffic between the azure resources
they kind of logically stay in between
or logically stay within the azure
virtual network and here we can design
the network it's given over to us you
know you can pick the ip you can pick
the routing you can pick the subnet and
a lot of freedom is given or i would say
a lot of control on how the network is
designed it's not like something that's
already cooked and we only get to use it
now we can actually build the network
from the scratch we can pick the ip
address that we like we can pick you
know which subnet needs to communicate
with the other subnet stuff like that
and like i said if you are using hybrid
environment you definitely would be
requiring a virtual network because it
helps connect the on-premises and the
cloud in a secure fashion using vpn the
last product we're going to discuss in
networking is a load balancer this load
balancer actually provides application a
good availability and a good network
performance so how does it work it
actually works by load balancing the
traffic to and from the virtual machine
and the cloud resources not only that it
also load balances between cloud and
across premises virtual networks with
azure load balancer we can actually
scale our application and create high
availability for our services which
means our application will be available
most of the time if any of the server
goes dead the server does not get
traffic what happens if the server gets
traffic user is going to experience
downtime what happens if the server does
not get traffic user won't experience
any downtime the connection is shifted
to an healthy service so the user
experiences uptime all the time so this
load balancer supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency it gives high throughput of the
data transfer and we can actually scale
up the flow of the tcp and udp
connections from hundreds to thousands
to even millions because we have a load
balancer now in between the user and the
application so how does it operate this
load balancer actually receives the
traffic and it load balances the traffic
to the backend pool of instances
connected to it according to the rule
and the health probe that we set that's
how it maintains high availability so
what does load balancer help it helps in
creation of high available scalable
application in the cloud in minutes it
can be used to automatically scale the
environment with the increasing
application traffic and one feature of
load balancer is to check the health of
the user's application instance and it
removes or it stops sending the request
to the unhealthy instance and kind of
shifts that connection to the healthy
instance that way a user or a connection
does not get stuck with an instance
that's not healthy that's all that you
need to know about the networking
services now let's talk about the
storage services or the storage domain
in azure now azure storage in general is
a microsoft manage service providing
cloud storage which basically is highly
available secure durable scalable and
redundant because it's all managed by
azure we don't get to manage a lot of it
and these azure storages are a group of
storage services they cater different
needs and the storage products include
azure blobs which is actually an object
storage it includes
azure data lake it includes azure files
as you see it in it includes azure
queues it includes azure tables and lot
more but let's start our discussion with
azure store simple azure store simple is
an hybrid cloud storage solution that
actually lowers the cost of storage to
nearly 60 percent of how much you'd be
actually spending without using it so
azure simple storage or store simple is
an integrated storage solution that
manages the storage task between
on-premises and the cloud storage what i
really like about azure is that it's
built around a hybrid environment in
mind there are a lot of other cloud
providers that are there where running
and hybrid environment is a big
challenge you know it has some
compatibility you won't be able to find
an hybrid or a on-premises and cloud
solution for your need stuff like that
but with the azure especially when it
comes to storage a lot of the things
that we're gonna see it clearly is
designed with hybrid environment in mind
all right so let's come back and talk
about store simple so store simple is an
very efficient cost effective and a very
easily manageable san storage area
networking solution in the cloud i
thought i'll throw in this information
the reason why it got store simple is
really because it uses store simple 8000
series devices which are used in azure
data center and this stores simple or
simple storage it comes along with
storage steering to manage the stored
data across the various storage media so
the current the very current data is
actually stored in on-premises on
solid-state drives and data that is used
less frequently is stored in a hdds or
hard disk drives and the data that
requires archived or that needs to be
archived very old data let's say less
frequently used data candidate for
archive they are actually pushed to the
cloud so you see how this storage
steering automatically happens in store
simple and one another cool feature of
store simple is that it enables us to
create an on-demand and scheduled
backups of data and and then store the
data locally or in the cloud and these
backups are actually taken in the form
of incremental snapshot which means that
they can be created and restored quickly
it's not a complete backup it's an
incremental backup and these cloud
snapshots they can be critically
important when there is a disaster and
when there is a disaster recovery
scenario because these snapshots can be
called in and they can be put on storage
systems and then they become the actual
data so recovering is faster if you have
proper scheduled backups or if you have
frequent backups and this storage simple
it really helps in easing our backup
mechanism which means it kind of eases
our disaster recovery steps or
procedures as well so this store simple
it can be used to automate data
management data migration data movement
data tiering across the enterprise both
in cloud and on-premises it actually
improves the compliance and accelerates
the disaster recovery for our
environment and if there is one thing
that's increasing every new day in our
environment that would be storage and
this store simple addresses that need
and we really don't have to pre-plan or
think in deep or having a proper storage
because now we have a simple storage
available in the cloud and moreover it's
on a pay-as-you-go type so not much
pre-planning on storage is needed yes
there will be a need but not as much as
i would without the cloud or without the
simple storage and the next service
under storage that we would like to
discuss is the data lake store this data
lake store or storage it's a cost
effective solution for big data
analytics in specific so let's expand
this so this data lake storage is an
enterprise-wide repository for big data
analytic workload now that's the major
service that's dependent on this data
lake store and this data lake enables us
to capture data of any size of any type
and of any injection speed and it kind
of collects them in one single space or
in one single place for operational
efficiency i mean operational efficiency
and for analytic purpose hadoop in azure
is very dependent on this data lake
storage and this
data lake store is designed with
performance for analytics in mind so
anytime you think of or any time you're
using analytic in the cloud or anytime
you're using hadoop in the cloud in
azure we are definitely using or we will
be to the most part or the normal
procedure or the right storage to pick
would be data lake store in azure it's
designed with security in mind so
anytime we use azure storage we can be
rest assured that we are using storage
from within a data center which has or
which was built with security in mind so
this data store also uses azure blob
storage behind the scenes for global
scale durability and for performance
let's talk about blob storage now blob
storage provides large amount of storage
and scalability now this blob storage is
the object storage solution for azure
cloud let's expand a bit on blob storage
azure blob storage is microsoft offering
for object storage now this blob storage
is optimized for storing massive amount
of unstructured data which could be text
or binary data it's designed and it's
optimized for rapid reads if i explain
to you on what scenarios we would be
using blob storage that might help you
get a good understanding of what blob
storage is so it's help or its design as
of now it's being used in many idea
environments to serve images or
documents directly to the browser it
helps in storing files for distributed
access a lot of fetchers can fetch data
from azure blob storage and it currently
helping users stream video and audio
it's currently being used for writing
log files it's currently being used to
store data as backup and restore at a
later point in times of disaster
recovery it also is used as an archiving
storage in a lot of cloud id
environments it's widely used in storing
analytic data not only storing but also
running analytic query against the data
stored in it so that's a wide use case
for blob storage not only that in
addition to all that we mentioned it
also supports versioning so anytime
somebody updates and data a new version
gets created which means at any point i
can roll back as in when needed and it
provides a lot of flexibility on
optimizing the user's storage need it
also supports tiering of the data so
based on need when i actually explore i
would find a lot of options i can pick
from that uh you know suits to my unique
storage environment or unique storage
need and like i said it stores
unstructured data and this unstructured
data is available for customers through
rest based object storage environment
the next product and storage service
would be a queue storage now queue
storage provides durable cues for large
volume cloud services it's a very simple
and a cost effective durable messaging
queue for large workers let's expand
this queue storage for a moment now this
q storage is a service for storing large
amount of messages that can be accessed
from anywhere in the world through http
and https calls a single queue or a
single cube message can be up to like 24
kb in size and a single queue can
contain millions of such 24 kb in size
messages and how much can it hold it can
hold up to the total capacity of the
storage account itself so that's kind of
easy to translate how much would it hold
and this azure queue storage it provides
an messaging solution between
applications and components in the cloud
what does it help it helps in designing
an application for scale it helps in
decoupling the application so you know
it's not very dependent or sometimes
it's not at all dependent on the other
application because now we have a queue
in between which kind of translates or
which kind of connects or which kind of
decouples both the environment now we
have a queue in between both the
environment can scale up or scale down
independently the next in the storage
service would be file storage let's talk
about file storage now these azure files
provide secure simple and managed cloud
file shares now with file share in the
cloud it actually extends the user
servers on premises performance and
capacity and a lot of familiar tools for
the cloud file share management can be
used along with the file storage that
we're talking about so let's expand a
bit on file storage now this azure files
or azure file storage offers a fully
managed file shares in the cloud that
can be accessed via the
smb protocol server message block
protocol now this azure file shares can
be mounted concurrently by cloud or in
on-premises deployments a lot of
operating systems are compatible with it
windows are compatible linux is
compatible mac os is compatible in
addition to all this being able to run
on on premises and on the cloud or being
able to access from on premises and on
the cloud it can also offer cash for
caching the data and keeping it locally
so it's immediately available when
needed so that's some additional feature
i would say that some advanced feature
that it offers compared to the other
file shares available in the market
let's talk about table storage let's
talk about table storage now table
storage is a no sequel key value pair
storage for quick deployments with the
large semi-structured data sets the
difference between one important thing
to note with table storage is that it
has a flexible data schema and also it's
highly available let's expand a bit on
table storage so anytime you want to
pick a schema less a nosql type table
storage is the one we'll end up picking
it provides an key pair attribute
storage with a schema-less design this
table storage is very fast and very cost
effective for many of the applications
and for the same amount of
data it's a lot cheaper when you compare
it with the traditional sql data or data
storage so some of the things that we
can store in the table storage are of
course they're going to be flexible data
sheets such as user data for web
application address books device
information and other types of metadata
for our service requirements and it can
have any number of tables up to the
capacity limit of the storage account
now this is not possible with sql this
is only possible with nosql especially
with table storage in azure explanation
of storage really concluded the length
and breadth of the explanation this ceo
was giving his id personal but this id
personal is not done with it yet he
still has a question even after this
lengthy discussion and his question was
well there are a lot of other cloud
providers available what made you
specifically choose azure i mean from
the kind of question that he asked we
can say that he is very curious and uh
he definitely had asked and very
thoughtful question so his ceo went on
and started to explain about the other
capabilities of azure or how it
kind of outruns the rest of the cloud
providers so he started or he again
started his discussion but from a
different angle now so he started to
explain what are the capabilities or how
azure is better than the competitors so
he started with explaining the platform
as a service capabilities and i'm going
to tell you what the ceo told his id
person so this platform as a service or
in platform as a service the
infrastructure management is completely
taken care by
microsoft allowing users to focus
completely on the innovation no more
infrastructure management
responsibilities go and focus on
innovation that's that's a fancy way of
saying it when we buy platform as a
service that's what we get we can
contribute our time on innovation and
not just maintaining the infrastructure
and azure especially is dotnet friendly
azure supports the.net programming
language and it has or it is built or
designed or it is optimized to work with
old and the new applications deployed
using net programming framework so if
your application is a.net most of the
time you would end up picking azure i
mean if you try to compare most of the
time you would end up picking azure as
your cloud service provider and the
security offerings that azure offers is
it's designed based on the security
development uh life cycle which is an
industry leading assurance process when
we buy services from azure it assures
that the environment is designed based
on security development life cycle and
like i mentioned many times in the past
and i would like to mention it again
azure has well thought about the hybrid
environments which a lot of other cloud
providers have failed so it's very easy
to set up and hybrid environment to
migrate the data or not to migrate the
data and still run a hybrid environment
they work seamlessly with
azure because azure provides seamless
connection across on-premises data
centers and the public cloud it also has
a very gentle
learning curve if you look at the
documentation it's picture rich and the
documentations are neat and clear would
really it would encourage you to learn
more it would encourage you to think and
imagine and try easily get a grasp of
how services work so it has a very
gentle learning curve azure allows the
utilization of technologies that several
businesses have used for years so there
is a big history behind it it has a very
gentle learning curve the certifications
the documentations the stage by stage
certification levels it's all very
gentle learning curve which is generally
missing in other cloud service providers
now this would really impress the ctos
or people working in finance and
budgeting if an organization is already
using microsoft software they can
definitely go and avail or be bold and
ask for a discount that can reduce the
overall azure spending in other words
overall a pricing of the azure so that's
what helped or they are the information
that helped the ceo pick azure as his
cloud service provider and then the ceo
goes on and talks about the different
companies that are currently using azure
and they are definitely using azure for
a reason like pixar boeing samsung
easyjet xerox bmw 3m they are major
multinational multi-billion companies
they rely
run operate their i.t in azure and this
ceo has a thought that his i.t person is
still not very convinced unless and
until he shows him a visual of how easy
things are in azure so he goes on and
explains about a practical application
of azure which is what exactly i'm going
to show you as well all right a quick
project on building an azure app using
or building a dotnet application in
azure web app and making it connect to
an sql database will solidify all the
knowledge that we have gained so far so
this is what we're gonna do i have an
azure account open as you see logged in
and everything is fresh here let me go
to resource group there's nothing in
there it's it's kind of fresh right i'm
logged in and this is what we're going
to do so we're going to create an
application like this which is nothing
but an to-do application
to do list application we're just going
to run from the web app get information
from us and save it in the database
that's connected to it so you can
already see it's a two-tiered
application web and db all right so let
me go back to my azure account the first
thing is to create an resource group
let's give it an a meaningful name let's
call it azure simply learn alright and
it's going to be a free trial and the
location
pick one that's nearest to you or you
know wherever you want to launch your
application now for this use case i'm
going to pick central us and create
it's going to take a while to get
created there you go it's created it's
called azure simply learn now
what do we need we need an web app and
and a separate sql database let's first
get our web app running so go to app
services and then click on add
it's not the web app plus sql that we
want we want web app alone for this
example so let's create and web app
uh give it a quick name let's call it
azure
simply learn
the subscription is free trial and i'm
going to use my existing resource group
a resource group that we created some
time back it's going to run out of
windows and we're going to publish
the code all set we can create it all
right while this is running
let me create my
database
right sql database
create a database
give it a name let's call it azure
simply learn db
put it in our existing resource group
that we created it's going to be a blank
database all right and it's going to
require some
settings like
the name of the server
and the admin login the password that
goes along and in which location this is
going to be created the server
click on create so what have we done so
far we have created a web app and we
have created an uh a database in
the resource group that we have created
so if i go to resource group it's going
to take some time before things show up
so if i go to my resource group i only
have one results group as of now
azure simply learn and there i have a
bunch of resources
being created and that's still being
created right in the meantime
i have my application right here that's
running out of
or that's in visual studio as of now
right so once
the infrastructure is set and ready
in the azure console we're gonna go back
to visual studio
feed these inputs
in the visual studio so the code knows
what the database is the the credentials
to log into the database and stuff like
that so we're going to feed those
information in visual studio by that
we're actually feeding it into the
application and then we're going to run
it from there
deploying this application takes quite a
while
we really got to be patient right now we
have all the resources that we need for
the application to run here is my
database and here is my app service
there's one more thing we need to do
that is
create and firewall exception rule so
one more thing needed is to create and
firewall exception
rule right so the application is going
to run from my local desktop and it's
going to connect to the
database right so let's add an exception
rule by simply adding the client id it's
going to pick my ip the ipf laptop i'm
using as of now and it's going to create
an exception to access the
database so that's done now we can go
back to our visual studio i already have
a couple of
apps running or a couple of
configurations pushed from
visual studio i'm going to clean that up
if you're doing it for the first time
you you may not need to do this
all right so let's start from the
scratch
this is very similar to
how you would be doing
in your environment right so we're gonna
select an existing azure app service now
before that i have logged in as you can
see i have logged in
with my credentials so it's going to
pull few things automatically from my
azure account so
in this case i'm going to use an
existing azure app so select existing
and then click on publish
all right if you recall these are the
very
same resources that we created a while
back
all right we have clicked on save and
it's
running kind of validating the code
and it's going to come up with an url
now initially the url is
not going to work because we haven't
mapped the application to the database
so that would be the next thing
all right so the app has been
published and it's running from my
web app as of now
it's going to throw an error
like you see
it's throwing an error that's because we
haven't mapped
the app and the db together so let's do
that
all right let's do that so let's go to
server explorer
this is where
we're going to see our
databases that we have created now let's
quickly verify that
go back to
the resource group
right appropriate to service group
which is right here
and here i have my
database azure
simply learn database
all right it has some issues connecting
uh to my database give me a quick moment
let's fix it
all right so
we'll have to map
the database into this application
all right so let's go to the solution
explorer click on
publish
and a page like this gets shown and from
here we can go to configure
here is our a web app all right with all
its credentials let's validate the
connection number one
all right and then click on next
this is my db connection string right
which the app is going to use to connect
to my db
now if you recall rdb was a
azure simply learn db and that's not
being shown here
so let's fix that
right so let's fix that
click on configure
and here
let's put our db servers uh url now
before that let's change this to sql
server
all right and then in here
put the
db's
url so go back to azure
here is my
db or
server's name
put that here
right
the username to connect to the server
that's
right here
put that in
and the password
to connect to the server let's put that
in
all right it's trying to connect
to our azure
portal or the azure infrastructure and
here is my
database if you recall it's azure
sldb that's the name of the database
let's test the connection
connection is good click on ok
so now it's showing up correctly azure
simply learn db that's the name of the
database
that'll be created
now it's configured
all right let's modify the data
connections
let's map it to the appropriate database
again
all right so our name of the database is
azure simply learn db
and then
it's going to be
sql
server that's the data source
the
username is simply learn
and the password is
what
we have given in the beginning
all right let's validate
the connection it's good click ok
now we're all set
and ready to publish our application
again now the application knows how to
connect uh to the database we have
educated it with the
the correct connection strings the dns
name
the username and the password for the
application to connect to the database
so visual studio is building this
project and once it is up and running
will be prompted with an url
to connect and anytime
we put or we give inputs to the url
that's going to
receive the input and save it in the
database
all right so here is my to-do list app
and i can start
creating to-do list for
myself all right so i have items already
listed
i can create an entry and these entries
get stored in
the
in the database i can create another
entry you know take the dog for a walk
that's going to get stored i can create
another entry
uh book tickets for
scientific
exhibition
and that's going to receive and put that
in the database and that concludes our
session so through this session we saw
how i can use azure services to create a
web app and
connect that to the db instance and how
those two services which are
decoupled by default which are separate
by default how i can you know use the
connection strings to make connection
between the app server and the database
and be able to create and working app i
strongly believe you enjoyed me walking
you through this session so in this
video here's what we're going to talk
about first we'll talk about what is
cloud computing what is microsoft azure
what are the services that are your
offers and then we'll have a look at a
use case where we'll be applying one of
these services to get a particular job
done now for the first question what is
cloud computing so cloud computing
actually provides a platform through
which you can access resources now these
resources include servers storage
application security and other ways you
can transform your data or get some use
out of it now at the same time you can
also store manage and process your data
now anything related to cloud computing
is made possible only with the help of
the internet now along with these things
there are several other things that you
can do with cloud computing now let's
have a look at some of the ways cloud
computing is making our lives better
firstly you have services for just about
every requirement that you have then you
get access to the newest and most
innovative technologies in the market
right now cloud computing provides
cost-effective solutions with flexible
pricing now most cloud service providers
work in such a way that you only pay for
the amount of time you use that
particular resource then you have one of
the most important selling points when
it comes to cloud computing which is
that data and applications are
accessible from any part of the world as
long as you have access to the internet
and finally you have increased
protection for your data and
applications now you should know that
there are several cloud service
providers in the market right now be it
amazon web services adobe creative cloud
google cloud platform and so much more
now among all these platforms there's
one that's growing really really fast
and that is microsoft azure now let's
ask the question what is microsoft azure
microsoft azure is actually a cloud
service platform that allows users to
build manage scale and deploy
applications by giving them access to
cloud services now these cloud services
range from creating virtual machines to
creating functions that run themselves
without having to worry about hardware
now all of this is made possible only
through the internet now here are some
things that you need to know about azure
firstly it was launched on the 1st of
february 2010 it has data centers in
more than 42 regions across the world
they also say that 12 more data centers
are in the making which helps them say
they're the only cloud service provider
that covers these many regions next
azure is preferred by 80 of the fortune
500 companies which means that the best
of the best in the market only choose to
work with azure and finally azure is the
second largest cloud service provider in
the market right now let's talk about
azure services as i told you azure
provides services for a wide range of
domains now let's have a look at some of
these domains there's ai and machine
learning compute containers database
identity management tools networking
security storage and so much more now
let's have a look at some of the
individual services within these domains
firstly you have azure virtual machines
with azure virtual machines what you get
is the opportunity to create windows or
linux virtual machines now all of this
is possible in a matter of seconds with
a large amount of customization now
let's have a look at some of its
features firstly you can choose from a
wide variety of virtual machine options
then you have a large amount of
optimization available to you for
example what size of operating system do
you want how much size do you want
allocated to it what version of the
system is it and so much more then it
provides low cost and permanent billing
now azure provides you permanent billing
which means that you're only charged for
how much time you use the service and
finally you have enhanced security and
protection for your virtual machines
next we have service fabric now with
service fabric you have platform which
enables you to create micro services now
this also makes the process of
application lifecycle management a whole
lot easier as a direct result you can
create applications with a faster time
to market it supports windows linux
on-premises or other clouds and it
enables you to do a tremendous amount of
scaling up depending on your requirement
and finally we have functions now with
functions you can build applications
with the help of serverless computing
here the users only pay for the amount
of resources that they've used you can
create applications in any language that
you want and the only thing you need to
worry about is the code of the
application everything other than that
that is the hardware requirements are
taken care of by azure now let's have a
look at the networking services firstly
we have the azure cdn or the content
delivery network with azure cdn what you
get is the ability to deliver your
content with reduced load times fast
responsiveness and less bandwidth now
cdn can be integrated with several other
azure services so that the process can
move at a faster rate it can handle
heavy loads and traffic spikes with ease
it also provides a robust security
system now with the content that's
delivered you can get advanced analytic
data with which you can understand how
customers are using your content next we
have express route with express route
you can connect your on-premises network
to azure through a private network now
by default this lowers latency it
increases the emphasis on reliability
and speed and it can be of great use
when you have to transfer large amounts
of data between networks now another way
this can be useful is if it's used to
add compute or storage capacity to data
centers next we have azure dns domain
name service or azure dns can be used to
host your domains on azure this provides
high availability and great performance
it provides fast responses to dns
queries by taking advantage of
microsoft's global network it also
provides high availability next we have
virtual network azure virtual network
allows the azure resources to
communicate with each other or other
on-premise networks via the internet and
all of this is kept extremely secure
now with this users can create their own
private network for communication it
provides users with an isolated and
extremely secure environment for their
applications to run now all of the
traffic stays entirely within the azure
network and it also allows users to
design their own networks
next we have traffic manager now with
traffic manager you can route incoming
traffic to improve your performance and
availability now one thing it provides
is multiple failover options so if a
particular situation goes wrong there's
always an option to consider to salvage
the situation it helps reduce
application run time and enables the
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations it also helps the
people who are using it to know where
the customers connecting from across the
world next we have load balancer with
this you are provided the ability to
instantly scale applications at the same
time providing high availability and
improved network performance for users
applications it can be integrated into
virtual machines and cloud services it
provides highly reliable applications it
also allows users to secure and
integrate security groups finally we
have azure vpn gateway now this allows
users to connect their on-premise
networks to azure using a site-to-site
vpn now this allows users to connect
their virtual machine to anywhere in the
world through a point-to-site vpn and
also it's very easy to manage and is
highly available
now let's talk about the storage
services first we have data lake storage
now with this what you get is a scalable
data storage with an emphasis on cost
effectiveness and scalability now it
comes of maximum use when you integrate
it with other services so that you can
get analytics on how the data is being
used it is also integrated with other
services like the azure blob storage now
it is also optimized for big data
analysis tools like battery spark and
hadoop next up we have blob storage now
blob storage provides a storage capacity
for data now depending on how often a
particular data is used it is classified
into different tiers now all the data
that is within the blob storage is
unstructured data now it has a way of
ensuring that the data integrity is
maintained every time a particular
object is being changed or the data is
being accessed and it also helps improve
app performance and reduces bandwidth
consumption
next we have queue storage now with this
you have a message queuing system for
large workloads this allows users to
build flexible applications and separate
functions not to mention with this you
can be sure that your individual
components will not fail it also makes
sure that your application is scalable
queue storage provides queue monitoring
which helps ensure that the customer's
demands are met then we have file stored
now with file storage you can perform
file sharing with the help of the smb
protocol or the server message block
protocol now this data is protected by
smb 3.0 and the https protocol in this
case like we mentioned in functions
azure takes care of all the hardware
needs and the operating system
deployments on its own it also improves
on-premises performance and other
capabilities lastly we have table
storage with table storage you can
deploy semi-structured data sets and
nosql key value store now this is used
for creating applications which have a
flexible data schema and also
considering how it has a very strong
consistency model it's mainly aimed for
enterprises next let's have a look at
some web and mobile services
first we have the azure search now with
azure search you get a cloud search
service which is powered by artificial
intelligence with this you can develop
web applications as well as mobile
applications now one big advantage is
that you don't have to set up or manage
your search indices azure takes care of
that and by extension it increases your
development speed the artificial
intelligence also will provide insights
and structured information that you can
use to improve the search and structured
information next we have logic apps now
with this you can create integration
solutions which can connect applications
that are important to your business now
with this you can visually create
business processes and workflows you can
integrate sas or software as a service
applications and enterprise applications
and more importantly it allows you to
unlock data within a firewall and
securely connect to services next we
have web applications now with web apps
you can create deploy and scale web
applications according to business
requirements now it supports both
windows and linux platforms and it helps
with continuous integration or
deployment abilities another very
important aspect of this is that the
data can be deployed and hosted across
multiple locations in the world and
finally we have mobile apps with mobile
apps you can create applications for ios
android and windows platforms one
advantage is that it automatically
scales up and down based on your
requirements now in situations where you
have network issues offline data syncing
ensures that your applications work
anyway and you can create cross-platform
applications or native applications for
ios android and windows
next let's have a look at some container
services first let's talk about acs or
azure container services it is also
known as the azure kubernetes services
as it's a fully managed kubernetes
container orchestration service now what
this means is that it eases the process
of container integration and deployment
it also can be used with other resources
from security like virtual networks
cryptographic keys and so much more to
ensure that your container is kept
secure next we have container instances
now this is similar to functions in a
way just that in this we're using
containers without having to manage
servers now applications can be
developed here without managing virtual
machines or learning new tools all that
is azure's problem to take care of and
it enables building applications without
having to manage the infrastructure that
is all you need to worry about is
running the container next let's have a
look at some database services first we
have the sql database now with sql
database what you get is a relational
cloud database service now this means
that it helps accelerate your app
development and makes it easier for you
to maintain your application now sql
database is also used extensively in
migrating workloads to the cloud and
hence saves time and cost it also helps
improve your performance by integrating
machine learning and adaptive
technologies into your database next we
have azure cosmos db now this is a
globally distributed multi-model
database service now what this means is
that with this you can create
application with support nosql
it provides a high grade security system
has high availability and low latency
now this is usually used in situations
where you have a diverse and highly
unpredictable workload now let's have a
look at some security and identity
services firstly we have the azure
active directory now if you want to know
more about azure active directory i
suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch our video on the azure
active directory this is just an
introduction so with this you can manage
user identities and you can make sure
the resources are kept safe with the
help of access policies most of these
are intelligence driven now one of the
main features is that you can have
access to your applications from any
location or device
it helps increase your efficiency and
helps down cutting costs when it comes
to having a help desk it can also help
improve security and can respond to
advanced threats in real time next you
have azure active directory b2c it helps
provide customer identity and access
management in the cloud now protecting
customer identity is extremely important
for an organization and that's what
azure adb2c does now it also enables the
application to be scaled to great
amounts even billions of customers next
we have the azure security center this
is basically like a command post with
which you get a complete view of the
security across users on your
on-premises and cloud workloads so with
this you are given threat protection
method that adapts to situations and
helps reduce exposing you to threats it
also has rapid threat response and makes
the process of finding and fixing
vulnerabilities a whole lot easier next
up let's talk about monitoring and
management services so first let's have
a look at azure advisor now azir advisor
is basically a guide for the best
practices when it comes to azure now
when you follow these it improves
performance security cost and increases
availability now it also learns from how
you use the services on your
configuration and usage pattern and the
adjustments that it suggests can be
implemented very quickly and easily next
we have network watcher now with this
you can monitor diagnose and understand
the working of your network now you can
monitor your network without actually
having to log in to your virtual machine
now you can also use something known as
network security flow logs to understand
the traffic pattern how much traffic is
coming towards you how much you're
giving and so much more it also helps
diagnose vpn problems that you might
have with detailed logs and finally you
have the azure resource manager now with
this you can ensure that the resources
that you have are managed and deployed
at a consistent rate now this makes it
extremely easy for you to manage and
visualize your resources that are used
in your applications or some other
requirement
and you can control who can access your
resources as well as perform actions on
it and now let's have a look at how we
can use one of these services to satisfy
a particular requirement so the friend
asks that she needs one last bit of help
she wants her friend's help to host the
website on his yaw and here's how we can
do it so now we're going to put one of
these services into action so this is
the azure dashboard so from here we are
going to create a virtual machine within
which we are going to create a website a
very simple html website nonetheless
so let's get started so first what we're
going to do is create a resource a
resource group so what a resource group
is is actually a repository of all the
resources like virtual machines or
storage that you're going to use in your
project so in this we need a virtual
machine so let's get that created so
first we'll name it
demo
east us and we'll create it now this
will take a few seconds
and that's it
so now that that's done we go on add
so we're going to be using a windows
operating system so we'll just search
for a virtual machine
we select this
and create
okay so here we're going to set up
we're going to select the resource group
the one just that we just created
a virtual machine name
okay
so
storage
name
passwords
and then
just breeze through the rest of it
we can
reduce the size we need this big
and create
now that the validation is done the next
step is to
create
now this will take a few minutes so
we'll wait
and as you can see here the virtual
machine has been created we'll go to the
source
so here all we need to do is connect and
download the rdp file
let's see if we run this file and see
what happens
now this error shows up in a whole lot
of systems that i've used
so there's a very easy way to
troubleshoot this problem so here's what
you need to do no so these are the
problems as remote access to the server
is not enabled the remote computer is
turned off the remote computer is not
available on the network
so what we're going to do is go to
networking
and add an inbound port rule now we're
trying to access a computer remotely
right so to remotely access the computer
we would need to add an inbound port
rule so that's what we're going to do
right now
so we can keep the source as any port
ranges any and our destination port has
3389 if you've noticed there we'd
actually have used the 3389 as the
inbound port
and then we change the name as 3389
and this rule is added
now after this is done all we need to do
you can see here that we refresh the
page this would be here
a new role has been added now so we'll
go to overview
and try to connect again
do the same thing again
and this time it worked so here we'll
input the name
and
our password
and that's it now we just press yes
and there you go the system has started
now your virtual machine is started now
in a while the server manager will pop
up
so there's some things that we need to
do so that we can host the website so
the first thing is to create an inbound
port so we'll turn off the virtual
machine for now
come back to that later first we'll go
to
a resource group
check the name of our resource
and then we'll look at all its resources
here
so here we need to find at the network
security group
and add an inbound security rule
press add we take any source any source
port range
and then we add port 80 which is the one
that we're going to use and we'll put
the name as port
80.
we'll add the security rule which will
take a few seconds
and that's that now it's a lot now let's
go back to our virtual machine
here you
go and let's get it started
login again
and there you have it it's on again now
we'll go to server manager so we need to
add roles and features
so most of this we can just run through
we leave them at the default values
same and here we need to add a web
server which is the iis so we'll select
this
we add the features
next so we can add the net 3.5 features
as well
next
and
we'll install now
now we'll wait for the installation to
finish
and now the installation is done so now
what we're going to see is if the
website can be reached i will go to the
public address which is given here so
we've come back to our original system
click
and you can see that the is page has
been created
now we need to work more to create the
html page
here's what we'll need to do to run our
website so right now what we're getting
is this the is page now let's make it
our own html page a very simple html
page from there on we can create the
website so go back to the virtual
machine and then we go to
c drive
so the is is located in a location which
is in c drive init pub
and www root so if you click on this
actually what you'll get is the page i
showed you earlier which is this one
so now we'll go to the server manager
click on tools
and find the iis manager
so we click on this
and sites
now there's a default website
we can now add a new one
site name
demo we need a physical path we'll put
it inside the
folder we just saw which is
right here c drive
unit pub
wwe root within which we'll create a new
folder
for simply learn demo
i save it
and put 80
and
okay
now this is assigned to another site so
we'll change that but we'll wait for
that okay
now for this we'll just change it
we'll click on this
so since both of them have the same port
we'll change that go here edit binding
we change this
to something else
okay and close
so now both are different and now we can
start our website
it's already started now
now we'll start the website right click
this
say manage website
and start
and that's it
now we will go to the
to the inner pub www root and we have
simply learn demo so here we will create
the
html website or the html
the document
so
index.html
okay
open this
it's a very simple website now so
we keep it save it
so here what we're going to do is save
as
an html file but for all
all files
we close this
now to make sure this is recognized as a
dot html file
it go to view
options
here we'll hide extensions for known
file types
just rename this
and there you have it it's a dot html
file
now let's go back
to our
original computer
and run this page
and there you have it now this is just
the initial version more work has to be
done on it but your first step is
already done we'll be talking about
machine learning in azure
before we move on let me tell you what
azure is so azure is microsoft public
cloud computing platform it provides you
with various services like compute
analytics networking and storage so you
can pick from these services to develop
and scale new applications or run
existing applications in the public
cloud
okay so once you log into your azure
portal and select machine learning as
your service you will be redirected to
this page now on the right hand side you
can see there's an option called my
workspace so once you click on my
workspace it will take you to a new
window which is machine learning studio
but before that let me give you a small
idea of what my workspace is so any data
that we get into our machine learning
studio we analyze it and that is
presented under my workspace now on the
left hand side you can see there are few
options under machine learning studio
page so let me go through those option
one so the first option is projects so
project basically gives you a list of
all the experiments that we have worked
on then comes experiments
so experiments are all the programs that
you work on to create a model after that
it's web services so since azure is a
cloud computing platform we know that
all the data needs to be uploaded over
the cloud by data i mean all the
experiments that we have needs to be
uploaded over the cloud
so web services gives you a list of all
the experiments that we have and is over
the cloud so that you can access it from
anywhere then comes notebooks so
notebooks are basically space where you
can explore analytics you can create
your own code you can visualize it and
at the last you can share it with your
peers then it's data sets so the data
set gives you a list of all the data set
that you have in your azure portal now
when you click on sample these are all
the sample data set that azure has
provided as to the users
now comes train models so while working
in an experiment you'll come to a point
where you need to train your model so
this gives you a list of all the models
that you have trained in your azure
program
then at the last you have settings so
any changes that you make is done under
settings so now that we are done with
this let's go to the next half of our
azure tutorial so on the left hand side
you can see there's an option called new
when you click on new it will open a
window so this window gives you a list
of all the templates that we have in our
azure machine learning studio okay so
since we are working from the scratch we
will be working on blank experiment so
once you click on blank experiment a new
window appears
okay so let me go through the component
that we have here so on the left hand
side you have the components at the
center you have the canvas where your
experiments will take place and on the
right hand side you have properties so
today we'll be working on problem
statement which says that we need to
find out the income of an individual
whose data we don't have in our system
now let's go on to the component part
and find the best data set that can suit
our problem statement okay so we see
that we have list of data sets in our
samples so the very first data set it
adopts senses income binary
classification so we've selected dataset
and drag it over to the canvas
but before that let me give a name to
our experiment so we'll give the name as
income prediction
now once you click on adult census
income you can see there is a circle
press right click and four options
appears in front of you the first one is
download the second is visualize third
is generate access code and the last one
is notebook since we need to visualize
the data set we will click on visualize
so once you click on visualize a new
window appears
on the left hand side you can see there
are 32 000 nodes and 15 columns that we
have in our data set but before that let
me go through all the columns that we
have here so the first one is age which
gives you a which tells about the age of
a person
then is work class so this gives you an
idea whether he's a government employee
is he working in a private sector or is
he a self-employed then is fnlwgt which
is the sample weight of the field then
is the education so education is
basically telling us about his highest
degree whether is it bachelors is it
high school grad or is he a masters
then comes education number so this
gives you an idea of the number of years
he took to complete his education then
his marital status so this is telling
about a person's is he married or
whether he has never married then his
occupation so occupation is actually
important while finding out the income
so if a person is a manager there a
chance he will be earning more as
compared to others then his relationship
whether he is a husband is she a wife or
has he never married then comes sex
whether he is a male or the female then
his capital gain capital loss hours per
week so this gives you an idea of number
of hours a person is working in a week
then is native country so income varies
from country to country so getting to
know about the country is also very
important while predicting our model and
at the last we have income we see that
the income column is divided into two
halves which is above 50 and below 50.
so there are two distinct values in
income group and in cases like these we
make use of classification algorithm now
let's go to the next part which is where
we will define the fields that we need
to have for our prediction so what we do
here is we select the column
so on the search bar when you type
column under manipulation you get a list
of options from that you select column
in dataset and drag it over to the
canvas now connect your data set with
select column in dataset now under this
you can see there's a caution which says
that value required so you go under
properties and select launch column
selector so once you select launch
column selector window appears
so this gives you a list of all the
columns that we have in a data set
so the very first column that we have
here is age so age is actually important
in understanding the income of a person
then comes work class so the background
of a person whether he's working in a
government employee or is he a private
employee is also important for
prediction of income then comes
education
a person who has a master's degree has
more chances of earning than a person
who has a graduation degree so education
is also an important field while
predicting our income then what comes
next is occupation
after that you have country
and at the last we will work on incur
now when you press next you get back to
the same window so now that we know the
fields that we're working on our next
step is to find the algorithm that best
suits our model
okay so now that we know the fields that
we have to work on our next step is to
find the best fit algorithm for our
model so what we do here is we look at
the list of algorithms that we have but
before that we know that our data our
target value is divided into two classes
so the algorithm that we'll be working
on is a classification algorithm now
azure provides few
classification algorithm like
and decision tree two class booster
decision tree so we'll be working on two
class boosted decision tree because this
gives you a high accuracy rate now let
me give you an idea of why two class
boosted decision tree is taken over all
the other classification algorithm so
what happens in 2 class booster decision
tree is for every node that we have here
the accuracy is calculated and once the
accuracy is above our required accuracy
then only it moves on to the next nodes
so this gives you a height so the
prediction value here becomes more and
more towards the higher side
so that the overall model will give us a
very high accuracy okay so our next step
here is to train the model so on the
search bar again just
type train and under train you can see
there's an option called train model so
drag the train model over the canvas and
connect the two cloud boosted decision
tree with this now you can see that it
says that it requires a value or a data
which is obvious because it's not it
does not have any data to work on so our
next step here is to split the data so
on the search bar when you
find split it gives you an option called
split data when you drag the split data
over your canvas and connect connected
with your column data
it asks you for the split percentage so
you split the data into training and
testing so 80 percent of data gets into
the training model and 20 goes into the
testing model so what we do next is we
connect 80 percent of training data with
the train model but you see there's a
value required this is because the model
is not aware of the column it needs to
train on so what we do here is we go on
launch column selector
and select the column so we need to work
on income column
so when we select column and press enter
we see that the question mark is gone
now our next step is to
find the score of the model so what
score does is it gives you the
prediction value of the model
okay so when you connect your trade
model with the score model you again see
a caution sign here this is because it
does not have idea of what it needs to
test on so you collect your testing data
with your score model
so our last step here is to evaluate the
model so on the search bar when you type
evaluate
you get an option called evaluate model
you drag the model here on the canvas
and connect it with the score model so
your model is now complete now our next
step is to save the model and run it
now once our program is executed click
on evaluate model once you click on
evaluate model and press visualize
a window will appear this shows you the
performance of the model you see that
the accuracy is 79 which is considered
to be good
now let me go through all the other
options you see there is an option
called positive label
and negative level which has been
assigned values of above 50k and below
50 kids respectively now let me tell you
what these values are so this part is
known as a confusion matrix so of all
the values above 50k true positive give
me value that are predicted correctly
and false positive give me value that
are not predicted correctly which means
that six out of all the value that we
have in positive label 666
have been predicted right that is they
have their salary above 50k and 422 have
been predicted wrong similarly they're
out of all the people that we have 840
have been predicted wrongly that if they
have salary of upper 50k but have been
predicted below 50k and 4091 have been
predicted correctly now this is used to
find the accuracy of the model so what
you do here is you sum the true positive
with true negative and divided by false
positive false negative true positive
and true negative and then you multiply
it by 100 and that's how you get your
accuracy now let us go back
and run this service over the net so
when you click on setup web service you
see predictive experiments click on
predictive experiment
now our next step is to connect the web
service input that is the entry point
with the score model
so what it does is once the program is
over the cloud it directly connects to
the score model and shows us the output
so you don't have to go through all the
processes now because the machine is
automatically learning
now you save this
and press run this will execute the
entire model
so once this is done all that is left
with you is to deploy web service so
once you click on deploy web service
it will take you to the dashboard
so you see an option called test once
you click on test
it will take you to a window where it
will ask you for values so let's just
say that i have a value of person age 35
let's say he's working in a government
his education is
bachelor's
then his occupation is manager
this country is us
so once i press next
it will give me the predicted value
telling me that he will be earning 50k
with the precision rate of 0.12
so this is how you make use of machine
learning in azure we are going to talk
about the service as your active
directory so firstly let's ask the most
important question what is azure active
directory now here we're in a situation
where we have two colleagues having a
conversation with each other so one of
them complains that he is finding a hard
time managing multiple user logins at
the same time his friend suggests that
he has a solution that the company start
using as your active directory he says
that with azure ad they'll be able to
handle multiple user logins without any
issue so just like the question in all
our minds the friend asks how is azure
active directory going to help us so to
help you understand let's think about a
scenario you're an employer working for
an organization and you want to use a
particular service in this case sql
database so you're assigned a set of
username and password then you want to
use another service a machine learning
service again you are assigned a
different username and password and
likewise for any number of services that
you want to use so for every service
that you are going to choose you need to
be assigned a new username and password
but this becomes a huge issue for the
administrator as they have to handle a
large number of username and passwords
now if you think about a large
organization where there's more than
thousand people working you can
understand how much of a hassle it's
going to be for the administrator at the
same time it's also a really difficult
thing for you to remember that many
numbers of username and passwords it's
difficult on the user as well and that's
where azure active directory helps now
here's a scenario where we're applying
azure active directory now you're an
employee you want to use a particular
service and you're assigned a single
username and password and with this
username and password you can access all
the services that you want so there's
only one set of username and passwords
that you need to remember you can use
any of the services that you want as
long as the administrator has given you
access to it so what is azure active
directory now azure active directory is
a service that falls under the identity
domain it allows multiple users and is a
cloud-based directory and identity
management service now here's an ideal
scenario you're joining an office newly
the admin helps you sign up to whatever
services you want and you can access
these services anywhere over the cloud
so now let's talk about something
different windows 80 and azure ad now
windows 80 was the previous version of
azure 80. so now we'll talk about why we
needed to change from windows active
directory to azure active directory so
what is windows active directory now
it's an os directory service which
allows you to work with multiple systems
multiple network resources in a unified
manner now the biggest draw when it came
to windows 80 was that it had many
layers now different layers that did
different bits of work so now let's talk
about each of these layers the first
layer is adds or the windows active
directory domain services now each layer
as i said before has a different role to
perform adds allows admin to manage
information relating to user logins and
other details like when they signed up
how much they're using and things like
that the next layer is adls or the azure
data leak storage services this layer is
for allowing you to store any amounts of
data of any type or size then you have
the adfs or the active directory
federation services where you're given a
single option for sign up with which you
get access to all systems and
applications then we have the fourth
layer the adcs or the active directory
and certification services this enables
administrators to customize services and
then be able to manage and issue public
certificates and the final layer is
adrms or the active directory rights
management service and this is used for
data protection now here's where azure
active directory changed the whole game
this means that there's a large number
of layers that administrators need to
take care of now how about there was a
solution for this and as your ad is that
solution as your active directory
integrates all these five layers into
two and these are the windows azure
active directory or the waad where it
combines all the problems when it comes
to identification management which is
almost all file layers taken into one
and the windows azure access control
service enables the federation or the
division of all these services of an
organization
and by division i mean assigning each of
these services to these users so that is
taken care of by the windows as your
access control service hence as your
active directory is able to simplify a
lot of the problems that windows as your
active directory had for example the
application office 365 uses as your
active directory to manage user
identities here's how now you're an
employee who wants to access one of the
office 365 services which could be excel
powerpoint microsoft word or something
like that so you go talk to the
administrator and he gives you access to
these services with the help of a single
username and password now as long as you
have this username and password and the
administrator has given you access to it
you can use any of these services so
who's the service audience who is using
the active directory service now there
are three types of audience when it
comes to azure active directory the
first one is id administrator the second
one application developers and online
customers so the idea administrators
their main emphasis is to ensure that
the sign-in takes place they take care
of all the sign-in procedures they also
solve issues when it comes to
authentication
for example to authenticate a particular
user the problem is solved by the id
administrators then you have application
developers who use these services to
develop applications and with this they
have an easier time developing
applications as all these resources are
easily available you have online
customers who make use of services like
office 365 and other crm services and
have all their demands catered
immediately so now let's have a look at
how we can use azure active directory to
provide access to a particular
individual
so if you log into the azure account
this is what you see or you go into
active directory list of all the people
who are using or have been given
permission to use resources from azure
okay now we're going to create a profile
we need to set up his name which is john
and second name jacob
now for properties we need to determine
the source of authority which is already
active directory so that's fine
we can select a group or add them to a
particular group if we feel like it
now if we add them to a particular group
it means that they have access to all
the resources that everyone in the group
has access to earlier so we'll do that
later
we'll select their directory role or we
can select it here if we need to it
could be user administrator or limited
administrator and now we'll set up a
password we already got one and we'll
create
and that's it we have created a user now
we'll go to their profile
so what we can see here is that you have
access to every bit of detail related to
this account so you have the name your
first name the username the object id
job info everything you can even have
other details like how often they've
signed in when did they sign up you can
check their password you can reset the
password delete their account and so
much more
now we can even add a directory role
which we saw earlier and now let's add
this person to the admin group so you
know he gets access to all the services
those people have access to and select
that's it we've added them now the other
things that you can see here there are
applications licenses devices these are
all restrictions you can add or remove
like which device you can use the system
through or with and stuff like that so
that's it and with that we have created
a user and given him access to certain
services we are going to talk about
another important as your service as
your data factory now why should you be
interested in data factory now let's
consider a scenario so here we have two
colleagues having a conversation with
each other and they say that the data
that they're generating from their
applications or products is increasing
exponentially now considering that this
data is coming from a number of
different products it'll be a bit of a
task to analyze and store all of this
data so he wonders how they're going to
manage that his friend suggests that
they use azure's data factory now what
does azure's data factory actually do
first it stores data with the help of
the data link storage now any kind of
data can be stored in the data lake
storage then you can analyze the data
you can transform the data with the help
of pipelines and you can publish the
organized data you can visualize the
data with third-party applications like
apache spark or hadoop as well now what
exactly is data factory so now let's
have a look at what exactly is data
factory now data factory falls under the
identity domain of services in the azure
catalog and is a cloud-based integration
service basically what it does is it
works on your data it stores your data
it orchestrates and automates the
movement or transformation of data it
works heavily on the data that you store
now let's see how it actually works or
how the flow of its processes are
firstly we have the input data set which
is nothing but the data that you have
within your data store the one that you
need processed then you pass this data
through a pipeline now what does a
pipeline do a pipeline basically
performs an operation on the data that
transforms it which could be anything
from just data movement or some data
transformation now data transformation
is possible with the help of usql some
stored procedures or hype now after this
is done you get an output dataset now
this output data set will contain data
that is in a structured form because
it's already been transformed and made
structured in the pipeline stage then it
is given into linked services like azure
data lake block storage or sql now what
it does is these store information that
is very important when it comes to
connecting to an external source now
this is you know if you wanted an
example you know how in an sql server
you need to mention the source and
destination of your data now for example
consider an sql server so you need a
connection string so that you can
connect to an external device you need
to mention the stores and the
destination of your data this is how the
link services work and finally you need
a gateway now a gateway basically
connects your on-premises data to the
cloud so you do need a client installed
on your on-premises system so that you
can connect to the azure cloud and
finally you have the cloud here what
happens is your data can be analyzed or
visualized with a number of different
analytical softwares like apache spark r
hadoop and so on so all this time i've
been mentioning that data lake is a very
important part when it comes to azure
data factory's proper functioning so now
let's talk about what exactly is data
lake now data lake is a data storage or
a file system which is highly scalable
and distributed it is located in the
cloud and works with multiple analytics
frameworks which is external frameworks
like hadoop apache and so on so now
let's have a look at it so first you
have your output data set which is data
from the mobile video web social media
so much more it is sent into the azure
data lake store and then it is provided
two external frameworks like r apache
and spark so that they can be worked on
now there are two main concepts when it
comes to data lake storage so one of
them is storage and the other one is
analytics now storage is of unlimited
size it can be petabytes terabytes
gigabytes and so much more it shows a
wide variety of data it could be
unstructured or structured data and it
can store really large files and another
concept when it comes to data lake is
analytics now how it works now here are
two examples of how analytics works when
it comes to data lake now when it comes
to analytics you can monitor and
diagnose real-time data for example data
that you're getting from vehicles or
buildings these can be used to optimize
how they work respond to certain events
or generate alerts in case something
goes wrong then you can also identify
fraudulent transactions on your credit
card or you can identify the correct the
geographical position of your card
perhaps monitor how many transactions
have been taking place on that card and
so on so now we're going to have a look
at how we can use the azure data factory
to move data from an sql database to a
blob storage on the cloud so here's what
we're going to do so first off to make a
database what you're going to need a
software known as ssms so you can find
it on google it's called you just need
to google it ssms the first thing you
can take here
and there you have it so you just need
to click here and download the file so
we i've already downloaded the file so
basically this is used to create a
database which we'll be transferring to
the blob storage so this will take about
depending on your computer speed pretty
long or little to no time i've already
downloaded it the process is very simple
just directly go on saying yes yes and
finally once installation is done here's
what we're going to do we should go into
the dashboard of microsoft azure we need
to create a data warehouse so we'll go
into all resources create a source
go to database
and select sql data warehouse there we
have it now it's very important that you
remember the names of the service of
everything that you're going to write
here because each of these become very
important later on so i've already set
up a possible set of names
youtube
it's free trial the source is already
created a blank database the server we
need to create a new one so
that we'll name it as youtube server
youtube
as the server admin login
the password as
all right the location does not matter
okay that's done now here the server is
done
and here we need to change how much you
want the lowest i mean how much
computation you want how much did
workload how important your workload is
so we'll put it at the lowest since we
don't require much we'll apply the rest
is normal and great
so now we're creating an sql data
warehouse so we'll wait so now the
deployment is done so we'll go to the
notification and go to the resource here
now this is done so we'll go to the ssms
which i've already opened here and then
go here
and copy this paste it here seo
authentication login which details we
have already stored here which is add
when youtube admin and the password
which is also given there
right
go to options we go to the database name
which is youtube
everything else is there
you need to change it to tcp ip
and connect
we sign in
we'll add the password
can we sign in now
right
so now that that's completed you can see
that this is what will pop up so this is
the name of the server we've given as
you saw earlier you go to databases and
here you have the youtube database that
we just created right click this and add
a new query
i already have a code for this program
it's a very simple program so
copying and pasting this
now if you need the code for this
program let us know in the comments
below it's very simple what we're doing
is creating a table called demo tab with
first name clark kent and last name is
bruce wayne and the table that's created
will have these two rows so now we're
going to execute this there you have it
two rows have been affected so now let's
have a look at our table
execute this line
and there you go the table's here so now
that this is done we're going back into
azure
back and we need to create a storage
account so that's where the story where
the blob storage is going to happen so
we're going to storage accounts and
click on add so here it's a free trial
resource group is youtube
storage account name is
the
store
that's all okay u.s performance is
standard
general purpose
you can do locally since we don't need
to be very reliable at least for this
one advance this fine
view and create
that's done and we create now we'll wait
for the deployment to finish
and that's it the deployment is done so
we'll go to the resource
and go to blobs so this is where the
storage is happening we need to create a
blob
simply
which does not exist and okay
it has been created
now for the next bit we need to create
the data factory now so
we go to
all services search for data factory
we press add
so here we'll
free trial use existing
which we have youtube east us and create
so now we've created a new data factory
now we'll wait while it's being deployed
so now it's created so we'll go here and
here we click on copy data and this
opens up
okay we'll name it
our description run once now
once now okay
right so we press next so we need to
connect to a data source so
so what you need to do is select a
secure as your sql data warehouse so
once again you could previous
here we select your skill data warehouse
go here
search for
source
is your subscription free trial here
youtube server
and the databases youtube you also need
to provide your username and password
i've saved it here
youtube admin
right
okay now we can select the table which
is demo tab next
next
and now for our destination so where are
we going to connect this to we're going
to azure blob storage next
destination
javascript free trial
and simply store
now we need to name our
name our storage path
next
all of this can be
passed on
here's what we're doing it copying
whatever is inside this to the azure
blob storage that's what's happening
right now
all of that is set
and
next
it's validating and we'll wait now
it's registering connections creating
database and in the end it's creating a
pipeline
so you can monitor the pipeline from
here if you feel like it
here's what we're going to find so
here's the
here's a visual representation of what's
happening
it's being copied into the blob storage
now let's have a look if it's actually
worked out we go to our database we'll
go into
storage accounts simply store
go to blobs
you've created a new one
and there you have it
so based on the container that you've
named there it's created a new one here
so actually i earlier created the name
called simply blob but as you can see
here as long as you name a container
you'll create a folder inside which
you'll find your particular thing that
you copied
and that's it you've copied data
similarly you can do a number of
multiple operations on this container on
the on the pipeline you just created
with the data factory and that's that
today we are going to learn about the
azure virtual machine so without further
ado let's get started
before getting in depth let me tell you
what's in store for today first i'll be
talking a little about azure next i'll
start off by explaining the azure
virtual machine
then i'll be focusing on few benefits of
azure virtual machine
moving forward i'll be going in depth
with the azir watching machine
components and finally we will be
looking into a demo on azure virtual
machine all of us may have heard of
azure at one point of time but what is
azure let me explain
azir is a cloud service created by
microsoft for building testing and
managing applications and many services
through the microsoft data centers the
azure hosts web applications over the
internet with the help of these data
centers
azir is very flexible it gives an option
to have the functionality as required
you can pay as you consume switch to
azure and accommodate the business
fluctuations there is no need to worry
about the infrastructure all the time
azir is very reliable and has 24 7 tech
support
azure offers pay-as-you-go pricing and
hence it is very cost effective
staying online all the time ensures
customers or users trust azure supports
backup and disaster recovery tools
now we know what azure is and its key
benefits let's now move on to azure
virtual machine
before that let's consider a scenario
ratio had to host 10 virtual machines at
once per project there was an issue when
her computer ram was not compatible with
the instances
the computer ram was only 8 gb and the
instances that required were 10 gb
then she says i wish there is a service
that's cost effective and also provides
extra ram memory one of a colleague
heard this and he comes up with an idea
he says can we use azir virtual machine
it has a pay-as-you-go pricing and has
this for storage
you can pay for what you use and create
any number of instances with high
storage capacity
also if any technical difficulty arises
you can easily retrieve the files
through the backup server
so now she's happy and she wants to know
more about azure washing machine
azure virtual machine is one of the wide
range of services that azio offers to
create your instance a virtual machine
is a computer file typically called an
image which behaves like an actual
computer it runs in a window giving the
user the same experience on a virtual
machine as they have on the host
operating system itself
multiple virtual machines can run
simultaneously on the same physical
computer each virtual machine provides
its own hardware like cpus memories and
other devices
as your virtual machine offers a high
range of flexibility and it maintains
the physical hardware that runs on it
let me explain some of the benefits of
azir virtual machine
first we have easy development and test
azure virtual machine has a quick and
easy way to configure the computer that
is required to code and test an
application
next agility and scale azure virtual
machine is agile and the ability to
clone and spin up multiple instances of
the same virtual machine allows us to
scale services and applications rapidly
efficiently and very cost effectively
azure virtual machine provides enhanced
performance demands for applications can
fluctuate so you pay for the virtual
machines you need and shut down the
unnecessary ones to save the cost
azure virtual machines provide extended
data center and can be easily connected
to an organization's network it is easy
to set up your redundant infrastructure
on azure and azure provides a full
disaster recovery site at a fraction of
the cost furthermore let me explain
azure virtual machine components in
details virtual machine comes under the
compute domain of azure it also offers
various services like availability sets
snapshots disks images and many other
services like hosts
virtual machine can be clubbed with
other services like disk images
availability sets hosts and many more so
the first component and the most
important component is the operating
system the operating system creates
connections to the remote desktop
session host there are many operating
systems available like ubuntu red hat
linux windows server sent os you can
also set the operating disk size so that
the memory is not wasted the next
component is disks azure virtual
machines use attached virtual hard disks
for storage there are two types of
virtual hard disks first is an image
there is a template for creation of new
azure virtual machine then we have disks
it is a bootable virtual hard disk all
durable disks are backed up by page
blobs in azure storage therefore the
disks inherit the benefits of blob
storage high availability durability and
many more the disks are mounted as
drives on the vm the next component is
virtual network
many components operate the virtual
machines in a scalable and secure manner
virtual networks could include equipment
such as separate network spaces for
internet facing and backend servers load
balancers firewalls and more many of
these components are deployed into an
azure virtual network azure virtual
network provides many features such as
subnet ip address load balancer and
network security group
another important component of azure
virtual machine is availability sets if
in case there's a slight chance there
could be a failure in physical servers
then these come into picture so in case
of such failure the azure platform will
migrate the failed virtual machine to a
healthy host to reconstitute the vm it
is highly recommended to deploy at least
two instances of the virtual machine and
virtual machines placed on an
availability set perform identical set
of functionalities
now that we know what azir virtual
machine is let's look into the demo in
this demo first we are going to create a
virtual machine connect it and then
create a web server and modify the web
server and finally launch the web
application so let's go ahead into the
demo now so the first step is to log
into microsoft azure with your
credentials
now let's click on virtual machines and
create a new one
so i can put add
and
you can use the subscription you want
either pay as you go pricing or free
the sales group will create a new one
that is payroll
one
okay
virtual machine we can create i'm gonna
use vm
web
zero zero one
and then region i'll be using east us
then image i'll be using windows server
r2 data center
size i'll be using b1 ms
select
username
[Music]
and then password of your choice
and then i'm gonna allow selected ports
and choose rdp 3389
and next
so ost step i'll be using standard hdd
and then
yeah next
so i can see a default virtual network
and a default submit in public ip as
well as default
then next
you can allow for auto shutdown but
again it's entirely your choice
i'm going to select an extension to
install and i'm going to install
microsoft anti-malware
create okay
i'm going to create a few tags now let's
go ahead with it
so i've created five tags now review
plus create
okay so everything seems good let's
create now
so the deployment is going to take a few
minutes let's wait for it
okay so that's done now let's go to
virtual machine and see our watching
machine
okay so it's been deployed
now let's get into the virtual machine
and copy the ip address
then hit windows plus r
and open mstsc
and
paste the ip address and connect
let's use a different account
you have to use the administrator
account that we've created before with
the same password
click ok
now the remote desktop session host
opens
the next step is to click on server
manager
and add rules and features
click on next
select roll base of feature based
installation and click on next
then select the watching machine you've
created and next
and then we are going to select
web server iis next
sorry
next okay so it's already installed my
computer but you have to install this
then let's close this
and open internet explorer
let's type in
http
localhost
yeah so now you can see the default was
opening
let's minimize this
and let's try it here
here we have just put the ip address
i think there's an issue
okay so let's add an input port
networking select networking and add
inbound port
let's move 480
and add
okay so it's added now let's go and
refresh it
now we can see the default web browser
opening
so the next step is to modify the web
browser let's go ahead with that go back
to your remote session host
let's go file
explorer so certain folders are created
in the c drive let's open that
it would be
under
i network
so this is where the default brush is
coming from now let's make a new text
document
open that and put
hello
welcome
to this
demo
by
simply
lawn
save it
close it let's rename this as
index
dot ht
so this is a text document so we need to
change that
okay let's remove this
okay that's done
now let's go back to our internet
explorer and hit f5
let's refresh this
let's try one
yep so it's done
now let's go back to the previous
browser and try let's refresh
yeah that's done
hi guys a very warm welcome
so today's uh topic is azure virtual
network tutorial
let's look into what's in it for you
so we would be covering why is azure
virtual network important
what is azure virtual network is
benefits of using the azure virtual
network
components of our show virtual network
that includes the subnet routing network
security group
why these components are required to be
created in the virtual network and how
to launch an instance within the
azure vnet or the virtual network
and then we will be seeing one demo in
which we'll create azure virtual
networks subnets and network security
groups
so first of all let's look into why is
azure virtual network important
so why azure virtual network is required
so somewhere far away at an office a
company was struggling with few
challenges
the company got a bigger projects which
lead to the following challenges that
includes poor network connectivity
time consuming process in building
network topologies could not divert
network traffic to its destination on
time so these were a couple of
challenges the company was facing so
the employees thought that what could be
the possible solution to these
challenges
and then we require the azure virtual
network in that case
so first of all let's understand what is
azure virtual network is
an azure vnet or a virtual network
represents your network or environment
to run vms and applications in the cloud
when it is created the services and
virtual machines within the network
interact securely with each over the
internet so virtual network you can
consider it as a virtual cloud which is
basically kind of a cloud
space virtually assigned
to the users or or to the organization
which they can dedicatedly use for their
purpose
so for example if you have to create
some uh instances or virtual machines
onto the azure cloud
and you want to connect it
with the on-prem servers for example
then you might require the virtual
network in that case let's assume that
those instances that are created in the
virtual network
require the
range of ip addresses that you want to
allocate to them and that is something
you can customize using the azure
virtual network
how do you want that the traffic should
be routed
to your instances in the virtual network
how the firewall securities should be
applied
everything the end user can control in
the virtual network so it seems like
that you are working in your own data
center ideally you would be working on
to the azure cloud
using the virtual network
now what are the advantages of using the
azure virtual network so couple of them
are it provides an isolated environment
for your application so as i said that
it feels like it seems like that you are
working in your on-prem environment that
means within your data center but
ideally it is a virtual space that is
allocated to you which is a kind of an
isolated environment and that is
specifically designed
for your tasks and the activities
a generally a subnet in a v-net can
access the public internet by default so
we create a subnet inside the virtual
network which can access
the public internet so there is a public
network connectivity that is enabled in
the virtual net so that a subnet which
will be created in the vnet can be
accessed
traffic can be easily filtered from
different resources so you can have some
control list defined you can have some
security groups created and how do you
want to allow the traffic onto the
servers or the application that is
something which you can control it is a
highly secure network and the security
groups and the policies are basically
implemented by the end user so you can
design how the security should be
implemented high network connectivity so
you have a higher bandwidth as compared
to the normal internet connection you
might be having in the data center
compared to that you use the azure
network only which gives you the higher
network connectivity
it builds sophisticated network
topologies in a simple
manner and which is easily manageable
troubleshooting issues that we would
encounter
now what are the components of azure
virtual network
one of them is the subnets
then you have routing
then you have network security groups
now what do we mean by subnets
the subnet is one of the
major or a prime important component in
the virtual network so what you have to
do is first obviously you would be
creating a virtual network
inside that you can create the subnets
subnets you can consider it a logical
partitioning
virtual partitioning inside the
virtual network
lets user segment the virtual network
into one or more
sub networks
for example let's assume that you're
working in an organization and in the
organization there are different
departments for every department there
should be some set of ip addresses that
you want to allocate to
the machines that the employees are
using
or
all the department should be isolated
that means they should have their own
network ids and the network addresses
allocated to their machines
and in that case what you would do is
you would create the subnets and the
subnet ids that would be allocated to
those departments
these sub networks can be separated
logically and each subnet consists of a
server so what you do is when you create
a subnet you can you can create a server
or an instance inside that subnet and
how do you want to give an access to
that instance depends on criteria or the
requirement
hence a subnet can further be divided
into two parts one as the public subnet
and the other one as the private subnet
these are the naming conventions of the
subnet then how do you want to give the
internet connectivity depends on
how the public subnet should be
interacting with the internet and for
the private subnet as the name suggests
that the internet is blocked so that
means it is completely isolated in the
virtual network
the private instances though if you want
that any instance created in the private
subnet should have the internet
connectivity or an access you can
primarily go with the nat gateways in
that case which is a network address
translation or kind of a translator
which converts the private to public and
vice versa
and that would actually enable the
internet connectivity to your subnets
then in the public instances they can
directly access the instance as the name
suggests public instances that public
subnets that means they have the direct
internet connectivity
next component is routing and
the routing is primarily a routing rules
you can say that are applied
and those are actually applied to
the routers only so since on the cloud
we cannot have a direct router access
and hence using the routing as a
component we can define some routing
rules which are directly applied to the
router and the infrastructure
it delivers the data by choosing a
suitable path from source to destination
for each subnet azure virtual network
automatically routes traffic and creates
a route table when you create a virtual
network
automatically a route table is created
and that
basically is required to route the
traffic and that can be used by every
subnet that doesn't mean that you only
have to create a single route table in
the virtual network you can have
multiple route tables also created which
can be associated with different subnets
as well then you have the network
security groups
it is kind of a firewall that protects
the virtual machine by limiting the
network traffic
it restricts inbound and outbound
network traffic depending upon the
destination ipa transport
and the protocol so it is basically
the network security group sits on the
instances
and
or virtual machines and
they basically
define that how the traffic should be
reaching to the ports onto the virtual
machine so how do you want to open up
the ports and for which ip addresses you
want to open up the ports that is
something
the end user or the administrator has to
specify our design so they act as a kind
of a firewall rules only that protects
the virtual machines
so how to launch an instance using azure
vnet
so first of all you have to create a
virtual network so virtual network act
as a container for subnets so first
thing is that you would be creating a
virtual network then you would be
creating
subnets
which are considered as a subset within
the virtual network
so cloud instance is included in the
subnet so first v-nets are created then
the subnets are created and then you
configure the properties in the security
group
have a look at this in detail
now with respect to the virtual network
what you need to do is you have to
create a virtual network in the azure
cloud
then you have to create subnets into
each virtual network which is kind of a
subset of a virtual network so you can
create one as a public subnet the other
one as a private subnet for example
now you have to assign instances so when
you create an instance you have to
specify that what is the virtual network
for which virtual network you are
creating an instance within that virtual
network you have to select that on which
particular subnet the instance should be
created
and then connect instance to a relevant
network security group so attach your
network security group to the instances
and based on the properties or the rules
that are defined in the network security
group that will be applied to the
instances within the subnets finally
configure the properties in the network
security and set the policies
as a result you will be able to launch
your instance on azure within the
virtual network
now we will be seeing one demo that how
we can create azure virtual network
subnets and the network security group
so just be there
to watch our demo on
the azure virtual network in today's
session i would be showing how you can
create the virtual networks onto the
azure
and for that you require the credentials
on microsoft azure and here you can see
on my screen that i have already logged
in into
the azure console
now what you need to do is in order to
search virtual network you can
type
and search in the dashboard
in the search bar
with respect to the virtual
networks and here you can find
uh the virtual network and the gateways
so what you need to do is you just have
to click on the virtual networks and
then it will give you the options
to add the components inside the virtual
networks so let me first open up
the virtual network
right
now
in theory we discussed that the virtual
network comprises of multiple components
and sub components so primarily is that
first you have to create a virtual
network
then you have to assign the ipv4 cidr
block to the virtual network
and then you create the subnets inside
the network which is a subset of the
virtual network along with that you
define the routing rules
and
likewise you create
the instances inside the subnets that
will be part of the virtual networks
so that's what we are going to do uh in
this demo so i would be adding up a new
virtual network so you can see here
there are already two virtual networks
that have been added one is the demo
vnet which is by default so when you
created the azure credentials
the demo virtual network was already
created by the azure so that it can
provide you the
default settings
and then the test one has been created
by me and uh that's the customized one
or you can say a non-default virtual
network
so i'll i'm going to add another
v-net and
would define
the name to it
so let's wait for
the details to appear so here you have
to define the virtual network to create
obviously we will be going with the free
trial only
and then you have to create a resource
group so
what is a resource group it is primarily
a collection of resources that share the
same lifecycle permissions and the
policies so if you have a resource group
created you can use it otherwise you can
create a new resource group so i already
have one that is the demo one i would be
using that
in the instance details you have to
specify the name of the virtual network
so
these are certain
parameters that you have to go with
while defining the name so let's say i
put something like
test
v-net
as the virtual network that i want to
create and that is you have to select a
region where you want to get that
created
so these are the available regions that
you can select i would go with
us east
east u.s only and then we have to define
the ip addresses also
see so in the ip addresses uh the cidr
blocks are allocated to the virtual
networks and that becomes a fixed ip
address for that vnet
so what you can do is you can specify a
range of ip addresses now whenever we
talk about a virtual network and the ip
addresses we primarily focus on the
private ips only so this is the private
ip that we are actually
talking about so i can reserve some
ip address cidr
for our vnet and that is the range of
40.0.0.0 16.
i'm going to reserve so now we'll create
one subnet and we'll name that subnet so
as we discussed that subnets are the sub
components of
the v net
so here you can see we have already
created one
subnet with the name public subnet so
likewise we can add another subnet also
and
let's name it to something like uh demo
subnet right and the subnet should have
the ip address range and that ip address
range should be part of the we need only
with inventing uh so same subnet address
range you would be defining in the
subnet as well so that will be forty dot
zero dot one dot or we can select two
dot zero
slash twenty four
the rest of the things uh would be
default uh we are not attaching any
route table as of now so just click on
ok
and here you can see
that the subnet is created
now once the subnet is created now we
are going to create a virtual machine
inside that subnet
and for that we will go to the search
bar
and here we'll type
virtual machines
now we'll create a virtual machine in
the same v-net that is the test v-net
and inside the demo subnet
so that our virtual machine gets the
private ip address from
the subnet that has been created in the
vnet itself so what you need to do is
you have to open up the virtual machines
click on add
and here
you should add a new virtual machine
so you should select the name of the
virtual machine and
the network details
where we would be defining
the v-net as well as the subnet where
the virtual machine should be created
so in the subscription we'll go with the
free tail and in the resource group
we'll go with the demo that has already
been created we'll put a virtual machine
name
something like
test
vm
and the rest of the things will be
default
so we'll quickly skip the disk check
also
now in the networking
we would be selecting
the test vnet as
our virtual network
and in the subnet we would be selecting
the demo subnet
so that is the recently one added in the
test we net and we want that our virtual
machine should be part of that subnet
only
now obviously since we are creating a
virtual machine so it should be part of
it should have the public ip also
assigned since uh from the public
network we need to access those virtual
machines so we'll keep it enabled right
and the next
would be the default settings that we
are going to proceed with
so let's review all the configurations
and then
create your virtual machine
so here you can see that our virtual
machine has been created validation has
been passed and it takes couple of
minutes to get that updated so let's
wait for a few more minutes so that our
virtual machine is ready and primarily
what we want to look into is that our
virtual machine is created in a correct
v-net and it gets
the private ip address from the subnet
that has been part of the
v-net which has been defined in the
creation of a virtual machine so let's
wait for a couple of more minutes and
we'll look into the status of the main
now you can see here our test virtual
machine has been created now what we
wanted to look into is that our virtual
machine is created in a correct
subnet or not and that is something
which we can validate by checking the
private ip address so it got the private
ip from the range of
the ip address that we have specified in
the subnet now in order to access this
particular virtual machine you have to
use the public ip since
since we have to access it from the
internet so
from the private ip this virtual machine
will not be accessible
so that's the reason that when we
created a virtual machine we allocated
the public ip address also for this
instance
so that is with respect to
the virtual network and the
demonstration on it and how we can
create a v-net and the sub-components of
the v-net how they are associated or
interlinked with each other and that
actually creates a kind of an isolated
environment on the
public cloud which gives you the
understanding that you can work into
just like an on-prem environment and
with that we have come to the end of
this video on aws and ask your full
course for 2022. i hope you found it
useful and entertaining please ask any
questions you have concerning the topics
covered in this video in the comment
section below
our experts will assist you in
addressing your problems thank you for
watching stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn nerd up and get certified
click here
you